WE'LL CALL THE
COMMITTEE OF HIGHER EDUCATION
TO ORDER OUT WITH ABSENCE OF A
QUORUM WE WILL START AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE. SO WE GET A CORE.
SO WELCOME TO THE SECOND BILL
HEARING OF THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER
EDUCATION COMMITTEE WHETHER YOU
ARE HERE IN PERSON WATCHING
VIRTUALLY OR ON THE PHONE I AM
GRATEFUL YOU HAVE JOINED US
HERE. ON THE CALIFORNIA STATE
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER FLOOR. PLEASE
NOTE THE FOLLOWING ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO HAS BEEN
APPOINTED BY MISTER SPEAKER TO
REPLACE THE VACANCY TODAY FOR
TODAY'S HEARING. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUBIO WELCOME
TO TODAY'S HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE HERE. FOR REQUEST OF
THE CHAIR FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN A.
B. TWELVE SIXTEEN RIGHT
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RUDY SALAS HAS
BEEN PULLED FROM THIS COMMITTEE
HEARING AND ADDED TO THE
HEARING ON APRIL TWENTY SECOND.
I WILL NOW GO OVER SOME KEY
ELEMENTS OF THE STRUCTURE OF
TODAY'S HEARING. DUE TO THE
ONGOING PANDEMIC WE ARE
PRACTICING PHYSICAL DISTANCING
IN THIS HEARING AND THROUGHOUT
THE CAPITOL BUILDINGS. WE ARE
ONLY ABLE TO HAVE A LIMITED
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WATCH AND
PARTICIPATE. IN THE HEARING IN
PERSON. WE HAVE A FEW DIFFERENT
OPTIONS FOR WITNESSES TESTIMONY
TODAY. FOR THOSE PRESENT TODAY
ON THE CHAMBER FLOOR AND IN THE
GALLERY WE ARE HAVING OF
PHYSICALLY DISTANT IN PERSON
HEARING. IN THIS SPACE WE CAN
ONLY ACCOMMODATE MEMBERS OF
THIS COMMITTEE AND THE AUTHORS
A MINIMAL CONTINGENT OF STAFF
AND A LIMITED NUMBER OF THE
PUBLIC AND MEDIA SO WE CAN
MAINTAIN SIX FEET OF SPACING.
THERE ARE ALSO STRICT PHYSICAL
DISTANCING PROTOCOLS FOR THE
PUBLIC TO ENTER AND LEAVE THE
CAPITAL. AND FOR THOSE HERE
TODAY IN THE HEARING. IF ANY
MEMBER OF THE PUBLIC IN THE
ROOM WOULD LIKE TO TESTIFY IN
THE BILL PLEASE RAISE YOUR HAND
AND I WILL ASK YOU TO APPROACH
THE MICROPHONE. AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME. I WOULD ASK
THAT THE PUBLIC NOT TOUCH THE
MICROPHONE. YOU CAN EXIT THE
HEARINGS ONCE YOU FINISH
TESTIFYING A RETURN TO YOUR
SEAT. PLEASE BE SURE TO OBSERVE
PHYSICAL DISTANCING UPON
LEAVING THE CAPITAL INCLUDING
LIMITING THE ELEVATOR USED TO
ONE PERSON AT A TIME. IN
ADDITION TO BEING ABLE TO
TESTIFY FROM INSIDE THE HEARING
ROOM WE HAVE SOME BILL
WITNESSES MAKING USE OF OUR
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING
ROOMS WHICH ARE LOCATED HERE IN
THE CAPITAL. THOSE WITNESSES
WILL APPEAR ON THE SCREEN SO
MEMBERS CAN WATCH THEIR
TESTIMONY LIVE. FROM OUTSIDE OF
THE HEARING ROOM AND ALSO ASK
QUESTIONS OF THESE WITNESSES.
THERE MAY BE A SLIGHT DELAY
FROM THE STREAM FROM THE
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCING ROOM
SO I ASK FOR YOUR PATIENCE. WE
WILL ALSO BE USING THE A. T.
AND T. MODERATED TELEPHONE
SERVICE THROUGH WHICH ANY
WITNESS CAN TESTIFY ON A BILL.
THERE MAY ALSO BE A SLIGHT
DELAY THERE SO AGAIN I ASK FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. THE PUBLIC TOLL
FREE NUMBER FOR THIS HEARING IS
ONE EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN SIX NINE
TWO. EIGHT NINE FIVE SEVEN AND
THE ACCESS CODE IS TWO FOUR
TWO. SIX TWO THREE SEVEN. YOU
CAN ALSO FIND THE NUMBER ON THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE WEBSITE. A. H. E. D.
DOT ASSEMBLY DOT C. A. DOT GOV
AS WELL AS ON YOUR TV OR
MONITOR SCREEN. IF YOU'RE
CALLING IN PLEASE PLAN TO DO SO
AS THE AUTHORED THE BILL YOUR
TESTIFYING ON IS BEGINNING
THEIR BILL PRESENTATION. THE
OPERATOR ON THE LINE WILL GIVE
YOU INSTRUCTIONS ON HOW TO BE
PLACED IN THE QUEUE. BASED ON
WHETHER YOU SUPPORT OR OPPOSE
THE BILL. IF YOU'RE CALLING IN
PLEASE ELIMINATE ALL BACKGROUND
NOISE. INCLUDING MUTING YOUR
LIVE STREAM BROADCAST AND YOUR
SMART DEVICES TO REDUCE THE
SOUND DISTORTION. PLEASE BE
SURE TO MUTE YOUR PHONE WHEN
YOU'RE NOT SPEAKING. PLEASE
ALSO BE ADVISED THAT IF YOU ARE
LEAD WITNESS PROVIDING
TESTIMONY FOR AGAINST THE BILL
YOU WILL REMAIN ON A LIVE LINE
AND WILL NEED TO MEET YOURSELF.
UNTIL YOU'RE CALLED ON TO
SPEAK. YOU HAVE ANY PROBLEMS
WITH THE MODERATED PHONE
SERVICE PLEASE CALL THE
COMMITTEE OFFICE AT. NINE ONE
SIX THREE ONE NINE THREE NINE
SIX SO AND THE COMMITTEE STAFF
WILL DO THEIR BEST TO ASSIST
YOU. PLEASE NOTE THAT WE ARE
ACCEPTING WRITTEN TESTIMONY.
THROUGH THE POSITION LETTER
PORTAL ON THE COMMITTEES WEST
WEBSITE. ADDITIONALLY PLEASE
NOTE THAT THE GUIDELINES FOR
BILLS HEARD IN HIS COMMITTEE IS
TO ALLOW TESTIMONY FROM TO LEAD
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. AND TO
LEAD WITNESSES AND OPPOSITION
TO SPEAK FOR NO MORE THAN TWO
MINUTES EACH. STAKEHOLDER
GROUPS AND ENTITIES THAT ARE
NEITHER IN SUPPORT OR IN IT IN
OPPOSITION WILL BE ALLOWED TO
GIVE TESTIMONY FOR NO MORE THAN
TWO MINUTES WHEN I CALL FOR
TWEETERS. THE MEASURE HAS MORE
THAN TWO ENTITIES IN THE
TWEENER CATEGORY ONLY TWO WILL
BE ALLOWED TO SPEAK FOR TWO
MINUTES EACH. PLEASE NOTE THAT
BECAUSE ANOTHER COMMITTEE WILL
HOLD A HEARING IN THIS CHAMBER
THIS AFTERNOON. TWO DAYS HIGHER
EDUCATION HERE IT HAS A HARD
STOP TYING. OF NO LATER THAN
ONE TWENTY. FOUR WHEN WE
MESSAGER. THIS WILL ALLOW THE
NECESSARY COVERT NINETEEN.
COMPLIANT SANITATION MEASURES
TO TAKE PLACE BEFORE THE NEXT
HEARING. THANK YOU FOR BEARING
BEARING WITH US AS WE IMPEMENT
METHODS TO CONTINUE TO SERVE
THE PEOPLE OF CALIFORNIA. WHILE
ALSO BEING MINDFUL AND
RESPECTFUL OF THE PUBLIC HEALTH
CONCERNS WE ALL FACE. FOR THE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
THE CHAMBER MEMBERS IF YOU'D
LIKE TO RESPOND TO A ROLL CALL
ASK A QUESTION OR PROVIDE A
COMMENT. I WILL NEED YOU TO
RAISE YOUR MICROPHONE SO STAFF
CAN ACTIVATED WHEN YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK. ALSO A
PLEASE IF YOU WOULD STAND UP
FACE THE MICROPHONE WAS
SPEAKING TO ENSURE YOUR VOICE
IS AUDIBLE AND COULD BE
RECORDED. FOR AUTHORS OF BILLS
UP TODAY. EACH MEMBER PRESENTED
WILL BE PROVIDE AN OPENING AND
CLOSING STATEMENTS HERE TO LEAD
WITNESSES WILL BE ANNOUNCED BY
THE CHAIR AS I PREVIOUSLY
STATED THEY WILL HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO PROVIDE. TESTIMONY
BEFORE WE PROCEED WITH OUR
FIRST AUTHOR. WILL TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. DO WE HAVE A
POOR OKAY SO WE WILL FIRST
ESTABLISH A QUORUM MADAM
SECRETARY BUTTE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. MEDINA PRESENT CHOI.
ARAMBULA BLOOM GABRIEL IRWIN
KILEY LEVINE. LOW RUBIO.
SANTIAGO BALLADARES. WE HAVE A
QUORUM THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MADAM SECRETARY SO WE WILL
BEFORE PROCEEDING TO THE FIRST
AUTHOR WE WILL TAKE UP THE
CONSENT CALENDAR WE HAVE THREE
BILLS ON CONSENT. THEY ARE THE
FOLLOWING FILE ITEM FIVE AB.
ONE ZERO ZERO TWO. AS AMENDED
FILE ITEM SEVEN AB THREE NINETY
SIX AND FILE ITEM FIFTEEN A. B.
ELEVEN THIRTEEN. CAN I HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. MOVED BY DR
ARAMBULA SECOND BY MISTER
BLOOM. WE HAVE A FIRST AND A
SECOND A MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. MEDINA HI MEDINA
HI CHOI CHOI I ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM. BLOOM I GOT
IT TO GABRIEL IRWIN. KILEY
LEVINE. LEVINE I LOW RUBIO
RUBIO I SANTIAGO BALLADARES.
BALLADARES I'D- BUT SEVEN ZERO.
SEVEN ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- WE WILL
HEAR BILLS AND FILE ORDER
BEGINNING WITH FILE ITEM. A. B.
FILE ITEM ONE A. B. SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE. MR BERMAN. WHEN YOU'RE
READY YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES AND
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR YOUR THOUGHTFUL
ANALYSIS WHICH HIGHLIGHTS BOTH
THE PREVALENCE OF BASIC NEEDS
AND SECURITY IN THE ACT IMPACT
OF THE PANDEMIC ON STUDENT
BASIC NEEDS WHICH I WON'T
REPEAT. I AM HAPPY TO ACCEPT
THE COMMITTEE SUGGESTED
AMENDMENT ALSO INCLUDED IN THE
ANALYSIS COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE
STEPPING UP TO MEET THE BASIC
NEEDS OF THEIR STUDENTS THROUGH
FOOD PANTRIES HOUSING RELATED
EFFORTS AND OTHER SERVICES AND
RESOURCES. HOWEVER FINDING
THESE RESOURCES OFTEN INCLUDES
NAVIGATING DISCONNECTED SYSTEMS
THAT CAN BE CONFUSING FOR
STUDENTS THEREFORE EIGHTY SEVEN
SEVENTY FIVE WHICH IS VERY
SIMILAR TO MY AB TWENTY THREE
EIGHTY EIGHT FROM LAST YEAR
WOULD PROVIDE A COORDINATED AND
INTEGRATED APPROACH TO MEET
STUDENTS BASIC NEEDS BY
ESTABLISHING A BASIC NEEDS
CENTER AND A BASIC NEEDS
COORDINATOR. ON EACH COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CAMPUS NO LATER THAN
JULY FIRST TWENTY TWENTY TWO.
THE BASIC NEEDS COORDINATOR
WOULD ACT AS A BROKER AND
IDENTIFYING SUPPORTING AND
LINKING STUDENTS. TO ON AND OFF
CAMPUS SERVICES AND RESOURCES.
THE BASIC NEEDS CENTER IS
INTENDED TO BE A ONE STOP
CENTRALIZED LOCATION FOR
STUDENTS TO MORE EASILY ACCESS
CAN AWARENESS BE CONNECTED TO
EXISTING SERVICES AND
RESOURCES. UNDER THIS BILL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WOULD ALSO
DEVELOP A DOCUMENT THAT CLEARLY
LISTS ALL ON AND OFF CAMPUS
BASIC NEEDS SERVICES AND
RESOURCES THAT WOULD BE
AVAILABLE AT THE CENTER. AS
WELL AS ON THE CAMPUSES WEBSITE
IN STUDENT PORTAL. THE IDEA OF
A COORDINATED AND INTEGRATED
APPROACH IS NOT NEW IN FACT
FIFTY NINE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
HAVE REPORTED HAVING SOME FORM
OF BASIC NEEDS ENTER ALREADY.
DURING THESE UNPRECEDENTED AND
CHALLENGING TIMES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS ACROSS ALL
CAMPUSES NEED OUR SUPPORT NOW
MORE THAN EVER AND BECAUSE OF
THIS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. AND I'M HONORED TO BE
JOINED BY TO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS TODAY. INJURE NICKENS
A STUDENT AT FOLSOM LAKE
COLLEGE AND VICE PRESIDENT OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE
STUDENT SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ONE OF THE
BILL'S SPONSORS. IN CRISTINA
TORE AS A STUDENT AT
BAKERSFIELD COLLEGE. THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN AT&T
MODERATOR THE FIRST LEAD
SEVEN SEVEN FIVE AS ANDREW
NICKENS THE VICE PRESIDENT. OF
LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS FOR THE
STUDENTS SENATE. OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE MISTER
NICKENS PLEASE PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE READY. HELLO TERRY
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME'S
INTERNET CAN BUT I'M A STUDENT
ALSO MY COLLEGE- DSW HAS
SPONSORED THIS BILL BECAUSE
BAKED NEED INSECURITY AMONG
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS HAS
REACHED CRISIS LEVEL
PROPORTIONS. WE KNOW THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE AN
ACCESS POINT IN THE HIGHER
EDUCATION THE LATTER OF SOCIAL
AND ECONOMIC MOBILITY. HOWEVER
DUE TO COVER NINETEEN THE
PANDEMIC IN THIS RECESSION
ENROLLMENT HAS DROPPED 12%
STATEWIDE ACUMEN COLLEGES AT A
TIME WHEN IN ROME IS NORMALLY
ON THE RISE. WHICH DEMONSTRATES
THE STUDENTS SIMPLY DO NOT HAVE
THE BASIC RESOURCES THEY NEED
TO ACCESS HIGHER EDUCATION.
WE'RE WATCHING AT THIS LATTER
IS CRUMBLING TO DUST IN THE
HANDS OF OUR STUDENTS OF COLOR.
AND LOW INCOME STUDENTS THE
GENERATION IS ACCESS TO HIGHER
EDUCATION. ENSURING THAT EVERY
CAMPUS IN THE BAKING NEEDS-
CENTER BASE NEEDS COORDINATOR.
HAS BEEN IDENTIFIED AS THE TOP-PARTY BOTH THE STUDENT SENATE
AND LOCAL SEVENS UP AND DOWN
THE STATE. THEY'RE NO GOOD OR
EXPERT FROM THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS AND STUDENTS
THEMSELVES. AND THEIR VOICES ON
THIS ISSUE HAVE BEEN CLEARED.
ARJUN I'VE ONLY. SEVEN FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER NICHOLS- AT&T
MODERATOR THE SECOND WITNESS
CALLING IN IS CRISTINA TAURUS
THE STUDENT AT BAKERSFIELD
COLLEGE IN A STORAGE PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
HELLO MY NAME IS CHRISTINA AND
I'M A COLLEGE STUDENT AND I'M
AND A FORMER BOSS WELL. I ACTED
OF FOSTER CARE SYSTEM WHEN I
WAS EIGHTEEN. I HAD MY DAUGHTER
AT THE TIME YOU IT WOULD BE
DIFFICULT TO MANAGE GOING TO
SCHOOL WONDERING WHERE I WOULD
WEAR MY BILLING ME WHERE AM I
GOING TO. I HAD TO DROP OUT OF
COLLEGE AT THE FRIENDS BECAUSE
I ENDED UP. I HAD A FEW BOXES
GET TO THE FOOD PANTRY INTO
BUT- IT BACK ON IT WAS A LOT TO
HANDLE BUT I HAVE TO DO IT.
WHAT MADE. THIS THIS BASIC
NEEDS AND I WOULD ALLOW PEOPLE
WHO NEED EXTRA HELP AND
SUPPORT. TO GET THEIR HIGHER
EDUCATION THE SENATE ALLOW
ACCESS TO THE RESOURCES THAT
ARE AVAILABLE. THEN AND THERE.
INSTEAD OF GOING THROUGH SO
MANY. DIFFERENT THE REQUESTED.
ALL THE SENATE WILL ALLOW TO
BREAK THE BARRIERS AND IT MIGHT
WE FACE. THE WE CAN FOCUS ON
CORE. AND FEDERAL HOW THEY'RE
TO SAY. THANK YOU. THANK MISTER
GEORGE. I WILL. WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
IN THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER OR
IN THE GALLERY. A SCENE NINE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN
THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER- IN THE
GALLERY. SCENE NINE. ANY
TWEETERS IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBERS NINE. SO NOW MOVING TO
THE PHONE LINES EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY WOODS
IS IN SUPPORT ON THE PHONE OR
IN THE QUEEN. IF SO PLEASE LET
IN JOURNALISM. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN IF YOU DO HAVE A IF
YOU DO HAVE A COMMENT IN
SUPPORT PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO ON YOUR TOUCH TONE PHONE
IN EIGHTEEN T. SPECIALIST WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER AND WE WILL IDENTIFY YOU
WHEN YOU WHAT WHEN WE OPEN UP
YOUR LINE. THE FIRST GO TO LINE
FORTY SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD
MORNING TECHNICAL MEN ON BEHALF
OF THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES IN SUPPORT. WELL LET'S
GO TO LINE FIFTY THREE. GOOD
MORNING REBECCA GONZALEZ
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. THANK YOU LINE. FIFTY
SEVEN. SHEGOOD MORNING LADIES
CENTER ON BEHALF OF I SEE ARE
YOU CALIFORNIA AND SUPPORT. BY.
FORTY ONE. GOOD MORNING I HAVE
WRITTEN SO FAR FROM YOUNG
INVINCIBLES ARE CALLING IN
SUPPORT. LINE. THIRTY EIGHT.
HELLO MY NAME IS KIMBERLY WILL
AND I'M THE DIRECTOR JENNIFER
COLLEGIATE JANET WITH THE YOUTH
EDUCATION ACT TO INNOVATION
WORKS COMPRISES OF OVER FOUR
THOUSAND NUMBERS I'M NOT
TALKING TO ASSEMBLY DISTRICT
FIFTEEN AND VOICING MY PASSION
SUPPORT. FOR EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN
FIVE. THANK YOU. BY. THIRTY
SIX. TERRY ROZIER WHICH JOHN
BURTON ADVOCATES FOR YOUTH-
STRONG SUPPORT. NINE THIRTY
TWO. NINE THIRTY TO MAKE SURE
YOUR PHONE IS ON MUTE IT. WILL
MOVE ON TO LINE SIXTY. GOOD
pMORNING MANY VIA THINKING ON
BEHALF OF THE FAMILY EVER
AGREED COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT VERY MUCH SUPPORT.
LINE FIFTY TWO. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS VINCE TO WORK
ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN NOW AT
HIGH TECH SPECS ARE STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. NINE SIXTY
FIVE. HI GOOD MORNING JEFF FROM
TELECOM THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL SUPPORT POSITION YET
THE PROPOSAL PART OF THE INTENT
AND KEEP WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSORS ON
GETTING TO SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIR AT THIS TIME WE
HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN Q. THANK
YOU. ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE
MISTER MODERATOR- IN THE QUEUE.
IF YOU'D LIKE TO SPEAK IN
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME ALL RIGHT ANY WITNESSES.
WHO ARE TRAINERS ON THE PHONE
OR IN THE QUEUE. GARY NINE WE
WILL GO TO THE COMMITTEE FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. OKAY
BAKER CHOI MOVES THE BILL.
SECOND BY THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LEVINE- WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE- APPRECIATE- AND THE
COMMENTS MADE BY THE PEOPLE
CALLING IN SUPPORT ESPECIALLY
GREAT TESTIMONY IN THE STUDENTS
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. I KNOW
WHEN I WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD
FOR ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEES
AMENDMENTS IN THE WAKE OF
COVERT NINETEEN IN THE RISE OF
BASIC NEEDS INSECURITIES AMONG
COLLEGE STUDENTS WITH THE OF
THE LEGISLATURE MUST CONTINUE
TO FIND WAYS TO ADDRESS THE
TOTAL RISING COST OF ATTENDANCE
FOR STUDENTS THIS INCLUDES
ADDRESSING STUDENTS HOUSING AND
FOOD. INSECURITY AB EIGHT SEVEN
SEVEN FIVE PROVIDES A
REASONABLE SOLUTION FOR HELPING
STUDENTS NAVIGATE THE OFTEN
CONFUSING WEB OF RESOURCES
AVAILABLE TO THEM A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CAMPUSES HAVING A
SINGLE LOCATION FOR BASIC NEED
RESOURCES AND A SINGLE
COORDINATOR WHOSE PURPOSE IS TO
LINK STUDENTS WITH AVAILABLE
RESOURCES WILL BE BENEFICIAL
AND THESE UNCERTAIN TIMES I
ALSO- JUST MENTION. THAT
PERHAPS NOT OUT THERE MIGHT
CONSIDER- OF TYING IT IN WITH-
FINANCIAL AID JUST AN IDEA. FOR
YOU TO CONSIDER- JUST AN IDEA
TO CONSIDER SO WE A MOTION AS-
THE MOTION BEFORE US IS TO DO
PASSED AS AMENDED TO
APPROPRIATIONS. A MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEDINA HI MEDINA HI
CHOI. CHOI ATTY ARAMBULA. ATTY
LOON BLOOM HI GABRIEL IRWIN
KILEY LEVINE LEVINE I LOW RUBIO.
RUBIO I SANTIAGO BALLADEER
HELLO THERE IS AT. ABOUT SEVEN
ZERO. SEVEN ZERO SEVEN ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT WE'LL LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS- THE NEXT
BILL IS FILE ITEM TO AB SEVEN
TEN SEVENTY THREE MR BERMAN
WHEN YOU'RE READY PLEASE
PROCEED THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
ITS DONE MISTER SHARON THANK
YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS ON ON THE
PRIOR BILL. CALIFORNIA IS
EXPERIENCING A GROWING SHORTAGE
OF EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS
WHICH IS WORSENED IT SINCE THE
START OF A COVERED NINETEEN
PANDEMIC EVEN BEFORE THE
PANDEMIC AND THE SHORTAGE OF
CHILDCARE HAS IMPACTED
CALIFORNIA'S ECONOMY WOULD
BUSINESSES LOSING IS SIX
HUNDRED THIRTY EIGHT MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR DUE TO EMPLOYEE
ABSENCES RESULTING FROM
BREAKDOWNS AND CHILDCARE
ARRANGEMENTS. POST CODE
NINETEEN A TRACKING AND
INVESTING IN THE ESSENTIAL
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
WORKFORCE WILL BE CRITICAL TO
ECONOMIC RECOVERY WELL STUDIES
CONSISTENTLY SHOW THAT FORMAL
TRAINING IN ECP THE STOCK
HIGHER QUALITY CHILDCARE
PERSPECTIVE INTO EARLY
CHILDHOOD- AND EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATORS REPORT THAT THE COST
OF TUITION. IS A KEY BARRIER.
TO ADDRESS THE SHORTAGE AB CAN
SEVENTY THREE WOULD ESTABLISH
THE EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION
WORKFORCE WAIVER. TO PROVIDE A
TARGETED FEE WAIVER FOR EIGHT
SPECIFIED ECT COURSES. ONLY FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TUDENTS WITH
A DECLARED MAJOR RELATED TO
EASY AND CHILD DEVELOPMENT.
THIS BILL WOULD REMOVE A
FINANCIAL BARRIER AND
INCENTIVIZE CALIFORNIANS TO
ENTER AND ADVANCE IN THE EASY
WORKFORCE WITH THE GOAL OF
INCREASING ACCESS TO HIGH
QUALITY EASY. FOR CALIFORNIA'S
CHILDREN AS THE COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS STATES BY PROVIDING
TUITION WAIVERS FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO WOULD LIKE
TO R. ELECT TO ENROLL IN THE C.
COURSES. AB TEN SEVENTY THREE
FOUR FALLS TO OVER THE
STRATEGIES LISTED IN THE
GOVERNOR'S RECENT MASTER
PLANNED FOR EARLY LEARNING AND
CARE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. AND TESTIFYING TODAY
IS DANA CHEONG EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY EQUITY
COLLABORATIVE AND NICOLE KIRBY
DEPARTMENT CHAIR OF CHILD
DEVELOPMENT AND EDUCATION AT
FOOTHILL COLLEGE. THANK YOU MR
BERMAN EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR WE
WILL NOW MOVE TO THE FIRST LEAD
WITNESS. WHO'S BEEN CALLING IN
FOR AB TEN SEVENTY THREE. AS
DANA CHAU EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
FOR THE COMMUNITY EQUITY
COLLABORATIVE. THIS GIANT
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU TURNING CARE MEDINA
VICE CHAIR CHOI AND HONORABLE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS DANA JOHN I AM THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF COMMUNITY
EQUITY COLLABORATIVE THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME
BEFORE YOU TODAY AS BOTH A
SPONSOR AND SUPPORTER OF AB TEN
SEVENTY THREE THE EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATION WORKFORCE
WAIVER. AS A FAMILY MEMBER
BERMAN SHARED CALIFORNIA IS
EXPERIENCING A WORKFORCE
SHORTAGE OF EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATORS WHICH HAS BEEN MADE
WORSE BY THE PANDEMIC AB TEN
SEVENTY THREE ADDRESSES THE
COST OF TUITION WHICH IS A KEY
BARRIER TO ENTERING AN
ADVANCING AND THAT'S VITALLY
IMPORTANT FIELD. THE PANDEMIC
HAS MADE CLEAR THAT CHILD CARE
IS THE SPECIAL FOR WORKING
FAMILIES YEAH SIX HUNDRED
THOUSAND OF THE MOST VULNERABLE
REPORT DIFFICULTY FINDING CARE
LEADING THREE QUARTERS OF
MOTHERS AND HALF OF FATHERS
BELIEVER SWITCHED TO A LESS
DEMANDING JOB SINCE THE
PANDEMIC THREE MILLION WOMEN
NATIONWIDE HAVE LEFT THE
WORKFORCE DUE TO CHILD CARE
SHORTAGES DRIVING PARTICIPATION
TO A THIRTY THREE YEAR LOW AND
LEAVING 40% OF BUSINESSES
UNABLE TO FILL VACANCIES. OUR
ECONOMY CANNOT FULLY RECOVER
UNLESS WORKING FAMILIES
ESPECIALLY WOMEN CAN FULLY
PARTICIPATE BY REMOVING
BARRIERS TO PROFESSIONAL
LEARNING AB TEN SEVENTY THREE
WOULD BE A GAME CHANGER FOR
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS AND A
VITAL BUILDING BLOCK FOR OTHER
EARLY EDUCATION LEGISLATIVE
INITIATIVES THE RESULT WILL BE
BETTER ECONOMIC OUTCOMES FOR
CALIFORNIA'S WORKING FAMILIES
AND A STRONGER START IN LIFE
FOR THEIR CHILDREN AS WELL AS
EXPANDED OPPORTUNITIES FOR THE
EARLY CHILDHOOD CARE AND.
LEARNING PROFESSIONAL THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MEASURE EIGHTEEN TO
MY THE SECOND LEAD WITNESS
CALLING IN IS MISS NICOLE
KIRBY. DEPARTMENT CHAIR OF
CHILD DEVELOPMENT AND EDUCATION
AT FOOTHILL COLLEGE MISS CURVY
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. YEAH HELLO CHAIR MEDINA
VICE CHAIR CHOI AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NICOLE
KIRBY AND I'M AN INSTRUCTOR IN
THE DEPARTMENT CHAIR CHILD
DEVELOPMENT EDUCATION AT
FOOTHILL COLLEGE IN LOS ALTOS
HILLS CALIFORNIA. MY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT BUT HOLDING
HANDS AT THE PORT EIGHTY TEN
SEVENTY THREE THE BILL THAT
HELPED ME TO CRITICAL NEED
EARLY EDUCATION. AS AN
INSTRUCTOR IN THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE I CAN TELL
YOU MY STUDENTS ARE DIVERSE AND
HAVE A WIDE VARIETY OF
EXPERIENCES IN EDUCATION. WELL
DIVERSE MY STUDENTS HAVE A LOT
IN COMMON. EIGHTEEN ITALIANS
THAT EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS
HAVE IN OUR SOCIETY AND
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT YOUNG CHILDREN
YOU QUALITY CARE. AS SAMPLE
CHILD DEVELOPMENT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STUDENT. 75% ARE PART
TWENTY AT FEDERAL COLLEGE. MOST
OF MY STUDENTS ARE TAKING ONLY
ONE CLASS AT A TIME AND THEY
ARE ALSO WORKING FULL TIME TO
SUPPORT FAMILIES OF THEIR OWN.
THE PROBLEM IS THE FACT THAT
AND PROMISED FINANCIAL AID
PROGRAMS REQUIRE STUDENTS TO BE
HALF TO PULL PAINTED IN. I
THINK MY STUDENTS BUT THE
BURDEN OF PAYING FOR COURSES
BUT THEIR LANGUAGE AND- EIGHTY
TEN SEVENTY THREE MAKES IT
POSSIBLE FOR CURRENT AND
POTENTIAL EARLY EDUCATORS TO
GET THE REQUIRED EDUCATION TO
WORK IN THE FIELD. IN MY
OPINION IT SHOULD BE THE FIRST
STEP IN CHANGING HOW WE TREAT
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS AND
OUR SOCIETY. PERSPIRE THE
MINUTE BARRIER AT THE MOST
FUNDAMENTAL EDUCATION AND NEXT
TACKLING P. DECENT PAY FOR THIS
CRUCIAL WORK. AB CAN
TECHNICALLY. THANK YOU MR KIRBY
WE WILL NOW MOVE THE PUBLIC
COMMENTS I ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER IN THE GALLERY C. NINE
ANY WITNESSES IN PPOSITION IN
THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER IN THE
GALLERY SCENE NINE ANY TWEETERS
IN THE BACK TO THE CHAMBERS IN
NINE SO WE'LL MOVE NOW TO THE
PHONE LINES. AT&T MODERATOR ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ON THE PHONE OR IN THE QUEUE.
WE WILL GO TO LINE SIXTY SEVEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. AND WE MOVED
TO LINE SIXTY EIGHT PLEASE GO
AHEAD. IN ORDER TO MOVE ON TO
LINE SEVENTY FOUR PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING BRITAIN
SOMEONE ON WHAT THE CALIFORNIA
ALTERNATIVE PAYMENT PROGRAMS
ASSOCIATION AND ONE STRONG
SUPPORTER AB TEN SEVENTY THREE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU I MOVED TO
LINUS FORTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING KEVIN ANDERSON ON
BEHALF OF THE CONSOLIDATION
UNITY FOUNDATION AND THE SAN
MATEO COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS SUPPORT THINKING.
AND WE'LL MOVE TO ONE FIFTY TWO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING
MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS VINCE
STEWART ON BEHALF OF CHILDREN
NOW BUT IT'S PRESS ARE STRONG
SUPPORT PRETTY BE TEN SEVENTY
THREE THANK YOU. THANK YOU
ALMOST HAVE LINE EIGHTY EIGHT
ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
MORNING- STRUCTURE AND MEMBERS
REMAIN A CARBOXYL ELLIOT
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE EARLY
CARE AND EDUCATION CONSORTIUM
IN SUPPORT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT WILL MOVE TO LINE SEVENTY
SEVEN ZERO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
GOOD MORNING THIS IS SERRA CAN
HAND COORDINATOR FOR THE SAME A
CHANCE COUNTY CHILD CARE
PARTNERSHIP COUNCIL OFFERING
SUPPORT. FOR EIGHTY TEN SEVENTY
THREE. INTO TE CHAIR NO
FURTHER LINES IN Q. PLEASE
CONTINUE. THANK YOU MISTER
MONTE MODERATOR- WE WILL NOW GO
TO WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ON
THE LINE OR IN THE QUEUE. AND
WE HAVE NO LINES IN OPPOSITION
IN Q. IF WE COULD GO THEN-
MISTER MODERATOR TO ANY WINNERS
ON THE LINE OR IN THE QUEUE.
HEARING NONE WE WILL NOW GO TO
THE COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THE MOTION BY DOCTOR
CHOI TO PASS THE. OKAY YES I
JUST WANT TO THANK HE AUTHOR-
FOR PUTTING FORWARD THIS BILL A
VERY VITAL TIME WHENIT COMES
TO GROWING THE WORK FORCE TO
IMPROVING ACCESS- AT A TIME
WHEN WE NO CHILDREN ARE GOING
TO NEED ACCESS WHEN WE NEED TO
GROW THE WORK FORCE WHEN CHILD
CARE PROVIDERS- NEED A POOL OF
SUBSTITUTE TEACHERS AS WELL
THAT JUST DOESN'T EXIST SO I AM
IN STRONG SUPPORT AND WE WOULD
REALLY APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO CO AUTHOR IF YOU
WOULD HAVE MEANT. A LOT I WOULD
LOVE THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISFIRE THAT IS- WE
HAD A MOTION BY DOCTOR CHOI DO
I SEE A SECOND. SECOND BY THIS
WAY AND THAT IS- TO THE AUTHOR
IF YOU'D LIKE TO A- CLOSE. I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT
OF COMMENTS RESPECTFULLY ASK
RIVAL THANKS SO MUCH I WANT TO
THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER BERMAN
FOR RE AUTHORIZING. A RE
AUTHORING AB TEN SEVENTY THREE
I APPRECIATE HIS CONTINUED
ATTENTION TO THE NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIANS EARLY CHILDHOOD
EDUCATION WORKFORCE. I
UNDERSTAND FROM UC BERKELEY
EARLY CHILDHOOD WORKFORCE INDEX
THAT CALIFORNIA IS EXPERIENCING
A SHORTAGE OF QUALIFIED EARLY
CHILDHOOD EDUCATORS. TEACHING
AS I KNOW IS A REWARDING
EXPERIENCE AND I HOPE THAT AB
TEN SEVENTY THREE ADDRESSES THE
FINANCIAL BARRIERS PREVENTING
COLLEGE STUDENTS FROM BECOMING
EARLY CHILDHOOD. EDUCATORS THE
MOTION BEFORE US IS DO PASSED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI AYE CHU
AYE AYES ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE
BLOOM. BLOOM I GABRIEL IRWIN
KILEY LEVINE. LEVINE I LOW.
RUBIO RUBIO I SANTIAGO VALIDUS
VALIDUS. FIVE BUT SEVEN ZERO.
LOTUS SEVEN ZERO THAT BILL IS
OUT WE WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR. THANK YOU MR BERMAN. THE
NEXT BILL ON FILE ORDERS A. B.
TWO THIRTY THREE FILE ITEM
THREE. BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER TASHA
BOERNER HORVATH. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. BOERNER HORVATH PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY
TO PRESENT AB TWO THIRTY THREE
WHICH SEEKS TO ENSURE THAT ALL
STUDENTS APPLYING TO THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA HAVE A
FAIR CHANCE OF THE MISSION
REGARDLESS OF THEIR WEALTH AND
FAMILY CONNECTIONS AS A PROUD
UC BERKELEY ALARM GO BEARS. I
WAS SADDENED TO HEAR THE UC
CAMPUS STUFF WERE IMPLICATED IN
THE COLLEGE EMISSIONS FRAUD
DISCOVERED BY THE F. B. I.'S
TWENTY NINETEEN OPERATION
VARSITY BLUES INVESTIGATION.
THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE AUDIT
COMMITTEE RESPONDED BY
APPROVING AN INDEPENDENT
EXTERNAL AUDIT TO INVESTIGATE
UC ADMISSIONS PROCESS THESE THE
FINDINGS OF THE AUDIT WERE
RELEASED IN SEPTEMBER TWENTY
TWENTY AND THEY DEMONSTRATE
ONGOING ON LONG STANDING FLAWS
IN CAMPUSES CAMPUS PROPHECIES
THE CREATED UNFAIR OR
INCONSISTENT EMISSION
PRACTICES. ARE STATE AUDITOR
FOUND THAT SOME UC CAMPUSES
STUFF EXPLOITED LOOPHOLES IN
THE ADMISSIONS PROCESS TO EMIT
SIXTY FOUR UNDER QUALIFIED
STUDENTS AS FAVORS TO DONORS
FAMILIES FRIENDS BETWEEN THE
ACADEMIC YEARS OF TWENTY
THIRTEEN FOURTEEN AND EIGHTEEN
AND NINETEEN. THE DEMOGRAPHICS
OF THESE UNDER QUALIFIED IN
IMPROPERLY OMITTED STUDENTS.
SKEWED WEALTHY WHITE. A FURTHER
APPLICATION REVIEWERS WERE
SOMETIMES OVERLY HARSH OR
OVERLY LENIENT IN THE
ASSESSMENT OF THE APPLICANTS
WHICH MEANS APPLICANT'S.
CHANCES OF EMISSIONS UNDULY
DEPENDENT ON WHICH STAFF
MEMBERS EVALUATED THE
APPLICATIONS. WE NEED TO ASSURE
CALIFORNIANS THE DIVERSITY AND
MERITOCRACY WE VALUE IS
RETAINED IN THE HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS. AB TWO
THIRTY THREE IS ALIGNED WITH
THE STATE AUDITOR'S
RECOMMENDATIONS FOR SYSTEM WIDE
PROTOCOLS TRAINING AND
OVERSIGHT ACROSS ALL UC
CAMPUSES TO PREVENT AGAINST
IMPROPER INCREASES THE MISSION.
AB TWO THIRTY THREE WOULD
REQUEST THE UC OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT TO ESTABLISH POLICIES
AND PROCEDURES TO IMPLEMENT A
FAIR AND IMPARTIAL EMISSIONS
PROCESS. INCLUDING TRAINING FOR
APPLICATION REVIEWERS ON THE
CONSISTENT AND UNBIASED USE OF
EMISSION CRITERIA. THIS BILL
WOULD ALSO REQUIRE AN ANNUAL
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE ON
HOW EACH CAMPUS IS IMPLEMENTING
THESE PROCEDURES AND WHAT
MEASURES HAVE BEEN ESTABLISHED
TO PREVENT INAPPROPRIATE
INTERACTION BETWEEN A MISSION
STAFF AND OTHER UNIVERSITY
DEPARTMENTS. ALL STUDENTS
APPLYING TO THE UC UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA SHOULD HAVE A
FAIR CHANCE OF THE MISSION. WE
MUST ENSURE THAT YOU SEE
EMISSIONS PROCESSES LIVE UP TO
THE CALIBER OF OUR STUDENTS
APPLYING I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR BY THE- WITH ME TODAY IS
WITNESSES. I HAVE BOB HARRIS
FROM THE STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE
ALLEN CALDERON THE EXTERNAL
VICE PRESIDENT OF THE UC IRVINE
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT
GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
WOMAN THE FIRSTLY WITNESS FROM
THE WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCE
ROOM BOB HARRIS PRINCIPAL
AUDITOR OF THE CALIFORNIA STATE
AUDITOR'S OFFICE MISTER HARRIS
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY
NAME IS BOB HARRIS FOR THE
STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE I WAS
THE PROJECT MANAGER ON OUR
REVIEW OF THE UNIVERSITY'S
ADMISSIONS PROCESSES. IF THE
POLICY OF OUR OFFICE NOT TO
TAKE A FORMAL POSITION ON BILLS
BUT I WOULD PROVIDE THE
COMMITTEE WITH AN OVERVIEW OF
HOW EIGHTY TWO THIRTY THREE.
ADDRESSES THE DEFICIENCIES WE
FOUND DURING OUR REVIEW IN THE
ADMISSIONS PROCESS AND ADOPT
THE RECOMMENDATIONS THAT WE
MADE TO SOLVE THOSE
DEFICIENCIES. ALSO BY WAY OF
UPDATE TO THE COMMITTEE WE
RECENTLY PUBLISHED OUR SIX
MONTH UPDATE ON THE
UNIVERSITY'S PROGRESS ON OUR
RECOMMENDATIONS. AND WE HAVE
FOUND THAT THE UNIVERSITY STILL
HAS SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS THAT
IT NEEDS TO MAKE TO ADDRESS THE
PROBLEMS THAT WE FOUND. NO AB
TWO THIRTY THREE ADDRESSES
QUITE A NUMBER OF THOSE
DEFICIENCIES AND ADOPTS MANY OF
OUR RECOMMENDATIONS I'LL
HIGHLIGHT TO FOR THE COMMITTEE
AND THEN TAKE QUESTIONS AS
NEEDED. ONE OF FOCUS FIRST ON
THE AREA APPLICANT EVALUATION
WHERE AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JUST MENTIONED. WE FOUND THAT
AN APPLICANT'S CHANCES OF
GETTING A HIGH SCORE OR A LOW
SCORE ON THEIR APPLICATION WERE
UNDULY DUE TO. WHICH
APPLICATION REVIEW WHERE THEY
HAPPEN TO BE ASSIGNED TO. THAT
LOOKS ALTADENA INCONSISTENT AND
UNFAIR PROCESS FOR APPLICANT
EVALUATION BECAUSE THE CAMPUS
HAS HAD NOT ADOPTED MONITORING
PROCESSES. TO ENSURE
PROFICIENCY THROUGHOUT THE
ENTIRE APPLICATION CYCLE AND
OUR SIX MONTH REVIEW SHOWS THAT
SEVERAL CAMPUSES ARE STILL
BEHIND IN THAT AREA THEY HAVE
NOT ADOPTED SUFFICIENT.
SOLUTIONS TO THAT PROBLEM. THIS
BILL WOULD ADDRESS THAT ISSUE.
SECOND ISSUE ALL COVER FOR THE
COMMITTEE AND THEN TAKE
QUESTIONS AS THE AREA
APPLICANTS SELECTION. WE FOUND
AT UCLA AND UC BERKELEY THE
CAMPUSES LACKED CLEAR
METHODOLOGIES FOR WHY THEY
WOULD DECIDE AMONGST A VERY
COMPETITIVE POOL OF APPLICANTS
TO CHOOSE ONE APPLICANT OVER
ANOTHER. LEAVING QUESTIONS
ABOUT WHY THEY WOULD CHOOSE THE
LOWER RATED APPLICANTS OVER
HIGHER RATED APPLICANTS WHICH
IS SOMETHING THAT WE SAW. AGAIN
WE RECOMMEND THE CAMPUSES ADOPT
CLEAR METHODOLOGIES FOR THE
CHOOSING AMONGST THEIR HIGHLY
COMPETITIVE POOLS BUT THE
UNIVERSITY IS STILL BEHIND IN
THAT AREA. WITH THAT I'LL TAKE
ANY OF THE COMMITTEES QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU. THE SECOND LEAD
WITNESS- CALLING IN IT IS
MISTER ALLEN CALDERON THE
EXTERNAL VICE PRESIDENT OF
ASSOCIATED STUDENTS AT UC
IRVINE MISTER CALDERON PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE READY.
GOOD MORNING MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ALAN
CONTENT ON A STUDENT AND%
EXTERNAL VICE PRESIDENT AT UC
IRVINE. I'D LIKE TO SET TO
START OFF BY THINKING ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS BOERNER HORVATH AND
MCCARTY FOR BRINGING THIS BILL
TO THE ASSEMBLY. COLLEGE
ADMISSIONS ARE STRESSFUL FOR
EVERYONE I KNOW YOU HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT WHETHER THEY'LL BE
ABLE TO AFFORD COLLEGE FOR
THEIR STUDENTS SOME HAVE TO-WORRY ABOUT WHETHER THEY MAKE
TOO MUCH MONEY TO QUALIFY FOR
FINANCIAL AID. STUDENTS WORRIED
ABOUT THEIR GPA FROM THE START
OF THEIR FRESHMAN YEAR
STANDARDIZED TESTING IS BOTH
EXPENSIVE AND NOT ACTUALLY
REPRESENTATIVE OF EACH
STUDENT'S ABILITY TO HANDLE A
COLLEGE CURRICULUM TO WORRY
ABOUT THE COST OF APPLICATIONS
WHAT OUR FINANCIAL AID PACKAGE
WILL LOOK LIKE. AND THE FEAR OF
REJECTION. AND FOR SOME THE
STORIES ARE MARGINAL. THEY KNOW
THAT THEY CAN AFFORD ALL OF
THESE THINGS. FOR SOME IT IS
EASY IS WRITING A CHECKS AND
OUT OF THE BOX THAT SHOULD
CONCERN EVERY PERSON ON THIS
COMMITTEE. EVERY STUDENT SHOULD
HAVE A FAIR CHANCE IN THE
ADMISSIONS PROCESS. WE SHOULD
NOT BE PRAYING TO GET LUCKY
WITH AN APPLICATION REVIEW WORK
WILL DO THEIR JOB IMPARTIAL
IMPARTIALLY. THE PRESTIGE OF
THE UC IS CONTINGENT UPON A
STRICTER FORM OF THIS PROCESS.
TO MAKE SURE THAT THE STUDENTS
ATTENDING OUR UNIVERSITY ARE
THOSE WHO TRULY WORKS FOR IT-
YOU KNOW AND HOW MUCH MONEY
YOUR FAMILY HAS. SHOULD NEVER
BE THE DETERMINING FACTOR IN
ADMISSIONS. BY CONTINUING TO
ALLOW THESE UNFAIR PRACTICES IN
ADMISSIONS THE UC WILL BECOME
KNOWN MORE FOR HOW IT BENDS THE
RULES FOR SOME STUDENTS. BUT
MAKES THE REST OF US JUMP JUMP
THROUGH HOOPS. NUMBERS OUT OF
RESPECT FOR OUR STUDENTS AND
ALL THE HARD WORKING FAMILIES
ACROSS THE STATE. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE
YES ON. EIGHTY TWO THIRTY
THREE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
MISTER CALDERON WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT. SHINO
WITNESSES IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER. NO ITNESSES IN THE
FRONT OF THE CHAMBER. NO
TWEENER WILL MOVE TO THE PHONE
LINES EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. ON THE
PHONE SB THANK YOU A LITTLE TO
ONE FORTY THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MICHELLE HOW ARE YOU I AM
AN UNDERGRADUATE AT THE UC
IRVINE AND OFFICER HAS
UNDERGRADUATE. YEAH AND I'M
CALLING IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
THANK YOU. NEXT WE'LL GO TO
LINE EIGHTY TWO PLEASE GO AHEAD.
AND WE'LL MOVE ON TO LINE FIFTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. ONE
FIFTY THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN.
I CAN MORNING REBEKAH DEVELOPS
OF THE NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF
SOCIAL WORKERS CALIFORNIA
CHAPTER IN SUPPORT. ANDERSON
CHAIR NOW FOR THE LINES IN Q.
THANK YOU MR MODERATOR IF THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
AND WE HAVE NO LINES IN
OPPOSITION ANY WITNESSES WHO
ARE TWEETERS. GARY NINE TODAY
WE HAVE ONE LINE. WE HAVE A
TWEENER MY APOLOGIES MISS YEAH
WE HAVE ONE ONE COMING AT ONE
MOMENT MISTER CHAIR. IN ORDER
TO LINE FIFTY FIVE ZERO PLEASE
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU- MISTER
JERRY MEMBERS HI THERE ARE YOU
ARMY AFTER THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA- WE WANT TO- AB
OPPORTUNITY TO LET YOU.
STUDENTS VERY SERIOUSLY-
UNIVERSITY COMMITTED TO
ENSURING THE INTEGRITY OF YOUR
POSITIONS PROPERTY ADDRESS
HIGHLIGHTED IN THE PREVIOUS-
PRESENTATION DETAINEES HIS
INITIATED CHIU INTERNAL AUDITS
AFTER THE NATIONWIDE PERSON
POLICE INVESTIGATION. THAT WAS
MADE PUBLIC IN MARCH OF TWENTY
NINETEEN. THANKS THE COMPLETION
OF THOSE INTERNAL AUDIT THE UC
HAS ALREADY ACTED TO IMPLEMENT.
A NUMBER OF IMPORTANT
SAFEGUARDS. JUST STRENGTHENING
OUR FOR- I KNOW TO DO THAT IN
WERE TAKEN INTO. PRIOR TO THE
INTRODUCTION EIGHTY TWO THIRTY
THREE AS WELL AS SUBSEQUENT
BUILD ANYTHING ON THIS TOPIC AB
TWELVE FIFTEEN. AND ALSO WAS-
ACTED ON BEFORE THIS THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT WAS. LAST
DECEMBER. I WOULD ALSO POINT
OUT THESE JOBS THE PRESIDENT
CONTINUED TO UNDERTAKE A
THOROUGH REVIEW. OF EACH ISSUE
CASE OUTLINED IN THE ARTERIES
REPORT. I DO THE METHOD OF THE
ORDERS REVIEW YOU SEE HOW TO
TAKE STEPS TO REQUEST THE
MATERIAL DIRECTLY FROM THE CSA
AND SINCE OUR RECEIPT OF THAT
INFO. YOU SEE HAVE BEEN
REVIEWING EACH CASE IN AN
EFFORT TO BETTER UNDERSTAND
EACH CIRCUMSTANCE. AND ENSURE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR ANYONE WHO
MAY HAVE ACTED IMPROPERLY.
ADDITION A PRESIDENT DRAKE
ACTIVE ENGAGEMENT- THE UC
REGENTS ALSO MONITORING THE
ISSUE VERY CLOSELY. THEY HAVE
AN UPDATE ON THE LAST MEETING
ON MARCH SEVENTEENTH- AND
THEY'RE CONTINUE TO BE ENGAGED.
UNIVERSALLY ALTERNATELY HAS THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF ASSURING THAT
ANY FURTHER CHANGES PROPOSED TO
OUR ADMISSIONS PROCEDURES. DO
NOT IMPEDE OUR ABILITY TO
ENGAGE IN A BROAD AND ROBUST
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF
APPLICANTS- THAT WE DO NOT
ADDITION TO SHARE TODAY AGAIN
THE UNIVERSALIST WORKER
DISCUSSIONS OF THE AUTHORS. AS
WE CONTINUE TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
THESE INDIVIDUAL CASES.
OUTLINED IN THE AUDITOR'S
REPORT AND I'M HAPPY. TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU. THANK
YOU. WILL NOW GO QUESTIONS OR
CRIME FROM THE COMMITTEE OKAY
MAKE A MOTION AND A NO LIKE TO
A CAR I AM THREE THE AUTHOR FOR
THE B. UP TO THIRTY THREE WHICH
IS ATTEMPTING TO- COME UP WITH
A MORE- FAIR AND EQUITABLE FOR
ALL ADMISSION STANDARDS OF WAR
PRACTICES- BECAUSE SELF OFF
SCANDALS THAT WE HAD. NEVER
HEARD OF HIM AND ALSO- TO DATE
MY AB TWO FIFTY ONE WAS A
RELATED TO WITH THIS SO FAIR
AND EQUITABLE THE COMMISSION
PRACTICES SET OF STANDARDS SO-
THAT THE DISORDER OR BE ABLE TO
ACHIEVE A WOULD BE OF GREAT
HELP WITH THAT. I MAKE A MOTION
FOR APPROVAL. WE HAVE A REMOTE
BY CHOI AS BY DOCTOR RUMBLE.
BUT OUR LIKE TO MAKE A CLOSING.
I'M SORRY MISTER BENNETT DID
NOT SEE MY PLAN. THE SEE THANK
YOU MR LEVINE I APPRECIATE X.
AND EFFICIENCY- BY WHICH YOU'RE
YOU'RE CHAIRING THE MEETING
MISTER FERRELL I DID HAVE A
QUESTION FOR THE HE THE
AUDITOR- AND- I I'D LOSE IT
MISTER HARRIS WHO IS THERE HE'S
HE'S STILL THERE- AND WHILE
WE'RE WAITING- TO CALL HIM UP-
I DID WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR. HER EFFORT TO ADDRESS WHAT
IS A REAL ISSUE WE WANT PEOPLE
TO BE ADMITTED BASED ON THEIR
MERIT TEND NOT TO ON ANY
UNSEEMLY- INFLUENCE THAT TIME
COULD BE WEIGHED DOWN ON ON THE
UNIVERSITY AS WE SAW WHAT
HAPPENED IN THAT SCANDAL- SAYS.
MR HARRIS'S THERE. THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I'M HERE RIGHT THANK YOU-
SO. YOU KNOW WHAT I'M LOOKING
AT- KNOW YOU THANKS FOR BEING
HERE AND I AM REPRESENTING THE
WORK OF THE AUDIT AND THE
AUDITOR- IN YOUR EFFORT ON ALL
OF THIS. WHEN I AM I'M LOOKING
AT THE BILL LANGUAGE IT DOES
APPEAR TO ME TO BE. A QUITE
PRESCRIPTIVE AND I THINK WE'LL
SEE THE SENATE AND WHAT I SEE
IS A COMPANION BILL FOR CSU
LATER ON- AND- IT IN INTO PLACE
ALL ADDRESS THE FIRST ONE THE
FIRST QUESTION I HAVE. WHICH IS
THE REQUIREMENT. BUT WHAT WHICH
I SUPPORT IN IN- IN SPIRIT.
ABOUT REPORTING ATTEMPTS TO
INFLUENCE DECISIONS BECAUSE NO
ONE SHOULD HAVE- A LEVER WAY
DOWN UPON THEM TO ADMIT. OR
DECLINE A STUDENT FOR THAT
MATTER- BECAUSE OF THAT TYPE OF
INFLUENCE THAT SHOULD NEVER
HAPPEN TO A STAFF MEMBER AT AT
YOU SEE- I AM CONCERNED ABOUT
THE PRESCRIPTIVE NATURE AND HOW
IT IS WRITTEN IN THE BILL AND
SO I WANT TO ASK YOU ABOUT THE
AUDITORS- RECOMMENDATIONS. AND
IN THIS WILL REFLECT ON MY
SECOND QUESTION- SO FOR
EXAMPLE- STUDENTS WHO HAVE BEEN
WAIT LISTED OFTEN ARE
RECOMMENDED WRITE A LETTER TO
THE UNIVERSITY. THE SAME THAT
YOU REALLY WANT TO GO THERE AND
THAT IS THE ONLY UNIVERSITY YOU
WANT TO GO TO AND IF YOU ARE
TAKEN OFF THAT WAIT LIST THAT
THAT IS YOU ARE GOING TO TAKE
THAT OFFER TO GO. ON AND THAT
IF SOMEONE WERE TO RECEIVE THAT
LETTER AND THEN LET'S JUST SAY
IT'S THE DEAN- AND THEN ASK
WHOEVER IS IN CHARGE OF THE
WEIGHT LAST- HEY WHERE IS.
MISTER HARRIS ON THE WAIT LIST
I GOT THIS LETTER IT WAS
IMPRESSIVE TO SEE ANYWHERE NEAR
THE TOP- WHAT IS THAT YOU KNOW
DOES THAT FALL INTO THAT HAVE
INFLOWS BECAUSE THE DEAN IS AN
INFLUENTIAL MEMBER OF THE
STAFF. OF THE LEADER OF
PERHAPS- EACH ONE OF THE
LEADERS OF THE UNIVERSITY WHERE
DOES NOT FALL AND HOW DOES THAT
WORK. HAPPY TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION THERE THERE'S A FEW
DIFFERENT- ELEMENTS- QUESTION I
WANNA MAKE SURE ADDRESS ONE IS.
THE ISSUE OF LETTERS OF
RECOMMENDATION. THE UNIVERSITY
HAS FORMAL POLICIES ABOUT WHEN
LETTERS OF RECOMMENDATION FOR
APPLICANTS ARE APPROPRIATE AND
NOT APPROPRIATE. SO THE
UNIVERSITY DOES HAVE A STAFF OF
PRACTICES THAT DEFINE WHEN A
LETTER OF RECOMMENDATION IS. IF
YOU WILL WITHIN THE SCOPE OF AN
APPROPRIATE- ADMISSIONS
ASSESSMENT. AND WHEN IT IS NOT.
SO THERE'S PRETTY CLEAR
INSTRUCTION ALREADY WITH
RESPECT TO WHAT TO DO WITH A
LETTER OF RECOMMENDATION NOW.
WITH RESPECT TO THE WAIT LIST
ISSUE. WE DID SEE THAT SORT OF
ACTIVITY THAT YOU'RE DESCRIBING
DURING OUR UP AT- IT IS IT IS
GENERALLY OUTSIDE OF THE
PRESCRIBED. ALLOWABLE USE OF
LETTERS OF RECOMMENDATION- SO
WE WOULD EXPECT THAT ADMISSIONS
OFFICES DUE TO THE RELATIVELY
CALM IN NATURE OF THOSE.
CORRESPONDENTS WOULD HAVE. A
STANDARDIZED RESPONSES TO.
THOSE LETTERS AND OTHER WORDS
SAYING THAT THOSE ARE NOT
INFLUENTIAL AND DO NOT ARE NOT
CONSIDERED ON. AS PART OF THE
ADMISSIONS REVIEW PROCESS SO
WHAT DOES BE REPORTABLE EVENTS
UNDER- THE BILL'S PROVISIONS-
THAT COULD BE SOMETHING THE
UNIVERSITY PROBABLY HAS SOME
FLEXIBILITY ON IN TERMS OF-
DELINEATING DIFFERENT TYPES OF
COMMUNICATIONS THAT STAFF MIGHT
RECEIVE IN THE WAYS IN WHICH
THEY SHOULD HANDLE. I SUCH A
BIT OF A GRAY AREA SO IT SAYS
THAT ALL. ALL THINGS SHOULD BE
REPORTED BUT THEY MAY HAVE A
PROCESS BY WHICH IT SAYS IF YOU
RECEIVE A LETTER FROM AN
APPLICANT- POST. DECISION BUT
PRE CLOSURE BECAUSE OF A
WEIGHTLESS SETTING EXPRESSES
THEIR INTEREST YOU'RE ALLOWED
TO SAY I GOT THIS LETTER- WHERE
IS THIS STUDENT OR BUSINESS
PERSON HAVE A PRAYER IT WAS IT
WAS AN IMPRESSIVE LETTER OR OR
NOT FOR THAT MATTER. THEY CAN
CREATE THEIR OWN POLICY AROUND.
THE TICKET CREATE THEIR OWN
POLICY FOR HOW TO REPORT THAT
THE LETTER WAS RECEIVED A
COMMUNIQUE. BETWEEN THE
ADMISSIONS OFFICE AND OTHERS
ABOUT. WHERE IN THE RANKING A
STUDENT MAY LIE. OUR TRICKY
BECAUSE IT DEPENDS ON WHO THE
ADMISSIONS OFFICE IS SPEAKING
WITH THEY MAY BE SPEAKING WITH
THE DEPARTMENT ON CAMPUS THAT
HAS A ROLE THAT THEY PLAY IN
DECIDING WHICH STUDENTS ARE
ADMITTED SO CERTAIN MAJORS DO A
SUPPLEMENTAL REVIEW OF OTHER
APPLICANTS TO THEIR PROGRAMS
AND THEY ARE ACTUALLY
PARTICIPANTS IN THE ADMISSIONS
PROCESS OF COMMUNICATION
BETWEEN THE ADMISSIONS OFFICE
AND ONE OF THOSE DEPARTMENTS
WOULDN'T NECESSARILY FALL INTO
A DANGEROUS ZONE BUT THERE MAY
BE OTHER PEOPLE ON CAMPUS WHO
RECEIVE THOSE CORRESPONDENTS
FOR WHICH IT WOULD NOT BE
APPROPRIATE FOR THE ADMISSIONS
OFFICE TO BE IN CONVERSATIONS
WITH SURE AND I CAN IMAGINE
THAT BEING FROM THE DEVELOPMENT
OFFICE SENT SOMETHING THERE
THAT- IS NOT IN. IN KIND OF A-
SO THAT WE WOULD THINK OF AS A
MERITED- WAY OF EXPRESSING
INTEREST OR OR QUALITIES THAT
WE WOULD WANT TO HAVE. BEEN IN
THE PROGRAM- I HAVE A LOT OF
RESPECT FOR JUST THE ENTIRETY
OF THE WORK OF THE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE AN EXHAUSTIVE APPROACH
THAT YOU HAVE. ONE OF THE
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE ABOUT-
HOW THE SUPPLIES IN THIS
INSTANCE. IS DID YOU USE- OTHER
UNIVERSITY MODELS FOR. DEALING
WITH THIS ISSUE DID YOU LOOK
OUTSIDE THE UC SYSTEM FOR WHAT
AND WHAT IN APPROACH SHOULD BE
FOR THE ADMISSIONS PROCESS
WHETHER IT WOULD BE. A PUBLIC
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM LIKE YOU SEE
LIKE UNIVERSITY OF MICHIGAN OR
OR SUNY- OR EVEN PRIVATE SECTOR
UNIVERSITIES THAT HAVE-
INSTANCES LIKE THIS WAY AND
THAT AS WELL. SO AS PART OF ANY
OUT OF IF YOU WERE GOING TO BE
LOOKING FOR BEST PRACTICES IN
THE FIELD THAT WE REVIEW. THERE
ARE NONE THAT WE SPECIFICALLY
REFER TO AN ARMADA AS THE
CRITERIA BY WHICH WE ASSESS THE
UC. WHAT WE WERE REFERRING TO
MOSTLY WHERE THE UC'S
PRINCIPLES AND ETHICS FOR IT
WHAT APPROPRIATE EMISSIONS
ACTIVITY WAS AND THEN A REVIEW
OF THE BUSINESS PRACTICES THAT
ARE SUPPOSED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE. PRINCIPLES AND ETHICS
ARE ADHERED TO AND THAT'S WHERE
WE SAW THE GAPS. AND IT'S WORTH
NOTING TO THE UNIVERSITY
DOESN'T DISAGREE WITH THE- THE
PRINCIPLE OF THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WERE MAKING IN
OTHER WORDS THAT CERTAIN
COMMUNICATIONS SHOULD JUST NOT
BE OCCURRING AS PART OF THE
ADMISSIONS PROCESS YEAH THANK
YOU FOR EXPLAINING THAT SO YOU
SEE ON THE BROADEST POLICY
LEVEL. HAS IT RIGHT IT WAS
IMPLEMENTATION OF THAT AND-
ADHERENCE TO THOSE STANDARDS
THAT THAT WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE NEW POLICIES
TO BE A BIT MORE GRANULAR AND
HOW YOU SEE FOLLOWS THOSE.
BROADER POLICIES. CORRECT WE
FIND NO FAULT WITH THE OVERALL
ETHICAL PRINCIPLES THAT THE
UNIVERSITY ESPOUSES THOSE ARE
THE RIGHT- NORTH STAR TO FOLLOW
BUT WHAT WE FOUND WAS THAT THEY
WERE FALLING DOWN ON THE
IMPLEMENTATION AND FOLLOW
THROUGH OF THOSE ETHICAL
PRINCIPLES. I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MISTER HARRIS. SO WE HAD A
MOTION BY DOCTOR CHOI. FOR A
SECOND I'M SORRY THE AUTHOR
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE SURE
YES I RESPECTFULLY ASK HER
NIVEAU. YEAH MOTION BY DOCTOR
CHOICE SECONDS AYE DR RUMBLE US
I COMMENDED AUTHOR FOR HER
DESIRE TO PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY
TO THE UC ADMISSION PROCESS AND
I APPRECIATE HER WILLINGNESS TO
WORK WITH MY STAFF. ON THE
PREVIOUSLY ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS
THE STATE AUDITOR AND COVERED
SIXTY FOUR CASES IN WHICH
INFLUENCES BEYOND THE ACADEMIC
MERIT FOR ACADEMIC POTENTIAL
THE STUDENT DETERMINE ADMISSION
DECISIONS AS PREVIOUSLY
INDICATED I'LL BE SUPPORTING
THIS BILL TODAY. HOPE TO THE
REGIONS AND THE UC OFFICE OF
THE PRESIDENT WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE STATE AUDITOR AND
THE LEGISLATURE TO ALLEVIATE
ANY ON GOING CONCERNS. THE
MOTION BEFORE US IS DO PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS. MADAM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA HI MEDINA HI CHARLIE.
CHOI I ARAMBULA ARAMBULA ADDING
BLOOM BLOOM HI GABRIEL IRWIN
HIGHLY LEVINE LEVINE I LOW
RUBIO RUBIO ATTY SANTIAGO
BALLADARES VALIDUS AT. THE VOTE
SEVEN ZERO THE LOTUS SEVEN ZERO
THAT BILL IS OUT I WILL KEEP IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THE
NEXT BILL IN FILE ORDER IS AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE FILE ITEM
FOR BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER IDEA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CARDIO WHEN YOU
ARE READY YOU MAY BEGIN. THANK
YOU MR CHAIRMAN MEMBERS OF YOUR
PERCENT AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
THREE WHICH CLARIFIES THAT THE
NINETY DAYS EMPLOYERS HAVE TO
CONDUCT AN INVESTIGATION SHOULD
BE WORKING DAYS EXCLUDING
WEEKENDS AND HOLIDAYS EXISTING
LAW ADDRESSES TIME LIMITS FOR
INVESTIGATIONS BUT AFTER NINETY
DAYS DISTRICTS ARE FORCED TO
BRING BACK EMPLOYEES. WHO
SHOULD REMAIN ON THE BASED ON
THE NATURE OF THE STATUS OF THE
ALLEGATIONS FOR THAT REASON
THIS BILL ALSO ALLOWS THE
ADMINISTRATIVE LEAVE TO BE
EXTENDED NO MORE THAN THIRTY
DAYS OF BOTH THE EMPLOYER AND
THE EMPLOYEE ARE IN AGREEMENT.
IN THE WAKE OF COVERT NINETEEN
A VAST MAJORITY OF EMPLOYEES
SHIFTED TO REMOTE WORK MAKING
IT DIFFICULT FOR EMPLOYERS TO
COMPLETE A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION THE COMPLEXITY OF
GATHERING INFORMATION
CONDUCTING INTERVIEWS AND
COMPILING INFORMATION HAS BEEN
FURTHER EXACERBATED BY THE
PANDEMIC. ADDITIONALLY
DEPENDING ON THE NATURE NUMBER
OF ALLEGATIONS INVESTIGATIONS
CAN NO LONGER CAN TAKE LONGER
THAN ANTICIPATED AB THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE PROVIDES MUCH
NEEDED RELIEF DURING THESE
DIFFICULT TIMES AND ENSURE
STUDENTS REMAIN SAFE
PARTICULARLY DURING THIS
OCCASION INVOLVING ALLEGATIONS
OF SEXUAL MISCONDUCT. I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK THE COMMITTEE
STAFFER WORKING WITH MY OFFICE
ON THIS BILL AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING TO WORK WITH ALL
STAKEHOLDERS AS OPPOSED AS IT
MOVES FORWARD. AVAILABLE TO
TESTIFY OVER THE PHONE IN
SUPPORT AS THEY BEGIN DONNA
WITH RESOLUTE COMPANY
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT.
THANK YOU MR LEO. EIGHT MORNING
THREE. A. T. T. OPERATOR THE
ONLY LEAD WITNESS CALLING IN
FOR A BI THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
IS DAVID KING DONNA- FROM
RESIDENT COMPANY ON BEHALF OF
THE LA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT MISTER CAN TURN OUT
WHEN YOU'RE READY PLEASE BEGIN.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN THIS IS THAT THEY
BEGIN TALKING ON BEHALF OF THE
LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT THE SPONSOR OF AB
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE. AT THIS
BILL AS THE ASSEMBLY WOMAN
REFLECTED IN HER OPENING
PROVIDE US WITH MUCH NEEDED
FLEXIBILITY INSURING THAT AARON
FOR EXAMINATION OF ALLEGED
MISCONDUCT BY ACCIDENT WILL EAT-
DID TO WORKING DUE TO THE
PANDEMIC. HOLIDAYS WEEKENDS IN
NATURAL DISASTERS HAS NEARLY
COMPRESS THE ACTUAL WORKING
TIME WITH IN THE CURRENT PERIOD
OF NINETY DAYS- THAT LAW ALLOWS
FOR THESE INVESTIGATION. TO
THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE TEMPLATE
CLARIFIED THAT DISTRICT
EMPLOYEES HAVE NINETY WORKING
DAYS TO COMPLETE ITS
INVESTIGATION. RATHER THAN THE
CURRENT LAW UNDEFINED NINETY
DAYS. THIS CHANGE ALLOW THE
EMPLOYER TO COMPLETE A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION THAT IS FAIR AT
ALL PART. AND AGAIN AT THE
ASSEMBLY WOMAN STATED THE
NINETY WORKING DAYS IS DEFINED
MONEY FOR FRIDAY EXCLUDING
WEEKENDS AND HOLIDAYS. FINALLY
THE BILL ALLOWS FOR BOTH. THE
EMPLOYER AND THE EMPLOYEE
AGREED TO A JOINT EXTENSION OF
THE NINETY WORKING DAYS TO
COMPLETE THE INVESTIGATION.
EVERYONE AT THE EXTENSION
DOESN'T EXCEED AN ADDITIONAL
THIRTY CALENDAR DAYS. SHKRELI
DEFEATED THE MUCH NEEDED SIX
DURING THE UNPRECEDENTED TIME
TO PROVIDE CRYSTAL CLEAR
STANDARD AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
FOR THESE REASONS WE ASK FOR
YOUR I THOUGHT. THANK YOU
MISTER KING DIANA WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENTS. SEE NO
WITNESSES IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBERS- CA NO WITNESSES AND
OPPOSITION IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER. C. NO WITNESS OR
CLEANERS IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER. SO WE'LL MOVE NOW TO
THE PHONE LINES ATG MODERATOR.
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT ON THE PHONE. AND AS A
REMINDER IF YOU ARE SPEAKING IN
SUPPORT PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. THE SPECIALIST WILL
PROVIDE YOU WITH YOUR LINE
NUMBER. AND PUT YOU BACK IN THE
QUEUE. WELL FIRST GO TO LINE
SIXTY SEVEN BUT- ONE MOMENT
PLEASE WE'RE HAVING SOME
TECHNICAL DIFFICULTIES. ONE
SIXTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
YOU ONE MOMENT PLEASE I'M
HAVING SOME TECHNICAL
DIFFICULTIES JUST ONE SECOND
THERE'S.
MY APOLOGIES DUE TO A
SYSTEM WHERE WE DO NOT HAVE A
ONE IN SPEAKING IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE HAS TIME. EIGHTEEN
T. OPERATOR ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. AND AFTER ANY
WITNESSES UP IN OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. WE HAVE NO ONE SPEAKING
IN OPPOSITION ANY YOU MAY
RECEIVE ANY TWEETERS MISTER.
MODERATOR. IF YOU WERE SPEAKING
IN A NEUTRAL POSITION ON THE
QUé ON THE MATTER PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. DNC
CHAIR WE HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP
AT THIS TIME OKAY WE WILL GO TO
THE COMMITTEE THEN FOR
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. I MAKE A
MOTION FOR APPROVAL. MOTION BY
DOCTOR CHOI. SECOND BY MR LOW-
AUTHORED LIKE TO MAKE A CLOSING
STATEMENT. THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIR AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY THREE
IS A NECESSARY AND TECHNICAL
FIX THAT ENABLE THE EMPLOYER TO
COMPLETE A THOROUGH
INVESTIGATION THAT IS FAIR TO
BOTH THE ACCUSER AND THE
ACCUSED AND I RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
TO THE AUTHOR THIS MEASURE AS
SHE SAID SPECIFIES NINETY DAY.
EMPLOYERS HAVE BEEN ORDERED TO
CONDUCT AN INVESTIGATION SHOULD
BE WORKING DAY. ADDITIONALLY
THIS MEASURE PROVIDES MORE TIME
TO CONDUCT. PERSONAL
INVESTIGATION. IF BOTH PARTIES
AGREE TO EXTEND THE
INVESTIGATION PERIOD I BELIEVE
THIS BILL IS STRAIGHTFORWARD
AND WILL PROVIDE THE CLARITY
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
AND THEIR EMPLOYEES NEED WHEN
DEALING WITH THE ALREADY
DIFFICULT SITUATION. WHERE A
MOTION BY DOCTOR TROYER SECOND
BY MR LOW THE MOTION BEFORE US
IS TO PASS THEM SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS THE PAST TO THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR. MEDINA HI
MEDINA HI CHOI HI CHOI I
ARAMBULA. BLOOM BLOOM I GABRIEL
IRWIN KILEY LEVINE. LEVINE I
LOW LOW I RUBIO. RUBIO I
SANTIAGO BALLADARES VALLADARES
HI. THE VOTE SEVEN ZERO THE
LOTUS SEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS
OUT I WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. THANK YOU TO
THE AUTHOR. THE NEXT BILL IN
FILE ORDERED TO BE HEARD IS AB
TWELVE SIXTY NINE FILE ITEM SIX
BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER GARCIA.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA WHEN YOU
ARE READY PLEASE PROCEED. NOT
NOT SEEN THE AUTHOR. YEAH OKAY
MR LEWIS HERE- OKAY ALL RIGHT.
MISTER LOWE WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
TO YOUR BILL. FILE ITEM NINE IF
YOU ARE READING. FILE ITEM NINE
A. B. EIGHT FORTY SIX. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES AB EIGHT FORTY SIX
WE AUTHORIZES SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNICORP
**** WITH PROJECT LABOR
AGREEMENTS TO UTILIZE JOB ORDER
CONTRACTING FOR CALACATTA
SMALLER CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS I
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW AT&T
MODERATED THE FIRST LEAD
WITNESS TO COLIN. AB EIGHT FOUR
SIXES DURING JEREMY SMITH A
LOBBYIST FOR THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA AFL-CIO MISTER SMITH
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR
TESTIMONY WHEN YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR CAN
EVERYBODY HEAR ME. WE CAN HEAR.
GREAT THANK YOU THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN OF THE
COMMITTEE CHAIRMAN SMITH HERE
ON BEHALF OF THE STATE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL OF
THE SPONSORS IN AB FORTY SIX.
THIS BILL SIMPLY EXTENDS THE
CLOUT THAT OFFLINE CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND K.
TWELVE DISTRICTS. THE LAST JOB-
COMPASSIONATE TOWARD JANUARY
FIRST TWENTY TWENTY SEVEN AT
HOWEVER ONE NEW TAXPAYER AND
LOOKED AT YOUR REQUIREMENTS OF
THE STATUTE. REQUIREMENT YOU
NEED A SKILLED ANDTRAINED
WORKFORCE. SPECIAL FROM THE
POLICY THAT THE STATE BUILDING
TRADES AND ADVOCATED FOR
NUMEROUS PIECES OF LEGISLATION.
THAT CONSTRUCTION WORK DONE FOR
PUBLIC ENTITIES WITH TAXPAYER
DOLLARS SHOULD NOT ONLY PROVIDE
MIDDLE CLASS WAGES AND BENEFITS
UNDER THE PREVAILING WAGE. BUT
ALSO EXPAND THE STATE
CONSTRUCTION WORKFORCE BY
REQUIRING YOU EXPENSES AND
YOU'RE A PERSON TO HAVE
GRADUATED FROM STATE. APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM. WE NEED
TO BE AWARE OF THE GROUNDWORK
OUT OF DELAY WILL PROVIDE OPERA.
THE RESIDENTS OF THE CALM OKAY
BACK IN. VETERANS WHEN.
EMANCIPATED YOUTH THE BOTTOM
THERE'S A IN OTHER CRITICAL.
THERE CRAPPIE NIKKI RESPECT
YOUR TO REMAINING. TOOL FOR A
JOBS ENCOURAGE. COMPETITION AND
MAX K. DOLLAR FROM PUBLIC WORKS
FINE. LIKE CASES THERE'S NOT A
LADY FIXED TRAINED WORKFORCE.
ENSURE TO BE FOUND WILL PROVIDE
WHAT HAPPENED WITH SIXTY
THOUSAND. CURRENTLY IN STATE
DETENTION PROGRAM. AND DURING.
EVEN WHERE THERE IS NOT A DELAY
FAR TO OUR PUBLIC EVENT IN.
FAILS GENERATE CALL LOCAL JOB
WITH APPEALING AND THE OF THE
OF THE TRADEMARK WORKING THAT.
CHAU REQUIREMENTS WON'T
CHALLENGE HIGH. TRAINED
WORKFORCE WILL BE. WHICH WILL
BRING PROJECT CAN YOU ON. AND
UNDER BUDGET IN THAT WORKERS
ARE. TRAINED ONLY IN CRAFT BY
THE LATE HEALTHCARE LOS. IN
IMPORTANTLY SURE. THE STATE
DEPARTMENT SYSTEM. BY PROVIDING
LOOKS BURKE THE JOURNEY THEIR
CRAFTING PROGRAM. OPENING SLOT
HI THEM FROM THE PAIN.
INCLUDING BE ORGANIZED BUT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER AND-
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR THIS LEAD
WITNESSED CALL IN FOR A H. FOUR
SIX IT'S PAST WAILING A
LOBBYIST FOR KOREAN GROUP AT.
LOS ADVOCACY THIS WHELAN
PROCEED WHEN YOUR READY. THANK
YOU ACCORDING TO MEMBERS WHALEN
ON BEHALF GUARDIAN GREW WE'RE
PROBABLY SUPPORTING A EIGHT
FORTY SIX- THE FILL THE SIX THE
CENTER DAY PER VERY. AND COFFEE
COOKER METHOD THAT IS USED BY
DOES OF K. TWELVE AND COLLEGES-
THE UPPER THE WITH A- EXPIRE AT
THE END OF THIS YEAR. GUARDIAN
PROVIDES JOB ORDER CONTRACTING
SERVICES TO THOUSANDS OF PUBLIC
SECTOR CLIENTS AROUND NORTH
AMERICA INCLUDING THE LA
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THE
LOS ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. AND OUR CLIENTS ARE
ABLE TO EXECUTE PROJECTS WITH
SIGNIFICANT COST SAVINGS. OVER
THE TRADITIONAL DESIGN BID
BUILD METHOD MAKING COMPLETE
PROJECT IN HALF THE TIME OF THE
TRADITIONAL PROCUREMENT PROCESS
THE STATE'S PUBLIC AGENCIES
TIME AND MONEY. IN OUR SCHOOLS
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES SHOULD
BE ABLE TO CONTINUE USING THIS
VALUABLE PROCESS HAPPEN ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS. ABOUT JOB ORDER
CONTRACT THANK YOU. THANK YOU-
NOW MOVE THE PUBLIC COMMENT. I
SEE NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN
THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER NO
WITNESSES IN THE OPPOSITION IN
THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER. NO
TWEETERS IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER WILL MOVE THE PHONE
LINES. AT&T MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE. IF YOU ARE IN SUPPORT OF
THIS MEASURE PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. WE WILL
OPEN UP LINE SEVENTY ONE. QUIET
PLEASE. ONE SEVENTY ONE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE PICK UP
YOUR HANDSET ARE CHECKING YOU
FEATURE. WE WILL MOVE ON IF
THERE ARE ANY- SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT OF THIS PLEASEPRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME.
MISTER CHAIRMAN WE HAVE KNOWING
QUEUING UP ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION MISTER MODERN. IF
YOU WERE IN OPPOSITION OF THIS
MEASURE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. WE DO HAVE SOMEONE
QUEUING UP ONE MOMENT WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEIR LINE NUMBER. WE
WILL OPEN LINE NINETY ONE GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE RICHARD MARX AND FOR
THE WESTERN ELECTRICAL
CONTRACTORS ASSOCIATION WE
OPPOSE THE INITIAL INSTALLATION
WE THINK THAT THE DELAY
PROVISIONS DEFEAT. THE VALUE
THAT JOB ORDER CONTRACTING
OFFERS TO SCHOOL DISTRICTS IT
SHOULD BE REMOVED FROM THE
LEGISLATION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
ANY OTHER WHICH IN OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE NO IN A Q. AND THAT AT
THIS TIME DO WE HAVE ANY
TWEETERS IN THE ON THE LINE.
THIRTY PEOPLE IN- WITH A
NEUTRAL POSITION ON THIS PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND ONCE AGAIN MR SURE WE
HAVE KNOWN IN Q. VERY GOOD WILL
NOW MOVE TO QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. C.
NINE I WOULD GO BACK TO THE
AUTHOR IF HE'D LIKE TO MAKE A
CLOSING STATEMENT. I RESPECT
ESCRIBIR I WANT TO THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FOR IT I WAS HAPPY TO SUPPORT
SB SIX EIGHTEEN SEVERAL YEARS
AGO EXTENDING THE JOB ORDER
CONTRACTING AUTHORITY TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND I'M
HAPPY TO CONTINUE EXTENDING THE
AUTHORITY WITH THIS
LEGISLATION. DO I HAVE A MOTION.
MOVED BY MISS RUBIO. SECOND BY
MISTER BLOOM MADAM SECRETARY BE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA I CHOI NO SORRY NO
ARAMBULA. BLOOM BLOOM HI
GABRIEL IRWIN HIGHLY LEVINE LOW.
LOW I RUBIO. RUBIO I SANTIAGO
VALIDUS HELLO THERE IS NO. THE
VOTE IS FOR TO ON CALL. OKAY
THE VOTE WAS FOUR ZERO THAT
BILL IS ON CALL THANK THE
AUTHOR AND WE WILL NOW GO BACK
IN FILE ORDERED TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER SIX MISS GARCIA A. B.
TWELVE SIXTY NINE. GARCIA
PLEASE PROCEED WITH YOUR BREAD
THANK YOU I APPRECIATE IT I
WANT TO BEGIN BY ACCEPTING THE
COMMITTEES RECOMMENDED
AMENDMENTS ELENA PAGE FOR THE
ANALYSIS AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR WORK. ON
THIS BILL. THE BILL WOULD ALLOW
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
THE NECESSARY INFORMATION AND
DATA FOR THE DEVELOPMENT OF A
STATE WIDE DEFINITION OF PARITY
FOR PART TIME FACULTY THAT CAN
BE APPLIED. AT THE LOCAL
CONTENTS THE LOCAL LEVEL. AB
TWELVE SIXTY NINE WHICH IS
GOING TO SPONSORED BY THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
AND- THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION
OF TEACHERS WILL HELP IMPLEMENT
EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL WORK. FOR
VALUABLE PART TIME COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FACULTY. PHYSICALLY THE
BILL WOULD COLLECT DATA. AND IT
WOULD HELP CLOSE THE EXISTING
PARITY GAP. OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE CRUCIAL PART OF
THE STATE'S HIGHER EDUCATION
SYSTEM. THE CURRENT EXPECTATION
A PART TIME FACULTY NOT ONLY
HARMS OUR FACULTY AND OUR
INSTITUTION BUT IT DAMAGES OUR
STUDENTS- WHO HAVE LIMITED
ACCESS TO THEIR PART TIME
FACULTY THE BILL APPLY FOR. OUR
PART TIME COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FACULTY AND ENSURE EQUAL PAY
FOR EQUAL WORK I WILL SAY AS
SOMEONE WHO HAS WORKED AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE I SEE MY
PUREST REBELLING- TWO PIECE-
THEIR INCOME TOGETHER BY HAVING
JOBS ON DIFFERENT CAMPUSES- AND
STRUGGLING TO BE ACCESSIBLE TO
THEIR STUDENTS BECAUSE OF THAT
AND SO THIS PARTY. WILL GO A
LONG WAY FOR THEIR QUALITY OF
LIFE BUT ALSO FR THEIR ABILITY
TO SERVE THE STUDENTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MR GARCIA. THE
FIRST LEAD WITNESS CALLING IN.
DOES MISTER ERIC HOW DO YOU
MAGGI. PRESIDENT OF THE-
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ASSOCIATION.
MR COM YOU MARGIE PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU. BARBEL TERROR BUT
ENOUGH BY CHURCHILL A AND
MEMBERS OF THE HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS ERIC HOW
YOU MIGHT BE AND I AM
REPRESENTING THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ASSOCIATION WHICH IS
THE HIGHER EDUCATION AFFILIATE
OF THE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION. WE ARE HONORED TO
SPONSOR AB TWELVE SIXTY NINE
AND A FATHER ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GARCIA FOR TAKING ON THE
IMPORTANT ISSUE OF PARITY FOR
PART TIME FACULTY AT OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. PART TIME
FACULTY COMPRISED 70% A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FACULTY AND
TEACHER APPROXIMATELY 50% OF
THE CLASS OF. THIS HAS CREATED
A DYNAMIC IN WHICH THE FACULTY
THAT ARE MOST LIKELY TO BE
SERVING THE MOST BY FIRST AND
LARGEST STUDENT BODY IN THE
WORLD ARE NOT GIVEN THE RESPECT
AND TOOLS TO POLICE FOR THEIR
STUDENTS. THE LACK OF PARITY IN
REGARDS TO PAY OFFICE HOURS
SHARED GOVERNANCE AND A MYRIAD
OF OTHER FACTORS. HAVE LED TO
OUR PART TIME FACULTY BEING
EXPLOITEDAND USED AS A COST
SAVINGS MEASURE. THE POINT
ASIAN HARM ARE PART TIME
FACULTY AND OUR INSTITUTIONS.
BUT A TENTATIVE OUR STUDENTS
FAR MORE AT THE END LIMITED
ACCESS TO PART TIME FACULTY WHO
ARE WORKING MULTIPLE JOBS TO
EARN A LIVING. AND YOUR NOT
COMPENSATED SUFFICIENTLY OR AT
ALL OUR OFFICE HOURS TO MEET
WITH STUDENTS. MOST PART TIME.
ARE NOT PROVIDED ADEQUATE SPACE
ON CAMPUS. THEY ARE NOT
INCLUDED IN THE SHARED
GOVERNANCE WORK THAT INFORMS
THE COLLEGES DECISIONS AND
CURRICULUM. AND THEY ARE OFTEN
NOT COMPENSATED FOR THE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT AND
OTHER TRAININGS REQUIRED BY THE
STATE AND FOR ACCREDITATION.
THE STATUS QUO HURT PART TIME
FACULTY AND NEGATIVELY IMPACT
THE STUDENTS THEY SERVE.
RESEARCH SHOWS THAT WHEN
STUDENTS ARE STRESSFUL WITH THE
CLEAN THEIR CAMPUSES BY
PROFESSORS WHO HAVE CONSISTENT
OFFICE HOURS OFFICE SPACE AND
INVOLVEMENT IN SHARED
GOVERNANCE ACTIVITIES AND OUR
OVERALL PART OF THE FABRIC OF
THE COLLEGE THOSE STUDENTS
PERFORM BETTER IN A VARIETY OF
WAYS. AB TWELVE FIFTY NINE
WOULD CREATE PARITY FOR PART
TIME FACULTY OF THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO THAT
PEOPLE WORK RESULTS IN EQUAL
PAY AND WOULD BE A TREMENDOUS
BENEFIT TO OUR STUDENTS. WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR I'VE
FOUGHT FOR AB TWELVE SIXTY NINE.
THANK YOU EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR
THE SECOND LEAD WITNESS CALLING
IT IS MISS LINDA JOHN CHAIR OF
THE C. F. T. PART TIME FACULTY.
IT'S JAN IF YOU WOULD BEGIN
WHEN YOU ARE READY. THANK YOU
AT OTHER VOTER MEDINA AND
MEMBERS OF THE HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS NOT A
CHANCE I'M ONE OF THOSE PART
TIME FACULTY MEMBERS JUST
REACHING OUT OF FULL TIME
LIVING I'M GOING TO SEVERAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. ANOTHER
CULTURE OF FEAR KEY PART TIME
FACULTY COMMITTEE OF VICE
PRESIDENT GORE FIFTY AS WELL
PRESIDENT OF THE COLLEGE AND IN
FACT IN THE FEDERATION. I'M
HERE TODAY REPRESENTING THE PSG
THAT'S ONE OF THE HOW CO
SPONSORS TO AB. TWELVE SIXTY
NINE. ALL LIKE TO THANK. ONE
GARCIA FOR BRING THE BILL
STANDING WITH US AND BUDGET
REPORT ISSUE. AB TWO HUNDRED
CENTURY ABOUT CREE PARITY FOR
THE PART TIME FOR. AND CAN YOU
CALL. SO THAT EQUAL WITH IN THE
COMPARE. CURRENTLY PARODIES
GERMAN- DIFFERENTIAL BETWEEN
JUST. PART TIME FACULTY ARE
PAID LESS THAN HER FULL TIME
COLLEGES. YOUR BENEFITS YEAH.
HI AND WE EVEN ABOUT OUT THE
BASED ON. WHAT PART OF YOUR
SIXTY SEVEN OF A TIME WORKLOAD
GENERAL ONLY BECAUSE TIME THE
YOU TO COURSES. NOT THE TIME TO
PUT GRADING FOR HELP OUTSIDE.
BE PUT PART OF THE CAMP CAN YOU.
AT A RESULT IN MANY PARTS
FACULTY MEMBERS ARE EX AS A
CALL. MEASURE AND ARE IN IF NOT
ALWAYS AS EXCITED SECOND CLASS
IN THE. ACADEMIC WORLD.
EXPLICATION HARMS OUR PARTY
FACULTY ARE INTO. AND THE REAL
DAMAGE TO OUR STATE. AND THEY
HAVE UNLIMITED TO PART TIME
BACK. GET STARTED. CRITICAL
ISSUES IN TWELVE NINE WITH
REQUIRE THAT THE CHANCE OF
COLLECT AND I PART TIME. CARRY
DATA EACH COLLEGE. BOB ONE
TWENTY TWO TWO. I DON'T THINK
TO OF THE OF FROM TIME FACULTY
CAN BE TO CON. FINALLY TWELVE
FIFTY NINE WOULD REQUIRE THE
COMMUTER COLLEGES. TO GET BY
TWO SEVEN EITHER BY THE FIRST
OF NECESSARY TO THE- COMMITTEE
CALL PART TIME FACULTY. EQUAL
PAY FOR IT WORK AND YOU TO OKAY
FOR CLEANING BECAUSE- I URGE AT
FIVE OH I'M AT TWELVE SIXTY
NINE. AND I THINK YOU. THANK
YOU MR CHAN WE WERE NOW MOVE
TO. COMMENT SEE NO. IN THE BACK
THE CHAMBER AND- IN FAVOR. NOR
WITNESS IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER AND- NO TO. WE WILL GO
TO THE LINE. EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR IS THERE ANY
WITNESSES AND- SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE. AND IF YOU'RE SPEAKING
IN SUPPORT PRESS ONE NINE ZERO
AT THIS TIME. THE FIRST QUOTE
ONLINE SEVENTY ONE GO AHEAD
PLEASE. SHE THANK YOU HI MY
NAME IS OBVIOUSLY MANY BERSERK
AND I'M AFFECTED A MEMBER AT
AMERICAN RIVER COLLEGE IN
SACRAMENTO I'M ALSO THE FACULTY
UNION PRESIDENT I WOULD LIKE TO
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I.
BOATS ON DID THEY ARE IMPORTANT
BILLS THAT WERE EVEN ABLE WHAT
WILL BE THE FIRST STEP WELL MY
PART TIME FACULTY COLLEAGUES TO
HAVE EQUAL PAY FOR EQUAL WORK
AND HAVE JOB. STABILITY THANK
YOU. THANK YOU WELCOME NEXT TO
LINE. FIVE BY NINETY FIVE YOUR
LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE.
WILL MOVE TO LINE NINETY SIX GO
AHEAD PLEASE. GOOD MORNING
MISTER TURNER MEMBERS RON RAPP
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
WE DON'T HAVE A FORMAL DECISION
AT THIS TIME BUT OUR
LEGISLATIVE COMMITTEE HAS
RECOMMENDED A SUPPORT AND OUR
BOARD MEETS ON SATURDAY. THANK
YOU. BY. NINETY SEVEN. ALL ALL
RIGHT NINETY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
WHAT I CAN HEAR YOU BY NINETY
SEVEN GO AHEAD HELLO MY NAME IS
JOHN GOTTI AND I'M AN ADJUNCT
FACULTY MEMBER WE HAVE COLLEGE
I'VE BEEN TEACHING PART TIME
FOR OVER TWENTY YEARS I GUESS
YOU COULD CALL ME PERMA TEMPS-
THIS BILL IS WELL OVERDUE I
DON'T REALLY WANT TO- MY- THAT
IT RIGHT NOW IT'S JUST YOUR
NAME YOUR POSITION AND WHERE
YOU'RE FROM SO THE MODERATOR.
LET'S GO TO THE NEXT CALLER
PLEASE. WE'LL GO TO LINE THIRTY
NINE GO AHEAD PLEASE. YES MY
NAME IS BOB STOCKWELL AND A
FACULTY MEMBER AT THE IN THE
COLLEGE I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB
TWELVE SIXTY NINE THANK YOU.
LINE. NINETY FIVE. GOOD
AFTERNOON STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ON
BEHALF OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN SUPPORT.
THERE ARE THOSE OTHER LINES IN
Q. MISTER CHAIRMAN IS GLAD IF
WE HAVE ANY CALLERS IN
OPPOSITION MISTER MODERN. ANY
CALLERS IN OPPOSITION TO THIS
MEASURE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. PLEASE MAKE SURE
YOUR PHONE IS ON MUTE IT AND
THAT YOU ARE. A PICKING UP YOUR
HANDSET BEFORE PRESSING ANY
BUTTONS. WE HAVE NO ONE QUEUING
UP MISTER MISTER ANY CALLERS
AND THE TWEENER POSITION. ENTER
ANY CALLERS IN A NEUTRAL
POSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO AT THIS TIME. HEARING NONE
HELLO IN QUEUE AT THIS TIME
HEARING NONE WILL GO TO THE
ULTIMATE. WE GO TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. SECOND AND- JOE I
WOULD LIKE TO. MAKE A COMMENT
ON THIS SO AS A FORMER ADJUNCT
FACULTY MEMBER AND A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE FOR SEVENTEEN YEARS-
THIS IS A VERY- RELATED- BAIL I
HOPE FOR THIS CAN GO BACK TO
HER AFTER RETROACTIVELY AND-
PROBABLY BETTER. WILL UNDERPAID
OF MY SERVICE- ANYWAY ENGINE
FACULTY MEMBERS ARE ARE
UTILIZED AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES OUT BUT I THINK AT
THIS BILL- WILL ORDER- TAKE
CARE OF THEM- MORE FAIRLY AND-
COMMITTED COLLEGES SO ORDER OR
TRY TO- MMHM MMHM IN THE
NECESSARY FOR TIME FACULTY
MEMBER SO RATHER THAN TAKING.
ADVANTAGE OF- LOW PAID ADJUNCT
FACULTY MEMBER SO WITH THAT I
MAKE A MOTION. AND THEN- MISTER
SEA OF YOU LIKE TO MAKE A
CLOSING STATE. AT ONE AT THE
BUZZER CHOI FOR HIS SERVICE AND
TAKE HIS COMMENTS OF MY CLOSING
COMMENTS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU. I ALSO
WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD. AND
FOR. ACCEPTING THE AMENDMENTS
IS OUTLINED ON PAGE FOUR. OF
THE ANALYSIS. AND ASK HER TO
CONTINUE TO WORK WITH THE
COMMITTEE REGARDING THE
CONCERNS. OUTLINED ON PAGE
FOUR. AND PAGE FIVE. AND I WANT
TO. JOIN OUR VICE CHAIR DR
CHOI. IN SAYING THAT I AM ALSO.
A HUGE ADVOCATE FOR PARITY OF
PART TIME FACULTY. MYSELF
HAVING BEEN A PART TIME
FACULTY- SO I VERY
WHOLEHEARTEDLY SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE TODAY. I HAD A MOTION.
BY DOCTOR CHOI AND THE SECOND
BY MR LOW THE MOTION BEFORE US
IS DO PASSES A MAN.
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MADAM
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEDINA HI MEDINA HI
CHOI AYE SORRY AYE ARAMBULA.
BLOOM BLOOM HI GABRIEL IRWIN
KILEY LEVINE HELLO LOW I RUBIO
RUBIO I SANTIAGO VALIDUS. THE
VOTE IS FIVE ZERO THE BILL'S ON
CALL. THE VOTERS FIVE ZERO THE
BILL WILL BE ON CALL THANK YOU
MS GARCIA. THE NEXT BILL IN
FILE ORDER IS AB TWELVE NINETY
FILE ITEM EIGHT BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WE- MR LEE PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS- THIS BILL ASSEMBLY
BILL TWELVE NINETY SIX TO
ENSURE THAT STUDENT VOICES ARE
REPRESENTED ON THE SUIT
CALIFORNIA STUDENT AID
COMMISSION THIS BILL ACT-
STUDENTS THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION SO THAT THERE WILL
BE ONE FROM EACH TYPE OF HIGHER
EDUCATION. INSTITUTION WAS
SEVEN EIGHT COMMISSION
INVESTORS STATE AUTHORIZED
FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS TO
STUDENTS AT COLLEGES
UNIVERSITIES AS WELL AS TRADE
INVITATIONAL SCHOOLS CURRENTLY
THE STUDENT AID COMMISSION. HAS
TO REPRESENT THE TWO STUDENTS
THAT REPRESENT FOUR DIFFERENT
ENTITIES AND ARE APPOINTED ON A
ROTATING BASIS THE FOR. I SAID
THEY'RE READY THE NEEDS OF
STUDENTS AND ATTENDING
DIFFERENT SESSIONS CAN VARY
GREATLY AS FINANCIAL AID NEEDS
AND EXPERIENCES FOR STUDENTS
ATTENDING A PRIVATE STATION
MAYBE ME VERY. THE VERY DAY
THAN US IN ATTENDING COLLEGE.
AB TWELVE NINETY WILL INCREASE
THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS MEMBERS
OF THE SENATE COMMISSION FROM
TWO TO FOUR. AND BY HAVING ONCE
A MEMBER FROM EACH HAVE
INSTITUTION THIS IN A
COMMERCIAL BETTER REFLECTS
STUDENT NEEDS AS A FORMER
STUDENT. CONSIDER LEADER MYSELF
I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT MORSON
VOICES AT THE TABLE ARE ALWAYS
A GOOD THING. I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR YOUR I. BOATS AND ALSO
I WILL BE HAVING TO HAND SIDE
SECOND MANY A STUDENT FROM FROM
THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE. OF
THE ARTS WILL BE TESTIFYING. ON
THE PHONE IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL TODAY. THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER. EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR
THE LEAD WITNESS TO COLLINS FOR
A B. TWELVE NINETY IS MISTER
TEN. SEGMENT NEED A STUDENT OF
THE CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE OF THE
ARTS PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU
ARE READY. TO THE WITNESS. GOOD
EVENING- ARE GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN JEAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE FAMILY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE MY NAME IS CAMPAIGN
MONEY AND I AM A FOUR YEAR
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT AT THE
CALIFORNIA INSTITUTE OF THE
ARTS FROM PALM DESERT
CALIFORNIA I AM SPEAKING TODAY
REPRESENTING THE INDEPENDENT
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES ADVOCATE
PROGRAM- I CAPPED AT A FIRST
GROUP OF STUDENTS FROM VARIOUS
INDEPENDENT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES THROUGHOUT THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. IT'S MY
PLEASURE TO SPEAK BEFORE YOU IN
SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE NINETY
FIVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER ALEX
PLEASE BUT OVER TWENTY THOUSAND
CALTRANS STUDENT AT K. I. T. T.
U. INSTITUTIONS HAVING A
PERMANENT PLACE FOR THE
STUDENTS HE'S BACK WITH CONFIRM
THE NOTION THAT ALL STUDENTS
SHOULD BE REPRESENTED WHEN IT
COMES TO ADVANCING STUDENT
CENTER HIGHER EDUCATION
POLICIES PROGRAMS AND
INITIATIVES MY I CAN'T COPE
BURKE AND I BELIEVE THIS BILL
IS GOOD PUBLIC POLICY AT TO
PROVIDE STUDENTS FROM EACH
HIGHER EDUCATION SEGMENT IT
CARMEN VOICE ON THE CALIFORNIA
HEARING AID COMMISSION. AND
INFLUENTIAL BODY THAT
ADMINISTERS THE STATE OPERATES
IN FINANCIAL AID PROGRAMS THAT
HELP MAKE IT POSSIBLE FOR US TO
ATTEND THAT INSTITUTION
OPPORTUNITIES AS THE FIRST
GENERATION STUDENT MY FAMILY TO
ATTEND COLLEGE THE ONLY PERSON
IN MY FAMILY TO PURSUE A DEGREE
IN THE ARTS I'M COMMITTED TO
USING MY EDUCATION AND PASSION
WITHIN THE FIELD THAT APARTMENT
HEALTH EXPRESSIONS ACTIVITY AND
ACTIVISM. I AM FOREVER GRATEFUL
FOR THE CALIFORNIA PROGRAM
WHICH AFFORDED ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ATTEND MY FIRST
WITH INSTITUTION AND STAY CLOSE
TO HOME IN CALIFORNIA I'VE USED
MY TIME IN COLLEGE TO PLAY AN
ACTIVE ROLE IN MY COMMUNITY ON
GOING IMPROVEMENT AND ITS MANY
FACETS OF THE LOCAL AND STATE
LEVEL- MY EXPERIENCE SERVING IN
VARIOUS LEADERSHIP ROLES
RANGING FROM STUDENT BODY
PRESIDENT TO WORKING WITH A I.
T. TO YOU AT THE CAL GRANT
STUDENT AMBASSADOR. ADVOCATING
FOR A POLICY BASED CALTRANS TO
WORK I FOUND THAT STUDENTS
CLOSER TO CHALLENGES CAN
CONTRIBUTE AN ESSENTIAL POINTS
TO EXCLUSION THAT IS WHY I'M
DEEPLY INTERESTED IN FINDING
WAYS HELPED OPEN IN MY
COMMUNITY WE URGE YOUR PASSAGE
IN SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE NINETY
AT THE PORT'S FUTURE STUDENTS
OF ALL HIGHER EDUCATION SECTORS
TO HAVE A VOICE AN ACTIVE. ROLE
IN THE POLICY DECISION MAKING
ACROSS THAT'S- THE LATEST
TUESDAY FUNDED. AID THANK YOU.
THANK YOU WE WILL MOVE THE PUB
COMMENT C. NO WITNESS IN THE
BACK OF THE CHAIR- IN FAVOR NOR
NOT. OR ANY WE GO TO THE LINE.
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES AND SOME. IF YOU
WERE SPEAKING SUPPORT PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE GATHER THEIR INFORMATION. WE
WILL FIRST GO TO LINE ONE ZERO
FOUR GO AHEAD. RIGHT NOT
CONTINUE THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LIKE A CALIFORNIA REPS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SEVEN THREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE
ZERO THREE. SH PERHAPS YOU
MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS RON RAPP
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
IN SUPPORT. WE'LL GO TO LINE.
ONE ZERO ONE. GOOD AFTERNOON
SUSAN RAN LEGISLATIVE
COORDINATOR AT THE ASSOCIATION
OF INDEPENDENT CALIFORNIA
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES IN
STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWELVE
NINETY THANK YOU. BY. NINETY
EIGHT. AFTERNOON HEARING
COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME IS
SHAYLA A BIT MATTER AND I'M A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT FROM
NOT PENDANT ON YOUR COLLEGE AND
I'M CALLING IN TO REQUEST THE
USE OR. AB. TWELVE NINE. MISTER
CHAIR WE HAVE NO ONE ELSE IN
QUEUE FOR SUPPORT. ANY CALLERS
IN OPPOSITION. TO VOICE YOUR
OPPOSITION TO THIS MEASURE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT
THIS TIME. MISTER CHAIRMAN WE
HAVE KNOWN QUEUING UP AT THIS
TIME ANY TWEETERS. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO SUPPORT A NEUTRAL
POSITION PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN
ZERO. AND AGAIN KNOWING DOING
UP SO THE PARTY WE DO HAVE ONE
TEARING UP AT THIS TIME. HE
WILL WAIT FOR WORK WHILE WE
PROVIDE THEIR LINE NUMBER TO
THEM. WE'LL GO TO LINE ONE ZERO
SIX GO AHEAD PLEASE. HELLO MY
NAME IS WHATEVER TODAY AGAIN
THE COLLEGE AND I FULLY SUPPORT.
EIGHTY ONE TWENTY ONE TO BE
DONATED OF. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER CALLERS MISTER MODERN. NO
ONE ELSE IS GET UP AT THIS TIME
SIR OKAY WE WILL THEN GO TO
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. I SECOND THE MOTION
CHAIR. OKAY WE HAD A MOTION BY
MR LOW SECOND BY DOCTOR CHOI
BUT AS THE OTHER ONE IT GIVE A
CLOSING COMMENT STATUS
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL. THANK
YOU I SUPPORT THIS BILL STUDENT
ATTENDING FOUR FOUR SEGMENTS
HAVE DIFFERENT PERSPECTIVES AND
HAVING STUDENT MEMBERS
REPRESENTING EACH SEGMENT
BRINGS PARITY FOR ALL STUDENTS
AND WILL ALLOW FOR MORE
ACCURATE REPRESENTATION. OF OUR
STUDENTS WE HAD A MOTION BY.
DOCTOR CHOICE SECOND BY MR LOW
THE MOTION BEFORE US I SUPPOSE
A- NO OTHER WAY AROUND YEAH.
MOTION BY MISTER LOS TAKEN BY
DR CHOI THE MOTION BEFORE US IS
DO PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MADAM SECRETARY COULD
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI. AYE
CHU AYE AYE ARAMBULA. BLOOM
BLOOM I GABRIEL- WHEN KILEY
LEVINE LOW LOW I RUBIO RUBIO I
SANTIAGO VALDEZ. THE VOTE IS
FIVE ZERO BILLS ON CALL. VOTERS
FIVE ZERO THE BILL IN IS ON
CALL WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. THE NEXT ITEM
TO BE HEARD IN FILE ORDER IS AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO FILE ITEM
TEN BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOW.
PLEASE PROCEED ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WHEN YOU ARE READY. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH CALLING TO MEMBERS AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO WOULD
ELIMINATE CALVARY COLLEGE WE
WANT TO ENSURE THAT WE HAVE THE
TYPE OF ACCOUNTABILITY AND
TRANSPARENCY IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA RESPECTFULLY ASK
PRIVATE AND ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU
MR LOW AT T. MODERATOR THE
FIRST LEAD WITNESS IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO. IS
MICHAEL YOUNG LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS MISTER
YOUNG PLEASE BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE
READY. YOU SHARE MEMBERS THAT
ARE MICHAEL YOUNG WITH THE
CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS ON THE FINANCE FIELD-
WHILE WE AGREE WITH THE GOAL TO
CALIBRATE WHICH IS TO PROVIDE
EASILY ACCESSIBLE SIXTY
PROGRAMS TO. UNEMPLOYED UNDER
EMPLOYED ADULT STUDENT WE DO
NOT BELIEVE THAT A GRAND CAL IS
OUT RIGHT WITH NEEDED TO
ACHIEVE THE GOALS D. SEVEN TO
DISTRICT COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM ALREADY OFFERS
SIGNIFICANT ONLINE PROGRAMS
STUDENT. EVEN WELL BEFORE THE
NINETEEN PANDEMIC FOR EXAMPLE
OF THAT CALIFORNIA VIRTUAL
CAMPUS THROUGH THE ONLINE
EDUCATION INITIATIVE IS A
COLLABORATIVE EFFORT AMONG THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
OFFERING ROBUST TO HIGH QUALITY
ONLINE COURSES. ADDITIONALLY
THE SAN DIEGO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT- CONTINUING EDUCATION
TO BE LAUNCHED I KIND OF HAD TO
ME WHICH IS COMPLETELY FREE
FULLY ONLINE AND- FULLY
COMPREHENSIVE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
BUILT TO SERVE A NONTRADITIONAL
STUDENT- SO DECIDED EXAMPLES
AND HOWEVER WE'VE SEEN-
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT AND
ABOUT. ABOUT A HUNDRED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN TAXPAYER
CLIENT INTENDED ON GOING FINE-
MEN. TEN MILLION DOLLAR IN A
LONG PLAN- FOR CALIBRATE WHICH
AN- HAS FAILED TO REACH GOLD
BINGE AND WATER INTO CLICK IF
ALL. ALREADY BIGELOW THROUGH
THE CALIFORNIA COLLEGES AND
DIRECT VIOLATION OF A LAW-
ADDITIONALLY AFTER ABOUT THREE
YEARS OF OPERATION REPEATING
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
OF TAXPAYER FUNDS. ACCOUNT
RIGHT IT'S ONLY ISSUE ABOUT
THIRTY THREE CERTIFICATE TWENTY
NINE TO BE DIVORCED MEANWHILE
THE ENTIRE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
SYSTEM WITH ABOUT TWO MILLION
STUDENTS MOVE COMPLETELY ONLINE
OR ALMOST COMPLETELY ONLINE
GRECO THE NINETEEN. MAKING
CLEAR THAT MANY OF THE COLLEGES
WILL CONTINUE TO PROVIDE
SIGNIFICANT ONLINE COURSES AND
PROGRAMS YEAH AND THEN- THE
CONTINUED INVESTMENT OF OUR
LIMITED STATE FUNDING FOR THIS
BILL EXPERIMENT CAL BRIGHT.
SEEMS TO BE AN APPROPRIATE USE
OF OUR LIMITED BY STATE
CALIFORNIA'S YOUR REDIRECT
THOSE RESOURCES REDIRECT-
SPINE- BACK TO LOCALLY
ACCOUNTABLE WILL BE ACCREDITED
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS TO
EXPAND THEIR ONLINE PROGRAMS
AND RESOURCES. TO HELP ENSURE
STUDENT SUCCESS WE URGE AN IDOL
ONE EIGHTY FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
YOUNG EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR THE
SECOND LEAD WITNESS AND SUPPORT
IS WENDY BRILL PRESIDENT ELECT
FOR THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA. COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND SHARE PHOTOGRAPHY AT THE
COLLEGES. OF THE CANYON. MS
BROWN. WHEN YOU'RE READY PLEASE
PROCEED. THE MORNING H. AND
COMMITTEE MEMBER MY IS WENDY A
ONE COOP AND I'M JUST. OF THE
FACT THAT THE- OF THE CAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND A- AT
CALL OF THE- I'M ASKING FOR THE
PASSAGE OF EIGHTEEN FOURTEEN
THIRTY TWO WHICH WOULD. WHICH
WOULD MAKE CALIBRATION
OPERATIVE AT THE END OF THE
TWENTY TWENTY TO TWENTY THREE
ACADEMIC YEAR. IN TWO THOUSAND
AND EIGHTEEN I SAT BEFORE THE
SENATE BUDGET SUB COMMITTEE ON
EDUCATION. AND SHARED FACT
CONCERN ABOUT THE NEWLY
PROPOSED FULLY ONLINE COLLEGE.
THANKS FACT TIME THE STATE HAS
A LOT OF A HUNDRED AND FORTY
MILLION IN FUNDING TO THE
COLLEGE WITH LITTLE TO SHOW FOR
IT. CALIBRATE HAS SPENT THREE
YEARS AND APPROXIMATELY SEVENTY
FIVE MILLION DOLLARS. TO WARD
TWENTY NINE STUDENTS. WITH
THIRTY FIVE CREDENTIALS.
PARKING CHARACTER LAST YEAR
COLLEGE OF THE CAN HAD A J.
FUND BUDGET OF A HUNDRED AND
TWENTY FOUR MILLION. WE SERVED
OVER THIRTY THREE THOUSAND
STUDENTS. AWARDED OVER TWO
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
CERTIFICATE AND THREE THOUSAND
DEGREES. THOUGH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGES ARE SIGNIFICANTLY
UNDERFUNDED WE HAVE BEEN
PARTICULARLY RESOURCEFUL AND
HELPING STUDENTS SUCCEED. ONE
CALBERT WAS CREATED THE
LEGISLATIVE MANDATED THAT IT
PROGRAM NOT DUPLICATE THE
PROGRAMS THAT ARE EXISTING
COLLEGES. CURRENTLY CALIBRATE
POPPERS MEDICAL CODING CYBER
SECURITY HI HE SEE OUR AND BUT
YOU'RE ALSO OFFERED AT MANY OF
OUR SCHOOLS. FURTHERMORE THE
MEDICAL CODING PATHWAY
CALIBRATE THE NAGO PROGRAMS
HAVE BEEN CLOSED TO NEW
ENROLLMENT SINCE JULY TWENTY
TWENTY UNABLE TO ACCOMMODATE
NEW STUDENT. TO REACH ADULT MEN
OF COLOR IN FACT ALMOST 70% OF
OUR TWO POINT ONE MILLION
STUDENTS ARE PEOPLE OF DIVERSE
ETHNIC BACKGROUND AND JUST LESS
THAN HALF OF ALL STUDENTS ARE
MALE. OVER 40% OF OUR STUDENTS
ARE WORKING ADULTS TWENTY FIVE
OR OLDER. CHILD RIGHT FIVE
HUNDRED STUDENTS ARE SIMILAR IN
BACKGROUND BUT SLIGHTLY LESS
ETHNICALLY DIVERSE. ANOTHER
FALSE PREMISE WAS THAT OUR
STUDENTS IT OUR SYSTEM DOES NOT
OFFER COMPETENCY BASED
EDUCATION. HOWEVER BEFORE THE
CREATION OF CALIBRATE MOST OF
OUR COLLEGES OFFERED OFFERED
COMPETENCY BASED EDUCATION. AND
MANY OF THE FOR THOSE PROGRAMS
ARE NOW ONLINE. CAN CALIBRATE
IS NEITHER UNIQUE NOR
PROGRESSIVE. INSTEAD IT IS AN
OUTRAGEOUSLY EXPENSIVE
UNACCREDITED EXPERIMENT THEY
CONTINUE TO VIOLATE STATUTES
AND SAILORS DIDN'T. WE URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY TWO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. TURNING NOW TO THE
WITNESS VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM
WE HAVE THE FIRST LEAD WITNESS
IN OPPOSITION TO AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY TWO A G. TO TELL WALKER
MEN AND PRESIDENT AND CEO OF
CONRAD COLLEGE. PRESIDENT TALL
WALKER MEN AND PLEASE PROCEED
WHEN YOU ARE READY. GOOD
MORNING MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE HI
MEDINA TELECOM AND THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN YOU
TODAY. AS SOME OF YOU KNOW I AM
A LIFELONG ADVOCATE FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WITH MORE
THAN TWENTY YEARS OF EXPERIENCE
AT THE NATIONAL LEVEL. I
BELIEVE DEEPLY IN CALIBRATING
ADDITION AND I URGE YOU TO
OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO
WHICH WOULD END OUR WORK TO
INCREASE ECONOMIC OPPORTUNITY
FOR CALIFORNIANS WORKING
ADULTS. I'D REFER YOU TO MY
LETTER FOR A MORE COMPREHENSIVE
UPDATE ON OUR PROGRESS BUT IN
SHORT HELP RIGHT HAS MET EVERY
STATUTORY MILESTONE LAID OUT IN
OUR FOUNDING LEGISLATION AND IS
MAKING SIGNIFICANT STRIDES
TOWARD OUR MISSION. TODAY I'D
LIKE TO FOCUS ON THE URGENCY OF
THIS MOMENT NOT FOR CALIFORNIA
BUT FOR THE MILLIONS OF
CALIFORNIANS BEARING THE BRUNT
OF THIS PANDEMIC. NAVIGATING AN
ECONOMIC RECESSION AND FACING
YET ANOTHER RECOVERY THAT WE'VE
BEEN STRANDED WITHOUT A PATH
INTO GOOD JOBS IN THE NEW
ECONOMY. I WAS WORKING WITH
GOVERNOR BROWN IN TWENTY
EIGHTEEN WHEN HE REACHED A DEAL
WITH THE LEGISLATURE TO CREATE
A SEVEN YEAR START UP TIMELINE
FOR COLLEGE THAT COULD BE A
PUBLIC ALTERNATIVES TO
PREDATORY FOR PROFIT. BUT I
LIKE TO MAKE VERY CLEAR THIS
COMMITTEE THIS WORK IS NO
LONGER THEORETICAL. CALVERT HAS
FIVE HUNDRED STUDENTS BUT WE'RE
ON A GROWTH TRAJECTORY TO SERVE
FIVE THOUSAND IN THE NEXT THREE
YEARS. OUR STUDENTS REFLECT THE
STATE'S TREMENDOUS RACIAL
DIVERSITY AND MORE THAN 90% ARE
ADULTS OVER THE AGE OF TWENTY
FIVE. THEY ARE EXACTLY THE
PEOPLE CALVERT WAS CREATED TO
SERVE. AND THE PANDEMIC'S
DISPROPORTIONATE IMPACT ON
BLACK LET NEXT INDIGENOUS
CALIFORNIANS. AND AS WELL AS
WOMEN IN REAL RESIDENTS HAVE
ONLY MADE A WORKING URGENT. IT
IS CLEAR HOW THE STORY GOES
HISTORICALLY. AS ECONOMY BEGINS
TO OPEN UP. UNCERTAINTY
LINGERS. PREDATORY FOR PROFIT
SEIZE THE OPPORTUNITY TO TARGET
RECRUIT AND LEAVE BEHIND
STUDENTS IN THE SAME
COMMUNITIES. WE CAN AGREE THAT
THERE'S SOMETHING OVERWHELMING
ABOUT THIS MOMENT. AND WE MUST
HAVE A TO DO MORE TO SERVE THE
HARDEST HIT COMMUNITIES ACROSS
THE STATE. NOT LESS. CALVET IS
DESIGNING FLEXIBLE PATHWAYS TO
IN DEMAND JOBS FOR THESE
CALIFORNIANS BUT IMPORTANTLY.
WE ALSO ACT AS A RESOURCE FOR
THE SYSTEM. TO RESEARCH AND
EXPAND THE IMPACT OF EFFECTIVE
STRATEGIES. AS GOVERNOR NEWSOM
MADE CLEAR IN HIS BUDGET
PROPOSAL. WE MUST BE COMMITTED
TO AN EQUITABLE BROAD BASED
ECONOMIC RECOVERY WILL ALL
CALIFORNIANS HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY TO REACH THEIR
DREAMS. BUT TO MAKE THIS VISION
A REALITY IN HIGHER EDUCATION
WE MUST LEARN FROM PAST CRISES.
SO I WANT TO CLOSE MY
ADVOCATING FOR OUR STUDENTS.
HECTOR LISTEN SAN PEDRO AND
HE'S IN OUR I. T. SUPPORT
PROGRAM. WITH THE HELP OF THE
CALVERT CAREER COACH HE UPDATED
HIS RESUME. HE WAS OFFERED A
JOB AT A ROBOTICS COMPANY WHEN
HIRING MANAGER NOTED HE WAS IN
A CALVET. INDUSTRY RECOGNIZED
TRAINING PROGRAM. FLORENCE
COMPLETED. MEDICAL CO PROGRAM
JULY. UNDERSERVED IT'S A- AND
WAS HIRED AS A MEDICAL CODER IN
SANTA NOT HOFFA AND- MONICA IS
A SINGLE MOTHER OF THREE BORN
AND RAISED IN SACRAMENTO. SHE
HAS THE PASSION TO FIX THINGS
BUT NO BACKGROUND IN TECHNOLOGY
SHE'S TRIED ONLINE FOR PROFIT
PROGRAMS THE WITHOUT SUCCESS.
TODAY MONICA IS IN OUR I. T.
PROGRAM PURSUING A MORE STABLE
FUTURE FOR HER FAMILY. SHE SAID
OF CALIBRATE QUOTE I THINK THIS
IS ONE OF THE BEST THINGS TO
COME TO CALIFORNIANS ESPECIALLY
AT A TIME LIKE THIS I CAN'T
WAIT TO GET MY HANDS GOING TO
CALIBRATE FUTURE. THAT HELP
FOR SO MANY CALIFORNIANS IS OUR
NORTH STAR AND I WOULD URGE
THIS COMMITTEE TO ALLOW US TO
CARRY FORWARD SO WE DON'T THINK
STUDENTS LIKE THIS BEHIND.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MISTER
WALKER MAN IN THOSE BLASTS LEAD
WITNESS IN OPPOSITION. AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO IS M. A
HAYNES. PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIBRATE COLLEGE BOARD OF
TRUSTEES. IT IS PROVIDING HEARD
TESTIMONY FROM THE WITNESS.
VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM. MISS
HAYNES WHEN YOU'RE READY PLEASE
PROCEED. GOOD MORNING MISTER
CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE. I'M PAM HAYNES
PRESIDENT OF THE CLUB RIGHT
BOARD OF TRUSTEES THANK YOU FOR
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO JOIN YOU
TODAY. I AM A TWENTY TWO YEAR
VETERAN TRUSTEE. AND ALSO SERVE
AS THE PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BOARD OF GOVERNORS. BUT THE BUT
MORE IMPORTANT TO THIS
CONVERSATION I AM A CALIFORNIAN
WHO BENEFIT FROM WORKFORCE
TRAINING OPPORTUNITIES AT A
TIME WHEN INDUSTRY WAS CHANGING.
DECADES AGO PROGRAMS LIKE THESE
GAVE ME THE TRAINING I NEEDED
TO LAND A JOB THAT HAD
BENEFITS. PAID A LIVING WAGE
AND ALLOWED ME TO FURTHER MY
EDUCATION AT SANTA MONICA
COLLEGE AND THEN TRANSFERRED TO
UCLA. TODAY CALIBRATE IS A
LIVING BREATHING COLLEGE WITH
APPROXIMATELY FIVE HUNDRED
STUDENTS AND MORE THAN FIFTY
EMPLOYEES INCLUDING FACULTY
REPRESENTED BY THE LOCAL
CHAPTER OF THE CALIFORNIA
TEACHERS ASSOCIATION. AS A
STATE WIDE COLLEGE CALIBRATE IS
ABLE TO BE RESPONSIVE TO THE
REGIONS OF THE STATE WITH THE
MOST NEED WORKING CLOSELY WITH
WORKFORCE BOARDS IN FRESNO ST
BERNARD DINO SOUTHEAST LOS
ANGELES COUNTY. AND SENATE BILL
TO OFFER IN DEMAND TRAINING. AB
RIGHT IS ALSO PARTNERING WITH
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
BAKERSFIELD COMPTON AND COSTA
MESA TO DEVELOP TEST AND
IMPLEMENT INNOVATIVE SKILL
BASED STRATEGIES. A FOR
ECONOMICALLY DISCONNECTED
ADULTS IN CALIFORNIA. AND I
MIGHT ADD THAT THESE
PARTNERSHIPS ARE DEEPLY
INVESTED IN KELP AND CALIBRATES
MISSION AND IT'S IT IS NEVER
BEEN MORE URGENT. BY MAKING
CALIBRATED OPERATIVE THE
LEGISLATURE WOULD TAKE AWAY A
CRITICAL TOOL NOT JUST FROM
CALIFORNIA FOR THE FOURTH- FROM
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES SYSTEM BUT FROM OUR
STATE AND OUR STUDENTS AT A
TIME WHEN THEY NEED MORE
EDUCATIONAL UP OPTIONS. AND
MORE OPPORTUNITIES NOT LESS I
WANT TO THANK YOU AND WE LOOK
FORWARD TO YOUR QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU MS HAINES WE WILL NOW
MOVE TO PUBLIC COMMENT. SEEING
NO WITNESSES IN SUPPORT IN THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBER NOR ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. NOR
ANY CLEANERS IN THE BACK OF THE
CHAMBER WE WILL NOW MOVE TO THE
PHONE LINES. EIGHTY ANTI
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. YEAH
COMMITTEE WANTED TO COME INTO
THE PORTLAND PRESS ONE DO AT
THIS TIME. AND BECAUSE WE GO TO
LINE SEVENTY THREE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS A THAT
I'M MISTAKEN DE ANZA COLLEGE
AND I'M CALLING TO SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL. EIGHTY FOURTEEN
EIGHTY TWO. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. TO GO TO LINE
EIGHTY FIVE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
MY NAME IS THEIR MORALITY I'M A
STUDENT AT THE END OF COLLEGE
AND I AM SUPPORT I AM IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. MEXICO TO
NINE SEVENTY ONE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME IS
ALREADY TRULY MONEY BERSERK
PROFESSOR AT AMERICAN RIVER
COLLEGE AND ALSO FACULTY UNION
PRESIDENT HI THERE. I AM
CALLING IN FULL SUPPORT FOR A
BI FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO AND URGE
YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU. NEXT
WE GO TO LINE ONE ELEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. RON RAPP SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO THANK
YOU. TO GO TO NINE ONE TEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY
MEDICAID TO GET A LOT ACTUALLY
GET TO COLLEGE I DO SUPPORT AB.
TWO THANKS TO THE TIMELINE OF
ONE HUNDRED PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO MY NAME IS AND I CANNOT
SHE HERE AREA AND I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT- EIGHTEEN FOURTEEN
THIRTY TWO AND A MASTER'S
STUDENT AT THE COLLEGE THANK
YOU. LIKE TO GO ON TO LINE
FORTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN. MOVING
ONTO LINE EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS ERIC
REID I'M A FACULTY MEMBER AT
FOOTHILL COMMUNITY COLLEGE I'M
CALLING IN STRONG SUPPORT OF AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO THANK YOU.
BONTA LINE FORTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO THIS IS JOANNE CAN
I'M A STUDENT AT THE END THE
COLLEGE AND I AM IN FULL
SUPPORT OF AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
TWO THANK YOU. I COULD GO ON TO
LINE THIRTY NINE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. YES MY NAME IS BOB
STOCKHOLM AFFECTED MEMBER AT
THE AT THE COLLEGE I STRONGLY
SUPPORT AB FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO
THANK YOU. AND THIS TIME
THERE'S NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU'D LIKE TO
COMMENT IN OPPOSITION PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND TWO AT THIS TIME.
AT THE MOMENT.
THIRTY GO TO
MINE ONE THIRTEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON THAT
HANDLED ON BEHALF OF NEXT IN
CALIFORNIA IN OPPOSITION. WE GO
TO NINE ONE TWELVE PLEASE GO
AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON RYAN
MICHAEL ANY WITH THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEGAL CALIFORNIA BUYING
ON BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA SEVENTY
THREE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN OPPOSITION. LIKE TO
GO TO LINE ONE OH NINE PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD MORNING MY NAME
IS ELIZABETH WELCOME I'M AN
ADULT AT THE COLLEGE OF SAN
FRANCISCO AND- CONTRARY TO THE
ASSERTION MADE AND SPONSORED
SECTION OF HIS NAME BACK ON
MODERATOR WILL GO TO THE NEXT
CON I'M ALL. I'M ALSO WORRIED
THAN IT CURRENTLY. LIKE TO GO
TO LINE NINETY PLEASE GO AHEAD.
MY NAME IS MICHAEL STEWART AND
I'M A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY AND PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA ACADEMIC SENATE I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THE
COMMITTEE OPPOSE AB FOURTEEN
THIRTY TWO THANK YOU. I
UNDERSTAND THERE'S NO ONE I
THINK YOU THINK ANY TWEETERS
MODERATOR. IF YOU WISH TO
COMMENT AND NEUTRALITY- PLEASE
PRESS. ONE ZERO. AND THERE'S NO
ONE IN Q. SO SEEN NINE
QUESTIONS COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. MISTER BLOOM. SHARE
I'M GOING TO A VOTE TO MOVE
THIS BILL FORWARD TODAY BUT I
DO HAVE QUESTIONS- GOING
FORWARD AND- ABOUT WHETHER. WE
SHOULD BE ON DOING A PROGRAM
THAT WAS CAREFULLY NEGOTIATED
ONLY A COUPLE OF YEARS AGO AND
IS- ONLY NOW I THINK IN ITS
FORMATIVE STAGES- SO I'D LOOK
FOR TO TALKING TO THE AUTHOR
MORE IN HEARING MORE DEBATE ON
ON THIS ISSUE BEFORE- IT. TO A
PRESUMABLY GETS TO THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOOM ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE- MISTER LOW
IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO CLOSE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I LOOK FOR
TO THE CONTINUE CONVERSATION
WITH COLLEAGUES AS WELL AS
WORKING WITH THIS COMMITTEE AS
WELL RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR
I. BOATS. THANK YOU- IN IN IN
RESPONSE TO TWO OF MY
COLLEAGUE- I KNOW THAT THE
CURRENT LAW PROVIDES FOR SEVEN
YEARS FOR COVERAGE COLLEGE TO
REACH SPECIFIED BENCHMARKS BUT
BASED ON WHAT THEY HAVE
ACCOMPLISHED TO DATE AND
KNOWING THAT EITHER A HUNDRED
AND IFTEEN COMMUNITY COLLEGES
NEED FINANCIAL SUPPORT AND HAVE
PROVEN SUCCESS IN COURSE
COMPLETION AN ONLINE COURSE
OFFERINGS I SUPPORT THIS
MEASURE TODAY AND DO ADVISED
THE AUTHOR TO AMEND SOME OF THE
FINDINGS AND DECLARATIONS TO
ALIGN WITH THE MOST RECENT
POWER RIGHT COLLEGE DATA. BUT I
ASKED THE AUTHOR TO BE ADDED.
AS A CO AUTHOR. IF YOU WOULD
THANK YOU. MR LOW AND THEN DID
DID I HAVE A MOTION. ON THIS
BILL- BY DOCTOR ARAMBULA SECOND.
SECOND BY MISTER BLUE SO MADAM
SECRETARY BUTTE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. MEDINA HI MEDINA HI
CHOI. ARAMBULA ARAMBULA ALLY
BLOOM BLOOM HI GABRIEL IRWIN
KILEY LEVINE LEVINE I LOW. LOW
I RUBIO SANTIAGO VALLADARES.
MELENDEZ HI. THE VOTE SIX ZERO
BILLS ON CALL THE BILL IS ON
CAR WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS- THE NEXT BILL
IN FILE ORDER A. B. NINE FORTY
FILE ITEM ELEVEN. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY. MR MCCARTY
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU I THINK I NEED
A DESK OR CHAIR BACK HERE I
WOULD HAVE FOR BILLS I HAVE NO
IDEA HOW THAT HAPPENED. I WANT
TO HELP BILL ONCE A HOUSING
BILL ONES THAT KIND OF K.
TWELVE BILLION ONE HIRED BILL
BUT HERE WE ARE WITH FOR. ALL
START WITH- NUMBER ONE THIS IS
AB NINE FORTY THAT CALLS MENTAL
HEALTH ACT WE KNOW THAT STOOD
MENTAL HEALTH IS A KEY TO
STUDENT SUCCESS MENTAL HEALTH
CRISIS IS EVEN MORE ACUTE NOW
DURING COPA NINETEEN THIS WOULD
CREATE A PROGRAM. IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA UTILIZED PROP
SIXTY THREE DOLLARS- I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR IDOL
THANK YOU. THANK YOU- MR
MODERATOR THE FIRST LEAD
WITNESS CAN LINE IN SUPPORT OF
AB. NINE FORTY IS SARAH. AND
I'M NOT SURE HOW TO PRONOUNCE
THE LAST NAME PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE. STUDENT
ASSOCIATION. SO IF THE WITNESS
WOULD PLEASE PROCEED. WHEN THEY
ARE READY. GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR
MEDINA AND MEMBERS OF THE
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE I'M SORRY CREATE THAT
THE PRESIDENT OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY ASIAN.
OFFICIAL VOICE OF NEARLY HALF A
MILLION HE PLEADED AND I'M HERE
TODAY TO EXPRESS OUR STRONG
SUPPORT FOR EIGHTEEN NINETEEN
FORTY. FIFTH STREET OF
LEGISLATION WILL PROVIDE MUCH
NEEDED FUNDING ALL TWENTY THREE
CSU CAMPUSES AS WELL AS THE UC
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM
EXPAND EATEN UP HELP YOUR CALL
HEALTH SERVICES. SIMPLY PUT
EIGHTY NINETY FORTY WILL
ALLOCATE MONEY FROM THE UNDER
UTILIZED PROP SIXTY THREE
ADMINISTRATIVE ACCOUNT SO THAT
OUR CAMPUSES CAN HIRE
ADDITIONAL COUNSELORS AND BUILD
THE HEALTH INFRASTRUCTURE
NEEDED TO SUPPORT UNICYCLE
ARTICLE NEEDS. THE NEED FOR
ACTION IS CLEAR AT THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN FIFTY IF YOU
HAVE ABOUT TWO HUNDRED AND
TWENTY ONE FULL TIME EQUIVALENT
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONALS IN
WHITE. WHICH MEANS OUR
COUNSELOR TO STUDENT RATIO IS
ABOUT ONE EVERY TWO THOUSAND
ONE HUNDRED AND SEVENTY SIX
STUDENTS. INTERNATIONAL
ASSOCIATION OF COUNCIL SERVICES
RECOMMENDS THAT COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES MAINTAIN A RATIO
OF ONE FULL TIME. EQUIVALENT
MENTAL HEALTH PROFESSIONAL.
EVERYONE TO ONE FIVE HUNDRED
YOU. SO THE FIFTY THREE SHOW
WAIT ABOUT THE RECOMMENDED.
ADDITIONALLY TWO THOUSAND
EIGHT. THE NATIONAL CALL AND
HEALTH. CARE SHOWED THAT FIFTY
THREE PER OF THE YOU CAN THAT
THERE WERE EXT. OVER INSIDE.
MORE THAN 11% SAID THAT THEY
HAD TO CONTEMPLATE SUICIDE. WE
NOTE THAT THE PROBLEMS EXISTED
BEFORE THE PANDEMIC FIFTEEN
THIRTY. RESTRICTED. DAY ABU
ONCE THE PEN. IS OVER. THANK
YOU GRADUATE EVEN IN ENGINEER
WITH REQUIRE AWAY FROM HOME
DISTRESS IS A FEW. A DEGREE
I'VE BECOME WEEK. OVERWHELMED
ISSUE SAID AS THE FIVE A PRESS.
GLOBAL HEALTH. YOU CANNOT ON.
REYES INJUSTICE. INCREASING
HEALTHY COSTS AND OTHER BATES
NEEDS A PRECIOUS MICHAEL THANK
YOU TAKE A DAY. THIS GOES
BEYOND STRESS OF MID EXAM OR
CLASS PROJECT HE PRESSURES ARE.
OUR ABILITY TO IN OUR ACT. MUCH
LESS ARE HOMELESS WILL BE.
CAMPUS NEED ONGOING FUND TO
PROPERLY AND YOU NOT HELP
MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS TODAY APART
THE FUTURE THANK YOU FOR CAN
YOUR KEEP. I'M PRETTY SUPPORT
NINE FORTY. THANK YOU EIGHTEEN
T. THIS SECONDLY WITNESS IN
SOME IS MAGGIE WHY. THE
LEGISLATIVE FOR CAL STATE
UNIVERSITY. MISS WHITE WHEN YOU
ARE READY PLEASE PROCEED. VERY
MUCH BETTER AFTERNOON I KNOW.
WITH A CALIFORNIA IN TO DR ED.
ARE PROUD TO SPONSOR THIS DOWN
AND WE THINK ASSEMBLYMEMBERS.
AND I'M GOING TO INCLUDE THE
LIVES OF STUDENTS. I UNDERSTAND
THAT MENTAL HEALTH IS BASIC
NEED LIKE HAVING TO EAT AND A
PLACE FOR YOU. MATHIS IN BE A
TO FOLLOW PURSUED STUDIES. AND
BECOME FIGHTING THEM OF THE
WHITE. INSURING THAT THE ENTIRE
ACCESS TO ADEQUATE HEALTH
SERVICES. HAVE BEEN UNDER
CHALLENGE FOR A UNIVERSITIES
AND THE DEMAND INCREASING.
EIGHTY NINE FORTY ONE ALLOW FOR
THE HIRING OF ADDITIONAL
COUNSELORS THIRD ACTION OF WAIT
TIME EXPANDED PROGRAMMING AND
SERVICES AND QUITE SIMPLY MORE
ACCESS FOR STUDENTS TO GET THE
HELP THEY NEED. WHEN THEY NEED
AT. WE BELIEVE THAT THE
ADMINISTRATOR ACCOUNT AND THE
MENTAL HEALTH SERVICES ACT IN
AN APPROPRIATE WAY TO FIND TO
COMPORT IN PRIORITY. DESPITE
DOUBLING ONE TIME ALLOCATIONS
OVER THE PAST THREE YEARS THE
ACCOUNT HASN'T EXPECTED
CARRYOVER BALANCE OF FORTY SIX
MILLION DOLLARS IN TWENTY
TWENTY TO. THE DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE OF MONTHLY BALL TENS OF
OFFICE ON HIGHER THAN EXPECTED
INCREASES. AND THE TAX REVENUE
IS DIRECTED TO THIS ACCOUNT
TODAY. THE BILL WOULD ALSO NOT
THAT PRESIDENT AND THERE ARE
SEVERAL ON GOING ALLEGATIONS
OUT OF THIS ACCOUNT. APPLE
TWENTY MILLION DOLLAR I'M GOING
APPROPRIATIONS FOR TRIAGE GRANT.
WITH EIGHTY NINE FORTY
CALIFORNIA COLLEGES WILL HAVE
THE NECESSARY RESOURCES TO
PROVIDE THE ON GOING SUPPORT
AND SERVICES THAT OUR STUDENTS
NEED. TWENTY THREE THEN YOUR
SUPPORT AT EIGHTY NINE FORTY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. THANK YOU
WE WILL NOW GO TO PUBLIC
COMMENT. SEE NO OPPOSITION NO
EXCUSE ME NO SUPPORT IN THE
BACK OF THE CHAMBER NOR
OPPOSITION OR ANY WINNERS WILL
GO TO THE PHONE LINES. AT&T
MODERATOR ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES SUPPORT ON THE PHONE.
THANKS NOT AMONG THE FIRST TO
COMMENT IN SUPPORT IN A PRESS
ONE IN THE AREA AT THE TIME.
ENTRANCE TO GO TO LINE ONE
SEVENTEEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. I'M
SORRY- ONE FIFTY ONE. PLEASE GO
AHEAD. MAY RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF
EDUCATION TRUST QUESTION
SUPPORT. THE NEXT TO GO TO LINE
ONE TWENTY TWO. PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HOW HIGHLY NOT BE HAPPY IF THE
CASE IN A CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ADMINISTRATORS AND
SUPPORT. MEXICO TO LINE FIFTY
SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. I SHOVEL
SEVENTY WITH THE UC STUDENT
ASSOCIATION STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU. MICHAEL KLEIN ONE
TWENTY PLEASE GO AHEAD. JUST
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE IN SUPPORT.
THANKS TO THE TIMELINE NINETY
EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD. NINE
NINETY EIGHT A LOT OF OPEN.
MOVING OUT. COMMITTEE MEMBERS
OF. SORRY I FORGOT THAT CARRIED
OVER ANYWAY GOOD AFTERNOON
TERRY COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY NAME
IS SHEILA IDEAL OF IT THERE AND
I'M A COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENT
OR MATHEMATICS AND YOUR COLLEGE
AND I AM CALLING IN ITS SUPPORT
OF AB. THANK. GO TO LINE
SEVENTY SEVEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
INTERNET CONFIRM HALF THE
STUDENT SENATE FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN STRONG
SUPPORT. THANK TO GO TO LINE
NINETY NINE PLEASE GO AHEAD. NO
MARTINEZ SACRAMENTO STATE
STUDENT BODY PRESIDENT AND
STRONG SUPPORT. THANKS TO THE
TIMELINE ONE NINETEEN PLEASE GO
AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME IS. COULD
NOT BE AT THE COLLEGE AND ALL
SHE MIGHT PLAYED THANK. TO THE
TIMELINE ONE TWENTY THREE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. YESTERDAY A
MEMBER OF THE FACULTY AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
BOARD OF TRUSTEES IN SUPPORT.
MEXICO TO NINE ONE SIXTEEN
PLEASE GO AHEAD. MANY IDEA
FOUND THEY EVER BRING COMMITTEE
COLLEGE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANKS TO THE TIMELINE FORTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO
MICHELLE MALARIA- UNDERGRADUATE
INBODY PRESIDENT AT UC IRVINE
AND I AM CALLING IN SUPPORT.
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR- IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE LET'S STOP FOR A
MOMENT I UNDERSTAND THERE'S TEN
MORE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON
THE LINE BUT WE HAVE A TIME
DEADLINE TO GET OUT. AND SO IN.
IN THE YES SO IN IN IN LIEU OF
THE TIME WE WILL TAKE NOTE THAT
WE HAVE TEN MORE WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT BUT LET'S MOVE ON TO
SEE IF THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION. MISTER MODERATE.
THANK YOU. ABSOLUTELY LATER
DETERMINE IF YOU WISH TO COME
IN OPPOSITION MATT PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THE TIME. WE DO HAVE
ONE KILLING UP TO BE JUST A
MOMENT. OKAY GO TO LINE ONE OH
FIVE GO AHEAD. HI KELLY AND I
HAD A PHONE WITH THE COUNTY
BEHAVIORAL HEALTH DIRECTORS AND
AFFILIATION AND RESPECTFUL
OPPOSITION COLLECTIBILITY
MENDED THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
TIME THAT NO OTHER THING Q. AND
ANY ANY TWEETERS. COMMENTS IN
BETWEEN PLEASE PRESS ONE TO DO
AT THIS TIME. AND THERE'S NO
ONE IN Q. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE. MR
MCCARTY WOULD YOU LIKE CLOSE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I'D LIKE TO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING
THE BILL FORWARD MENTAL HEALTH
CONCERNS AT OUR COLLEGES HAVE
BEEN A MAJOR SOURCE OF CONCERN
FOR THE LEGISLATURE AND I
COMMEND THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR
HIS DEDICATION AND PASSION WORK
IN THIS AREA I KNOW THAT THE
FINAL NUMBERS ARE UNSPECIFIED
IN AB NINE FORTY AND THAT
THERE'S SOME CONCERN FROM THE
OPPOSITION. ABOUT THE M. H. S.
A. ADMINISTRATION FRONT BEING
OVER SUBSCRIBED BUT I TRUSTED
THE AUTHOR WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK ON THIS BILL AS IT MOVES
FORWARD ACTION IS NEEDED AND I
BELIEVE AB NINE FORTY IS ACTION
TAKEN THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR.
SO I HAD A MOTION. I HAD A
MOTION BY MISTER LOW A SECOND
BY MR LEVINE. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASSED APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. SECRETARY V. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS
THE PATH TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE MEDINA AYE MEDINA I
CHOI. ARAMBULA ARAMBULA AYE
BLOOM. BLOOM I GABRIEL IRWIN
KILEY LEVINE LEVINE I LOW LOW I
RUBIO SANTIAGO BALLADARES
CALAVERAS I'D. CODE IS SIX ZERO
THE BILL'S ON CALL SIX ZERO THE
BILL IS ON CALL WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THE
NEXT BILL IS AB TWELVE FIFTEEN
FILE ITEM TWELVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY. PLEASE PROCEED.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THIS
pTIGHTENING AND REFORMS TO THE
UC ADMISSIONS PROCESS IN THE
WAKE OF THE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN OPERATION VARSITY
BLUES- THERE IS A ONE BILL
HEARD EARLIER TODAY ON THE
ASSEMBLY FLOOR I BELIEVE OTHER
BILL HEARD IN COMMITTEE TODAY.
YOU KNOW WE TOOK SWIFT ACTION
TWO YEARS AGO TO ADDRESS THIS
ISSUE TO TIGHTEN UP THE
ADMISSIONS BY ACCEPTANCE BURKE
THE GOVERNOR SIGNED A BILL WE
HAD SOME WORK THROUGH THE
BUDGET PROCESS AS WELL- THIS IS
REALLY FOLLOW UP BECAUSE THE
STATE AUDITOR FOUND THERE WERE
SOME OTHER- SHORTCOMINGS IN THE
UC ADMISSIONS PROCESS- WE ARE
WORKING WITH THE UNIVERSITY TO
UNDERSTAND. THEIR CONCERNS BUT
WE THINK THIS IS A FAIR
COMPROMISE WE HAVE HERE AND
THEN RECENT AMENDMENT AS FAR
AS- THE SCOPE OF THE OVERSIGHT
AUDITS ON AN ANNUAL BASIS BUT
THE BIG PICTURE HERE IS GOING
TO MAKE SURE THAT- DONATIONS
AND PERSONAL CONNECTIONS ARE
NOT CONSIDERED IN ADMISSIONS
DECISIONS. REQUIRE YOU SEE
CAMPUS TO REPORT ON THE REST
LEFT ATHLETIC EMISSIONS
PROTOCOLS TO PREVENT FRAUD OF
COURSE YOU HAD A FEW PEOPLE
ATTEMPTING TO BE COLLEGE
ATHLETES AND GOT IN THROUGH
FRAUDULENT MEANS THERE WAS NO
FOLLOW UP TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE PEOPLE WERE ON THE SPORTS
TEAMS AND IF THEY WERE NOT.
MAKE SURE THEY DON'T- TAKE THAT
SPOT IN THE UC CAMPUS SO THE
BIG PICTURE HERE OF COURSE WE
HAVE A RECORD NUMBER OF PEOPLE
APPLYING TO THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA. A TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND APPLICANTS THIS YEAR
EVERYBODY DESERVES A FAIR SHOT
THAT'S THE BASIS OF OUR UC
ADMISSIONS SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA
MERITOCRACY AND WHETHER IT'S
ONE PERSON MADE BY FRAUD OR
HUNDRED IT'S WRONG. AND DENIES
ADMISSIONS TO HONEST AND
QUALIFIED STUDENTS I WITH ME
TODAY ARE A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT
HOPES TO GO TO A UC AS WELL THE
STATE AUDITOR TO TALK ABOUT-
THEIR THEIR THEIR FINDINGS AND
AGAIN I WILL NOTE. THAT THE UC
IS- AT THAT IS FOCUSING ON THE
MAJORITY OF THESE
RECOMMENDATIONS. IN THE AUDIT
REPORT. THE ONE ISSUE THAT THEY
HAVE HAD EXT SOME. WITH AS FAR
AS HAVING- ANNUAL AUDITS FROM
ALL THE CAMPUSES WE HAVE. HEARD
THAT ISSUE WE DID TAKE
AMENDMENTS ON THE TWENTY
SECOND. WHICH LIMITS THE AUDITS
AS OPPOSED TO- AT EACH CAMPUS
EVERY THREE YEARS WE WILL HAVE-
TO CAMPUS IS EVERY YEAR SO-
LIMIT THE NUMBER. OF AT
CAMPUSES WILL BE ON A ROTATING
ESSENTIALLY FIVE YEAR BASIS
WHICH EVERY CAMPUS RECEIVES AN
AUDIT. SO WITH THAT I ASK THE
ARRIVAL THANK YOU. THEY GIVE US
MCCARTY THE FIRST LEAD WITNESS.
IS FROM THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM A BOB HARRIS
PRINCIPAL AUDITOR OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE AUDITOR'S
OFFICE. AND I WOULD JUST REMIND
EVERYONE THAT WE ARE ON A
LIMITED TIME THE SCHEDULE HERE
SO IF- THE WITNESSES MIGHT.
KEEP THAT IN MIND AS THEY GIVE
THEIR TESTIMONY SO WITH THAT
WILL GO TO MISTER HARRIS PLEASE
PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE READY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
THE COMMITTEE AGAIN BOB HARRIS
WITH THE STATE AUDITOR'S OFFICE
PROJECT MANAGER ON A ROOF.
UNIVERSITY'S ADMISSIONS
PROCESSES AS A REMINDER OUR
OFFICE DOESN'T TAKE FORMAL
POSITION ON BILLS BUT ONCE
AGAIN I'LL PROVIDE AN OVERVIEW
OF HOW AB TWELVE FIFTEEN.
ADDRESSES THE PROBLEM WE FOUND
DURING OUR AUDIT THAT CONTINUE
TO BE PROBLEMS TODAY AS OF OUR
ASSESSMENT OF THE UNIVERSITIES
PROGRESS INTO THE AUDIT WAS
RELEASED. AND HOW IT ADOPTS THE
RECOMMENDATIONS WE MADE IN KEY
AREAS AND IN THE INTEREST OF
TIME I'LL JUST HIGHLIGHT A
COUPLE VERY QUICKLY ONE IS IN
THE AREA OF COMMUNICATIONS
BETWEEN THE DEVELOPMENT OFFICES
AT THE CAMPUSES. AND THE
ADMISSIONS OFFICES WITH RESPECT
TO SPECIFIC APPLICANTS WE SAW
THOSE CONVERSATIONS OCCURRING
WE SAW THEM INAPPROPRIATELY
AFFECTING ADMISSIONS ACTIVITY.
THERE NEEDS TO BE A STRONG
FIREWALL BETWEEN THOSE TWO
OFFICES THAT'S WHAT OUR
RECOMMENDATION IS AND THAT'S
WHAT THE BILL WOULD ENCOURAGE
THE UC UNIVERSITY TO ADOPT
SOMETHING THAT HAS NOT YET DONE
TO DATE. ALL MISTER MENTIONED
THE ATHLETICS THE PROCESS IS
SUBJECT TO ABUSE- WE SAW THAT
THERE WAS INSUFFICIENT
VALIDATION OF TALENTS. IN
INSUFFICIENT TRACKING THE
PARTICIPATION THIS BILL WOULD
ADDRESS THAT AREA AS WELL.
FINALLY IN THE- AREA OF REGULAR
ON GOING OVERSIGHT BY THE
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT WE
RECOMMENDED THAT THE OFFICE THE
PRESIDENT CONDUCT REGULAR
REVIEWS OF CAMPUS ADMISSIONS
ACTIVITY. SOMETHING WHICH IT
HAS NOT CLEARLY INDICATED HOW
IT WILL ACCOMPLISH YET SO WITH
THAT. I'LL TAKE ANY QUESTIONS
THAT THE COMMITTEE MIGHT HAVE.
THANK YOU MISTER HARRIS NOW
WILL GO TO THE SECOND LEAD
WITNESS. TYLER SMITH HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS MISTER SMITH.
PLEASE PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE
READY. THANK YOU- GOOD
AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN AND- OTHER
MEMBERS OF THE FAMILY AND
HIGHER EDUCATION. HI MY NAME'S
HARASSMENT AND SOPHOMORE AT THE
GAME OF HOCKEY HIGH SCHOOL- I
AM A PART OF THE LAW PUBLIC IN
POLICY PROGRAM THAT WAS
ESTABLISHED WITH THE HELP OF
THE STATE. AS A SOPHOMORE I WAS
VERY DRIVING TO PUSH AND GO TO
COLLEGE TO ACHIEVE A HIGHER
EXCLUSION- BUT DUE TO THE
VARSITY BLUES SCANDAL. I CELLS
AND MANY OTHERS I KNOW MORE TO
TURN FROM MICHAEL WHEN HE
REALIZED THAT GETTING TO. MHM
HIGHER WELL IN HAD MORE
CONNECTIONS WERE ABUSING SYSTEM.
AND I AM. THAT AB FIFTEEN. WELL
HOW ENSURE. AND PROTECT FUTURE
OF MYSELF MANY LIKE ME. TWO
HUNDRED. HELLO CAN HAVE A SPOT
IN THE FUTURE. THANK YOU MISTER
SHE- NOT SEEN ANY WITNESS IN
THE CHAIN WILL MOVE TO THE FULL
LINES EIGHTEEN TEAM. ARE ANY
WOULD SUPPORT ON THE PHONE
LINES. GENERATIONS TO COME IN
AND SUPPORT YOU MAY PRESS ONE
ZERO AT THIS TIME. KNOWING Q.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOUNG TECH WHICH TO
COMMON IN OPPOSITION IN THE
PAST ONE YEAR AT THE TIME. AND
WE HAVE NO LINK YOU ANY ANY
TWEETERS. WISH TO COME IN
BETWEEN THE PRESS ONE ZERO. NOW
WE DO HAVE- COMICAL NINE ONE
TWENTY ONE PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI
DAVID I TRIED REGULARLY AT THE
UNIVERSITY CALIFORNIA AND THE
INTEREST OF TIME ALONE I
RESPECT THE ENTIRE TESTIMONY WE
JUST WANT TO. STATE THAT THE
UNIVERSITY IS NOT HAVE A
POSITION ON AB TWELVE FIFTEEN
AT THIS TIME WE WANT TO BE VERY
CLEAR THAT THE UC TAKES ALL
MATTERS RELATING TO ADMISSIONS
OF OUR STUDENTS. EARLY IN THE
UNIVERSITIES COMMITTED TO
ENSURING. FAIRNESS AND
INTEGRITY OUR MISSIONS
PROPERTIES. AT THE UNIVERSITY
LOOKS FORWARD TO FURTHER
DISCUSSIONS WITH THE AUTHOR AS
WE CONTINUE TO LEARN MORE ABOUT
THE INTO THE- INDIVIDUAL CASES
THAT WERE OUTLINED. IN THE
AUDITOR'S REPORT AND I'D BE
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER TWEETERS.
NO NOTHING YOU ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
THE AUTHOR WISH TO GIVE A
CLOSING STATEMENT. THANK YOU I
THINK THAT- THAT THIS IS A
THOUGHTFUL FOLLOW UP TO WHAT WE
LEARNED FROM THE AUDIT AS WELL
AS REFORMS THAT YOU KNOW WE- WE
I'VE TALKED TO PRESIDENT- DRAKE
ABOUT THIS AS WELL AS PRESENT A
PLATONIC. IT'S A BLACK EYE IN
THE UC SYSTEM AS WELL AS A
BLACK EYE AND ALL OF THIS AND
THEY DON'T WANT THIS TO HAPPEN
AS WELL SO WE YOU KNOW WANT TO
TRUST BUT VERIFY SO THIS IS HOW
THE LEGISLATURE PUTTING IN
WRITING AND- AND CODIFYING THE
DIRECTION THAT THEY'RE SAYING
THEY'LL GO AS WELL AS MAKING
SURE WE HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE.
OVERSIGHT IN- IN AUDITS AFTER
THE PROCESS AFTER AFTER THE
FACT I'M TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
MISSIONS PROCESS IS FAIR AND
DOESN'T LET ANYBODY I'D SNEAK
IN THROUGH FRAUDULENT MEANSTO
MAKE SURE THAT YOU SEE- AND
MISSED THE MISSION SLOTS ARE
AVAILABLE TO QUALIFIED
CALIFORNIA LIKE IT'S ONLY.
THANK YOU ASK THE RIGHT. THANK
YOU I COMMEND THE AUTHOR FOR AS
HE SAID. PRESTEIGNE BUT
VERIFYING WHEN IT COMES TO UC'S
IMPLEMENTATION. OF THE STATE
AUDITOR'S SUGGESTIONS. I
APPRECIATE YOUR WILLINGNESS-
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY TO WORK
WITH MY STAFF. ON THE
PREVIOUSLY ACCEPTED AMENDMENTS.
OPERATION VARSITY BLUES AND
COVERED ADMISSION CASES. AT UC
CAMPUSES WHERE STUDENTS WERE
ADMITTED. AS ATHLETES WITHOUT
VERIFICATION OF THEIR- ATHLETIC
ABILITIES. AND THE STATE
AUDITOR UNCOVERED ADDITIONAL
CASES OF IMPROPER. INFLUENCE ON
ADMISSION DECISIONS. AS
PREVIOUSLY INDICATED ON SEBI
SUPPORTING THIS BILL. AND I
HOPE THAT THE REGIONS AND THE
UC OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT WILL
CONTINUE TO WORK. WITH THE
STATE AUDITOR AND THE
LEGISLATURE. TO ALLEVIATE
ONGOING CONCERNS. TO HAVE A
MOTION. MOVED BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DR ARAMBULA AND SECOND
BY THIS ORDER THERE IS- A
MATTER SECRETARY THE MOTION
BEFORE US IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS THE PAST THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
AYE MEDINA I CHOI ARAMBULA. I
BLOONS BLOOM I GABRIEL IRWIN
KILEY LEVINE LEVINE I LOW LOW I
RUBIO. SANTIAGO GALLAGHER
VALLADARES HI. THE VOTE IS SIX
ZERO THE BILL IS ON CALL. SIX
ZERO BILL IS ON CALL I WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THE NEXT BILL ON FILE
FILE ITEM THIRTEEN A. B.
THIRTEEN SEVENTY SEVEN BYE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MCCARTY. YEAH
THIS IS A BILL RELATED TO
STUDENT HOUSING WE KNOW THAT
THE STUDENT- AFFORDABILITY
CRISIS IS NOT ONLY ABOUT
TUITION BUT THE COST OF
INSTRUCTION AND HOUSING AND
BOOKS AND FOOD TRANSPORTATION.
THERE'S BEEN SOME UNIQUE
EFFORTS- FOCUSED AROUND THE
STATE SPECIFICALLY AT
UNIVERSITY OF SAN DIEGO TO
BUILD- BELOW MARKET RATE
HOUSING- USING- THAT RESOURCES
FROM THE UNIVERSITY NOT A
UNIVERSITIES ARE THAT LUCKY
HAVE A OPPORTUNITY THAT THIS
WOULD CREATE A STATE- HOUSING
REVOLVING LOAN FUND TO HELP OUR
UC CSU AND COMMUNICATE ALL
AGES. CONSTRUCT AFFORDABLE
STUDENT HOUSING- WILL BE- ALSO
WORKING WITH THIS FOR THE
BUDGET PROCESS I ASK THE
ARRIVAL THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
MCCARTY EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR
THE FIRST LEAD WITNESS CALLING
IN FOR AB. THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN IS PRETTY DEEP KOTULA
CHANCELLOR AT UC SAN DIEGO
CHANCELLOR WHENEVER YOU ARE
READY. AND I WOULD JUST REMIND
WITNESSES IF YOU COULD KEEP IT
BRIEF WOULD BE GREATLY
APPRECIATED. PREDATOR GOOD
MORNING GERMANY TO LHS CHOICE-
TO AND NUMBER THE- THANK YOU
ALL FOR YOUR CONTINUED SUPPORT
FOR THE UNIT OF CALIFORNIA AND
THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
MCCARTY FROSTING AB ONE THREE
SEVEN SEVEN. AND FOR WORKING
DILIGENTLY TO FUND MUCH NEEDED
HOUSING FOR. AND RICH FONG CAN
LOOKS IS VITAL TO THE SUCCESS
OF OUR PHONE. STUDENTS LIVE ON
CAMPUS A MORE TIME TO STUDY
EXPLORING AND CONNECT YOU
SPACES SPECIFICALLY DESIGNED
FOR LEARNING AND DISCOVERY.
THEY HAVE MORE OPPORTUNITIES TO
INTERACT WITH FACULTY
RESEARCHERS AND COLLEAGUES.
THEY'RE MORE FOCUSED AND
ACTIVELY ENGAGE WITH EDUCATION
THE JOINT STUDY GROUPS FROM
ORGANIZATIONS ATTEND MORE
EDUCATIONAL EVENTS AND DEVELOP
STRONG PEER NETWORKS. THESE
NETWORKS KEEP THEM MOTIVATED
WITH- AND PROMOTE LONG TERM
CAREER. SUCCESS AFTER
GRADUATION- ON THE VERY ON IF
YOU DIEGO THAN THAT AND BUILD
FROM HOW. BECAUSE WE THEM OF
THE OKAY AND ITS IMPACT THE
OVERALL EXPERIENCE A SUCCESS.
WE ALSO KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF
MAKING HOUSING AFFORDABLE AND
ACCESSIBLE. UC SAN DIEGO IS
LOCATED IN THE BEACH COMMUNITY
OF LA JOLLA AND PROXIMAL OFF
CAMPUS RENTALS. CAN BE COST
PROHIBITIVE FOR STUDENTS. OUR
FOR OKAY HOUSING IS TO FOR YOU
HOUSING GUARANTEE. AT LEAST 20%
BELOW MARKET RATE. TO ACHIEVE
THE GUARANTEE HOUSING GUARANTEE
GO WE HAVE EXPANDED OUR HOUSING
INVENTORY FROM ELEVEN THOUSAND
NINE HUNDRED AND SIXTY BAD IN
TWENTY THIRTEEN. TO SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED AND
FIFTY FIVE BUT TODAY. AND WE
ANTICIPATE CONSTRUCTING AN
ADDITIONAL TWELVE THOUSAND FIVE
HUNDRED BEDS LIKE TWENTY THIRTY
TWO. FOR A TOTAL OF ABOUT
THIRTY THOUSAND THAT. HOUSING
MORE CONCERNED CAMPUS HAS BEEN
BENEFICIAL AS MANY BENEFITS AS
A FIVE. IT IMPROVED AS AN
EXPERIENCE IT COULD TRAFFIC AND
IT FREES UP RENTAL UNITS IN
LOCAL TWENTY ABLE COMMUNITIES.
THE STATE AND THAT THE UC TO
INCREASE ENROLLMENT. TO HELP IS
TO HELP READERS OBJECTED UC SAN
DIEGO THAT HAD MORE THAN NINE
THOUSAND UNDERGRAD DEGREES
IMPORTANT TWENTY TWELVE. BIT
FACTOR IN THE GROWTH REQUIRED
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN
INFRASTRUCTURE AND FACILITIES.
PARTICULARLY FROM HOUSING. YOU
SAN DIEGO FINEST HOUSING.
THROUGH ISSUING THIRTY FIVE YOU
BOND. FURTHERMORE OUR CURRENT
OF OUR LIMITED THAT COULD. TO
FINANCE HOUSING. LIQUID PC TO
INDIA GOVERNMENT OF ACADEMIC
PRIORITY. GIVE THAT TYPICAL
ABOUT TWO THIRDS OF THE GOOD
TOWARDS THAT SERVICE THANK YOU
AND HAVE PROJECTS. ACCESS TO
LOOK WE LOVE LOANS. WOULD BE
MARKET INTEREST. WILL ALLOW TO
OF HIGHER. THE ON CAMPUS
HOUSING. KEEP AND DRUG FOREIGN
GRANT LOWER AND HELP PRESERVE
THAT COULD. FOR OTHER MISSION
CAPITAL CRIME. AGAIN WANTED YOU
FOR THE TOPIC. AND I APPRECIATE
MR MCCARTY UPWARDS TO FOUR
CREATIVE SOLUTIONS TO THE
CHALLENGES OF BUILDING
AFFORDABLE FROM HOUSING. I
WOULD BE DELIGHTED TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU SIR.
THANK YOU CHANCELLOR. AT THE
MODERATOR THE SECOND LEAD
WITNESS CALLING IN IS RACHEL
COOPERMAN. A STUDENT AT SAC
STATE. THIS COOPERMAN WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. AFTER THE CHANNEL
THE STATE MEMBERS THAT. MY NAME
IS RACHEL COULD AND THE GRADUAL
SENIOR SEPARATE STATE AND CAR
THAT I AMERICAN THERE'S A ME
BECAUSE- DURING MY TIME IN HIGH
EDUCATION. LIVING AT HOME WITH
NON. IT BE ACTED FOR ME TO LIVE
IN IRAQ MY OWN. I CAN QUALIFY
FOR AID TO THE OF COLLEGE AND
THE EXTENT CAME OUT OF MY OWN
CAR. BECAUSE OF THIS I HAD TO
WORK FULL TIME. COMMITTEE
CALLING. BUT COMING BACK MORE
YEAR I THINK OF TOLLING AND
TRANSACTED. PEOPLE EIGHT FORTY
STUDENT A FULL TIME EMPLOYEE.
WHEN I WAS COLLEGE MY GREAT ARE
GREATLY. BECAUSE NOT ABLE TO
DEDICATE TIME TO MAKE STUDY OF
HAVING TO WORK YOU NEED MY HELP
NEEDS. THE CARD I RECOGNIZE
MERELY TO THIRDS OF MY- AND THE
TIME I TO DEPARTMENT. I THINK
ACTION KNOWN ORDER TO COVER
MAJOR. AND MORE SPECIFICALLY MY
HOUSING. I CONTINUE TO WORK.
SACRAMENTO EIGHT TO COVER THESE.
AND BECAUSE OF THE LACK OF BOTH.
HOUSING GIVE TAKE MY CELL
YOU'RE CAN'T. BEING COLLEGE
STUDENT ALREADY A FULL TIME JOB
AND- ALREADY HIGH CONCEPT TO
AGREE. THAT THERE WOULD BEEN
MORE HOUSING OPTIONS YET LIKE
INSIDE MYSELF. I WOULD BE ABLE
TO DEDICATE TIME. TO GETTING
GOOD FROM THAN WHAT FULL TIME
AND COME STILL AND UP INTO. MY
SITUATION IS NOT UNIQUE-
CALIFORNIA ARE FACING DIFFICULT
DO TO THE LACK AFFORDABLE- BY
TELEVISION YOU KNOW HOW REBELS
LOAN FOR AND OFFERING GREAT TO
CREATE. EIGHTY THIRTEEN SEVENTY
ONE EIGHT FOUR CAMPUS TO
PROVIDE MORE HOW DO WE CAN BE
INCREASED DIDN'T NEED THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISS COOPER MY- NOT
ANY WITNESSES IN THE CHAMBER.
WILL MOVE TO THE LINE. EIGHTEEN
T. MY THERE AND WITNESSES AND
SOME. IF YOU LIKE TO COME IN
AND IN A PRESS ONE ZERO TIME.
FIRST TO GO TO LINE ONE
SIXTEEN. PLEASE GO AHEAD. MANIA
FOUND A EVERGREEN COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT JUST A MOMENT. YES
WE HAVE A COUPLE MORE MOMENTS.
NEXT TO THE TO LINE ONE TWENTY
THREE PLEASE GO AHEAD. GET A
MEMBER OF THE FACULTY AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT
BOARD OF TRUSTEES IN SUPPORT.
TO GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY FIVE
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS CASEY GET MODERATE TO THE
BABY AND THE CARNAGE THAT HEADY
SUPPORT SB. THIRTY THIRTY
THIRTY SEVEN. THE NEXT TO GO ON
TO LINE ONE TWENTY SEVEN PLEASE
GO AHEAD. SCHLABACH SPEAKING ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
FACULTY ASSOCIATION STRONG
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AT THE TIME
THERE'S NO ORDERS IN Q. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. IF YOU
LIKE THE COMMON OPPOSITION
PRESS ONE AND ZERO AT THIS TIME.
AT THIS TIME THERE'S NO ONE IN
Q. ANY TWEETERS. IF YOU LIKE TO
COME IN BETWEEN YOU MAY PRESS.
ONE ZERO. AND THERE'S NO ONE IN
Q. ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM THE COMMITTEE. C. THE
RIGHT OUR TO MR MCCARTY WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU
ASKING ARRIVA. THANK YOU- I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
INTRODUCING AB THIRTEEN SEVENTY
SEVEN. HOUSE IN IS CERTAINLY
ONE OF THE MOST COMPLEX ISSUES
FACING OUR CAMPUSES NOT JUST
FOR STUDENTS BUT ALSO FOR
FACULTY AND STAFF. AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN IS A WAY TO
PROVIDE FINANCIAL AND TECHNICAL
SUPPORT NECESSARY TO HELP CSU
UC AND COMMUNITY COLLEGES BUILD
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO MEET
URGENT AND GROWING NEEDS OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. WE HAD A
MOTION BY MR LOW SECOND BY MISS
VALIDATORS. MADAM SECRETARY THE
MOTION IS DUE PASSED
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
AYE MEDINA AYE CHOI. ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM. BLOOM HI
GABRIEL IRWIN KILEY LEVINE
LEVINE I LOW LOW I RUBIO
SANTIAGO CALAVERAS BALLADARES
HI. THE THIRTY SIX ZERO THE
BILL IS ON CALL SIX ZERO THE
BILL IS ON CALL WE LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE
NEXT BILL FILE ITEM FOURTEEN A.
B. FOURTEEN NINETY ONE THE LAST
BILL BUT MR MCCARTY YOU MAY
PROCEED WHEN YOU ARE READY. YES
THANK YOU THIS IS RELATED TO
ADULT EDUCATION WHICH WE ALL
HAVE IN OUR COMMUNITIES WE KNOW
IF IT MAKES A DIFFERENCE IT
HELPS INDIVIDUALS GET BASIC
SKILLS- FOCUS ON ENGLISH
LITERACY AND CITIZENSHIP FOR
HELP HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS GO
BACK AND GET THEIR HIGH SCHOOL
DIPLOMA LIKE IT HELPS ME THIRTY
YEARS AGO WHEN I FLUNKED OUT OF
MY LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL FIVE MILES
FROM YEARS ADULT ADDED TURN MY
LIFE AROUND- WE KNOW THAT ADULT
ED MATTERS WE ALSO KNOW THAT
THERE'S A BIG NEED EVERY YEAR
WE SPENT ABOUT FIVE HUNDRED
MILLION THE BUDGET. FOR ADULT
EDUCATION. BUT TOO OFTEN-
INSULT AND CONSORTIUMS- HOARD
MONEY AND DON'T SPEND IT
THROUGH CARRY OVER FUNDS. THIS
WOULD CREATE A REASONABLE CAP.
A 15% FOR YEAR TO YEAR
CARRYOVER FUNDS FOR ADULT
EDUCATION MAKING SURE MORE OF
OUR ADULT ADD RESOURCES. HELP
THE COMMUNITIES WHICH THEY ARE-
ALLOCATED EVERY YEAR TO- TO
SIR. I WITH THAT ASK YOUR AYE
VOTE I HAVE- TWO WITNESSES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU THIS
MCCARTY AT&T MODERATOR THE
FIRST LEAD WITNESS IN SUPPORT
OF AB FOURTEEN NINETY ONE IS
JOANNE TURKEY FORMER BOARD
MEMBER OF MOUNT DIABLO UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT MR KEY WHENEVER
YOU'RE READY. PLEASE PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON THANK YOU MANY
RESTAURANTS ARE KEY AS HE SAID
AND I THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO SHARE WHY I AM
SUPPORTIVE OF EIGHTY FOURTEEN
NINETY ONE AS A FORMER TEACHER
ADMINISTRATOR AND SCHOOL BOARD
MEMBER COME OUT TO HAVE A
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT I HAVE
A FRONT ROW VIEW OF HOW THIS
BILL WOULD BE GOOD FOR ADULT
LEARNERS ESPECIALLY THOSE WITH
THE GREATEST NEED FOR EDUCATION
TRAINING AND EMPLOYMENT. I HAD
THE PRIVILEGE OF BEING A MEMBER
OF THE STATE WORK GROUP JOINTLY
CONVENED IN TWENTY THIRTEEN BY
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE CAMPUS
OFFICE AND THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION FOR THE
PURPOSE OF DESIGNING THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF AB EIGHTY SIX
IN A WAY THAT WOULD ENSURE
SERVICES AND RESOURCES OPTIMIZE
THE MOST EFFECTIVE. DATE OTHER
TRADITIONAL REGIONAL CONSORTIA
STRUCTURE CAME FROM THIS
PROCESS WITH AN EXPECTATION
THAT LOCAL PLANTS WOULD BE
BASEDON PRIORITIZE WHO NEEDS
IN TRUTH COORDINATION AND
COLLABORATION AMONG K. TWELVE
AND COMMUNITY COLLEGE ADULT
EDUCATORS I THANK SURE YOU'RE
AWARE A LOT OF HARD WORK IS
GONE INTO THIS EFFORT OVER THE
PAST SEVEN YEARS WITH MANY
POSITIVE OUTCOMES BUT AT THIS
STAGE IN THE PROCESS HOWEVER
SOME PERSISTENT CHALLENGES HAVE
BEEN IDENTIFIED IN AB FOURTEEN
NINETY ONE IT'S DESIGNS TO
ADDRESS ONE OF THEM. AND THAT
IS ENSURING THAT PRECIOUS
DOLLARS NEEDED FOR AND THAT
NEEDS ARE IN FACT BEING
UTILIZED IN A TIMELY MANNER FOR
THE GREAT MAJORITY OF A
CONSORTIUM MEMBERS EIGHT
DOLLARS CATION PROGRAM IS THEIR
ONLY SOURCE OF REGULAR REVENUE
TO SERVE STUDENTS IN THEIR
COMMUNITY JANE DOLLARS UNSPENT
YEAR OVER YEAR FLIES IN THE
FACE OF THEIR EFFORTS AND
CREATE UNNECESSARY TENSION AT
THE CONSORTIUM CABLE WHICH IS
SUPPOSED TO BY DESIGN BE
ORCHESTRATED BY A SHARED VISION
COMMITMENT AND PLAN FOR
IMPROVING THE LIVES OF ADULTS
AND FAMILIES IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES. LOCAL CONSTRUCTION
NEEDS YOUR SUPPORT OF THIS
INCREASE STATEWIDE
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THE USE OF
THESE ALLOCATIONS FIFTY EIGHTY
ANTI I HAVE WORKED HARD AND
CRAFTING AND BANNING THE
SPECIFIC LANGUAGE AT THAT THE
INTEGRITY OF LOCAL PLANNING IS
INTACT BUT ALSO. ENSURES THE
FUNDING ISSUES EACH YEAR R. S.
INTENDED. I AM TO THANK
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE. FORD
CHAMP ABOUT. AND CAL AND I URGE
YOUR SUPPORT OF A- FOURTEEN
NINETY ONE THANK YOU. THEY GIVE.
KING H. TEAM. THIS LEAD WITH
CALLING IN IS KATHLEEN.
PRINCIPAL DOES GO AND OF THE
CAN COUNCIL FOR ADULTS
EDUCATION. THIS PORTER WHENEVER
YOU ARE READY YOU MAY PROCEED.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M KATHLEEN
PORTER ADULT EDUCATION DIRECTOR
IN POWAY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND PRESIDENT OF THE
CALIFORNIA COUNCIL FOR ADULT
EDUCATION I APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO EXPRESS SUPPORT
FOR ASSEMBLY BILL FOURTEEN
NINETY ONE. CURRENTLY THE
CALIFORNIA ADULT EDUCATION
PROGRAM PROVIDES A THREE YEAR
SPENDING WINDOW FOR ALLOCATIONS
NOT BASED ON STATUTORY
REQUIREMENT. TO CARRY OVER IS
DEFINED AS THE FUNDS REMAINING
AFTER THAT THREE YEAR PERIOD AB
FOURTEEN NINETY ONE PROPOSES
USING THE MORE COMMON CONCEPT
OF CARRY OVER THAT FUNDS
ALLOCATED ANY GIVEN YEAR ARE
FOR USE IN THAT YEAR. THIS
DISTINCTION IS AN IMPORTANT ONE
WHEN WE CONSIDER MAKING A
DIFFERENCE TO CALIFORNIANS IN
NEED OF ADULT EDUCATION
SERVICES TODAY. WITH THE THREE
YEAR DEFINITION CAPE CARRYOVER
IS REPORTED TO BE BETWEEN FOUR
AND TEN PERCENT. HOWEVER USING
THE YEAR OVER YEAR MODEL
PROPOSED IN AB FOURTEEN NINETY
ONE CARRYOVER IS ESTIMATED TO
BE MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY MILLION OR 24% OF THE
TOTAL ANNUAL ALLOCATION AND
THERE ARE MORE THAN TWENTY
AGENCIES. CARRYING OVER MORE
THAN A 100% OF THEIR ANNUAL
ALLOCATION QUITE SIMPLY THIS
MEANS THAT FUNDING IS NOT
SERVING STUDENTS IN THOSE AREAS
IN THE FISCAL YEAR. AN ESL
CLASS COSTS ROUGHLY TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS PER YEAR AND
SERVE TWENTY FIVE TO THIRTY
STUDENTS SO HUNDRED THIRTY
MILLION DOLLARS A CREATES TO
FIFTY TWO HUNDRED MORE CLASSES
SERVING MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND
SIXTY THOUSAND STUDENTS
STATEWIDE. EIGHTY FOURTEEN
NINETY ONE PROVIDES A LOCAL
CONSORTIUM THE TOOLS NEEDED TO
MEET THE UNMET NEEDS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES EACH YEAR ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ADULT.
EDUCATION PROGRAMS IN THE
STUDENTS WE SERVE I URGE YOU TO
SOME EIGHTY FIVE NINETY ONE
THANK YOU THE- THANK YOU MISS
PORTER- NOT SEEN ANY WITNESSES
IN THE BACK OF THE CHAMBER WE
WILL MOVE TO THE PHONE LINES.
AT&T MODERATOR THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. YEAH IF
YOU LIKE TO COME IN SUPPORT YOU
MAY PRESS ONE ZERO AT THE TIME.
THIRTY GO TO LINE ONE TWENTY-SIX PLEASE GO AHEAD. HI COLLEEN
PACKER ON BEHALF LOS ANGELES
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT. THE TIME THERE'S NO
ONE ELSE IN Q. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. IF YOU LIKE TO COME
IN OPPOSITION IN A PRESS ONE
AND YOU KNOW AT THE TIME. TO GO
TO LINE ONE TWENTY EIGHT.
PLEASE GO AHEAD. HELLO MY NAME
IS MADELINE I BY- AND I AM-
REPRESENTING THE ASSOCIATION OF
COMMUNITY AND CONTINUE THAT
WHICH IS THE- ADULT EDUCATION-
PROGRAM FOR THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND I REPRESENT THE
SEVENTY NINTH MINUTE COLLEGES
WHO OPERATE OKAY EDUCATION- AND
WE ARE IN OPPOSITION. THIS. THE
TIME IS NOW IN A THANK YOU
THANK YOU ANY TRAINERS. ELECT
ECONOMY BETWEEN PRESS ONE TO DO
AT THIS TIME. ANY WE HAVE NO
ONE TO THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE.
ST NINE- MISTER CARTY WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE THANK YOU ASK THE
RIVA. THANK YOU MR MCCARTY
ADULT EDUCATION AS I WHEN I WAS
A TEACHER OF ONE FOR- IN ADULT
EDUCATION PROVIDES A UNIQUE
SERVICE TO COMMUNITIES
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. LOCAL
CONCERT SHOULD CURRENTLY HAVE
THE AUTHORITY TO CREATE
ACCOUNTABILITY OF THE USE OF
FUNDS THROUGH A VOTE OF THEIR
GOVERNING BOARDS HOWEVER WITH A
HUNDRED AND THIRTY MILLION
UNSPENT FUNDS BEING CARRIED
OVER INSTEAD OF BEING USED FOR
THEIR INTENDED PURPOSES AND
ADULT EDUCATION NEEDS. ARE
BEING ON MATT. ABSOLUTE JUST
LAID OF INTERVENTION IS
NECESSARY. I THANK ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MCCARTY FOR BRINGING AB
FOURTEEN NINETY ONE FOR. AND
FOR HIGHLIGHTING THE ADDITIONAL
AVAILABLE FUNDS FOR EDUCATION.
AT A MOTION BY MISS BROWN
ADDRESS. AND A SECOND BY MR
LOW. THE MOTION BEFORE US IS DO
PASSED TO THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE AND SECRETARY IF YOU
WOULD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
EDUCATION COMMITTEE MEDINA HI
MEDINA HI CHOI. ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM. BLOOM I
GABRIEL IRWIN KILEY LEVINE
LEVINE I LOW. LOW I RUBIO.
RUBIO I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I
BALLOT THEIR VALLADARES HI. THE
VOTE IT'S EIGHT ZERO THE BILLS
OUT. THE VOTERS EIGHT ZERO THE
BILL IS OUT I WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. NEXT
BILL ON FILE IS AB TEN FORTY
FILE ITEM SIXTEEN ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MURATSUCHI MISTER
MURATSUCHI YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN
YOU ARE READY. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE. I'M HERE 2% ON
AN ISSUE THAT I KNOW MISTER
CHAIRMAN IS VERY NEAR AND DEAR
TO YOUR HEART. THE ISSUE OF
ETHNIC STUDIES. THIS BILL. WILL
REQUIRE CALIFORNIA'S COMMITTEE
COLLEGE STUDENTS SEEKING AN
ASSOCIATE DEGREE. TO TAKE TO BE
REQUIRED TO TAKE A THREE UNIT I
THINK STUDIES COURSE. I'D LIKE
TO SHARE A PERSONAL STORY OF
HOW I'VE BECOME SUCH A TRUE
BELIEVER. OF THE POWER AND THE
POTENTIAL. OF ETHNIC STUDIES TO
CHANGE LIVES. I AM A PRODUCT OF
THE ETHNIC STUDIES MOVEMENT. I
RECEIVED WHAT I WOULD CONSIDER
A PRETTY BASIC AMERICAN
EDUCATION AS THE SON. OF A
CAREER US ARMY CIVIL SERVANT I
WAS I GREW UP ON MILITARY BASES
AROUND THE WORLD. AND I TENDED
WATER BASICALLY THE EQUIVALENT
OF PUBLIC SCHOOLS ON MILITARY
BASES- SERVING THE CHILDREN OF
AREN'T THE MEN AND WOMEN IN THE
US ARMED FORCES. MY EDUCATION
WAS PRETTY WHAT I CONSIDER
PRETTY TYPICAL IN THE SEVENTIES
AND EIGHTIES. YOU KNOW I'VE
LEARNED ABOUT HOW. OUR NATION
WAS STARTED BY THE ARRIVAL OF
THE PILGRIMS AT PLYMOUTH ROCK.
AND I LEARNED HOW OUR NATION
WAS FOUNDED. BY THE GREAT
FOUNDERS OF OUR NATION. GEORGE
WASHINGTON THE FATHER OF OUR
COUNTRY. THE FARM OF THE
FOUNDERS THE FRAMERS OF THE
CONSTITUTION. MEN LIKE THOMAS
JEFFERSON AND JAMES MADISON. I
DID WELL ENOUGH WITH THIS.
CONVENTIONAL AMERICAN EDUCATION
TO GET INTO UC BERKELEY FOR
COLLEGE. WHICH YOU KNOW IN THE
EARLY EIGHTIES IT WAS A LOT
EASIER TO GET INTO UC BERKELEY
AT THAT TIME. BUT IN MY THIRD
YEAR IN COLLEGE I DECIDED. TO
TAKE AN ELECTIVE. ASIAN
AMERICAN STUDIES TWENTY EIGHT
INTRODUCTION TO ASIAN AMERICAN
HISTORY. AND THAT COURSE CHANGE
MY LIFE. IT WAS THE FIRST TIME
THAT I LEARNED THE HISTORY OF
PEOPLE THAT I KNEW. ALL THAT I
CAN RELATE TO. AND SOME OF THE
MOST IMPORTANT LESSONS THAT I
LEARNED FROM ETHNIC STUDIES.
WAS THE IMPORTANCE OF
PERSPECTIVE. THAT HISTORY
LITERATURE SO MANY ACADEMIC.
DISCIPLINES DEPEND SO MUCH ON
WHO IS TELLING THE STORY WHO IS
TELLING THE HISTORY. WHOSE
PERSPECTIVE IS BEING
REPRESENTED. AT THE THIRTIES
ALSO TAUGHT ME THE IMPORTANCE
OF CRITICAL THINKING. THAT.
IT'S IMPORTANT TO ANALYZE. WHAT
WE'RE HEARING AND LEARNING AND
READING. IT'S SO DEPENDENT
AGAIN ON WHO'S TELLING IT AND
WHOSE PERSPECTIVE IT'S COMING
FROM. AND SO I THINK NOW. IN
THIS TIME. WITH ALL THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE ARE FACING
NOT ONLY IN MULTICULTURAL
CALIFORNIA. BUT IN OUR NATION
AS WE STRUGGLE WITH SO MANY OF
THE CHALLENGES. OF. DEALING
CELEBRATING THE DIVERSITY THAT
WE HAVE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. NOW MORE THAN EVER
WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
CALIFORNIA CAN YOU CALL
STUDENTS. I HAVE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE ETHNIC
STUDIES IN ORDER TO RECEIVE AN
ASSOCIATE DEGREE. THIS BILL IS
SPONSORED BY THE COUNT NAY LOS
ANGELES COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICT. AND- I WOULD LIKE TO.
I REQUEST THAT SO WE HAVE TO
SUPPORTING WITNESSES FOR THIS
BILL. THE CHANCELLOR OF THE L.
A. COMMUNICATORS DISTRICT DR
FRANCISCO RODRIGUEZ. AND A
SECOND ALEXIS SORT OF ALSO. THE
CURRENT STUDENT AT UC BERKELEY
AND FORMER STUDENT BOARD MEMBER
OF THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNICABLE
ITS BOARD OF GOVERNORS. THANK
YOU THE STORE IS TO G. WE WILL
NOW TURN TO OUR FIRST LEAD
WITNESS. A DOCTOR FRANCISCO
RODRIGUEZ CHANCELLOR LA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT-
FROM THE WITNESS VIDEO
CONFERENCE ROOM- CHANCER
RODRIGUEZ WHEN YOU ARE READY
PLEASE PROCEED.
MMHM. OKAY
RIGHT. AT&T MODERATOR COULD YOU
ON MUTE- THE WITNESSES- BUTTON
IN THE VIDEO CONFERENCE ROOM
PLEASE. THAT'S RIGHT I CAN HEAR
ME NOW I CAN HEAR YOU NOW
CHANCELLOR PLEASE PLEASE YES
SIR THANK YOU SO MUCH I GOOD
AFTERNOON MEDINA. VICE CHAIR DR
CHOI IN THIS THE MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M DOCTOR FRANCISCO
THEY GUESS I SERVE AS CHANCE
THROUGH THE LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT I'M
VERY PROUD TO STAND WITH
ASSEMBLYMEMBER MURATSUCHI LINE
WITH OUR DISTRICT AS A SPONSOR
OF THIS BILL I'D LIKE TO SHARE
VERY BRIEFLY A FIVE POINT FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION. AS TO THE
IMPORTANCE OF THIS BILL FIRST
OUR RESEARCH STUDIES HOUSE
CONFIRMED THAT INDEED THAT
MAKES THIRTIES BENEFITS STUDENT
SUCCESS. ACCELERATORS STUDENT
SUCCESS. I TAKING ONE ENOUGH
THIRTY THIRD EDUCATION OUTCOMES
IMPROVE THEIR- RATES ARE THAN
STUDENTS WHO DO NOT TAKE. THAT
THINKS THAT. SECOND I THINK
THAT IS NOT A GADUATION
REQUIREMENT FOR CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE STUDENTS
TRANSFERRING TO THE CALIFORNIA
STATE UNIVERSITY. THIS BILL
BOTH COMPLIMENTS AND IS
RESPONSIVE AND CONFORM TO THE
REQUIREMENTS OF THE SENATE BILL
FOURTEEN FIFTY SIX DR SHIRLEY
WEBER'S BILL THAT WAS PASSED
INTO LAW. LAST YEAR SO BY
HAVING ONE COURSE THAT STUDENTS
COULD TAKE AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. FOR CSU TRANSFER BOTH
SAVES TIME MONEY AND
FACILITATES THE TRANSFER
PROCESS AND TRYING TO THE
DEGREE THIRD. THIS BILL WILL
HELP TO BOLSTER THE ETHNIC
STUDIES CURRICULUM CURRENTLY
AVAILABLE AT OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WERE ABOUT 25% OF OUR
COLLEGES. DO NOT HAVE ANY OF
THE STUDIES CURRICULUM AND IN
DOING SO THIS BILL WILL HELP
DIVERSIFY HIRE MORE ETHNIC
STUDIES FACULTY. WERE LIKELY
THE FACULTY OF COLOR INTO OUR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE RANKS
SOMETHING THAT WE- SIMPLY ARE
ALSO VERY VERY INTERESTED IN
MOVING THE NEEDLE ON. FOURTH
GIVEN THE RACIAL STRIFE THAT
WE'RE EXPERIENCING THROUGHOUT
THE THIS COUNTRY. THE DEMAND
FOR RACIAL EQUITY AND JUSTICE I
THINK STUDIES PROVIDES A
CRITICAL VIEW AND UNDERSTANDING
OF OUR SOCIETY'S. HISTORY OF
RACE ETHNICITY AND CLASS AND IT
PREPARES OUR STUDENTS. FOR
TWENTY FIRST CENTURY
CITIZENSHIP IN A MULTICULTURAL
MULTILINGUAL WORLD ARE THAT
THEY WILL INHERIT FIFTH AND
FINALLY THE ADOPTION OF THE
SENATE BILL. TEN FORTY YEARS
LANDMARK IT WILL BE A LANDMARK
LEGISLATION THAT WILL ALLOW
CALIFORNIA ONCE AGAIN. A TO
LEAD THE NATION IN HIGHER
EDUCATION POLICY BY MAKING THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
LEAVE THEM AT THAT STUDIES I
THINK I'M A PRODUCT OF THE
ETHICS THAT IS MOVEMENT. HAS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MURATSUCHI. AS
AN UNDERGRADUATE AT CHICANO
STUDIES MAJOR FROM YOU DAVIS.
I'VE SEEN FIRST. OF THE IMPACT
OF THE BENEFITS- AT NYC STUDIES.
NOT TO BOOK MY PURSE HELLO. AS
WELL AS MY PROFESSION CAREER
THANK YOU DO THIS AND MRE ARE
FOR COMMITTEE COLLEGE STUDENTS
FOR THOSE THREE. I THANK YOU
FOR YOUR COULD. HOW DID YOU
RESPOND TO QUESTIONS YOU MIGHT.
AND RESPECT ASK FOR YOUR I ON
THIS THE BILL CHEN FORTY. THANK
YOU CHANCELLOR. EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR WE WILL NOW GO TO THE
SECOND LEAD WITNESS. ALEX SANTA
ROSA. IF YOU WOULD PROCEED WHEN
YOU'RE A WRECK MISTER SANTOS
THANK YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
I WILL BE FUTURE AND GOOD
AFTERNOON ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MEMBERS AT MY NAME IS ALEXIS
ACTIVITIES ERICA AND THE
PREVIOUS TICKET NUMBER ON THE
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES
BOARD OF GOVERNORS AND TRANSFER
STUDENT UC BERKELEY AS WELL AS
AN INDIGENOUS. AND SHE KIND OF
STUDENTS. BEYOND TRUTH TO
COLLEGE. WHICH IS OUR NEIGHBORS
GOING ALSO ACCEPT THE TRUTH
THAT WHILE WE HAVE TO PER
STUDENT THE MONK OUR BODY. NOT
EVERYONE GETS THE BENEFITS FROM
THAT DIVERSITY. ARE YOU CAN GO
THEIR ENTIRE COLLEGE CAREER NOT
TAKING A SINGLE CLASS AND RACE
GENDER OR CULTURE. IF YOU
THINKING TO YOURSELF I DIDN'T
HAVE A CLASS ON THAT I STILL
HAVE TO BE I TURNED OUT FINE.
THE TRUTH IS THAT MANY OF THE
SAME PEOPLE WHO DO NOT SEE
VALUE IN ETHNIC STUDIES DO NOT
OCCUR THE BRUTALITY CAUSED BY
THE LACK OF IT. I THOUGHT
TECHNICALITY WHEN IT WAS
BROUGHT HOME AN INDIAN
HEADDRESS. MY CLASSMATE ON
THANKSGIVING. COOL I CALLED MY
GRANDMOTHER TO BE BROUGHT TO
TEARS. I THOUGHT THAT THE TALLY
EVERY TIME I WALKED OVER STOLEN
HUMAN REMAINS BURIED UNDER UC
BERKELEY BECAUSE FOR YEARS
THERE ARE PEOPLE SAYING I DON'T
SEE A PROBLEM. I THINK
TECHNICALITY EVERY TIME I HAVE
TO CORRECT A PROFESSOR WITH A
PHD IN YEARS EXPERIENCE I'M A
REAL HISTORY OF OUR LAND. AND I
AM TOLD I AM LONG WINDED NINE
HISTORY. I THOUGHT IT WOULD
HAVE ALREADY IN THE POLICE
FORCE BORN ONLY FIVE MILES AWAY
FROM THE THIRD LARGEST WHITE
SUPREMACIST GROUP IN THE NATION.
WALKED AWAY FROM MY COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. THIRTY ONE CLOSER BUT
I PUT OUR E. IN THE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE WHO CAME UP TO ME AFTER
JUST ONE PRESENTATION ON THE
SAME ISSUES IN ONE CLASS THANK
THANK YOU I HAD NO IDEA HE
TAUGHT ME SO MUCH. IMAGINE NOT
ACROSS ALL OF OUR SYSTEM. IF WE
TRULY VALUE DIVERSITY AND
EQUITY WOULD FIGHT TO ENSURE
OUR STUDENTS OF COLOR HAVE
TAKEN FIREMAN WHICH INCLUDES
ENSURING THOSE WHO DO NOT LOOK
LIKE I. THINK LIKE A AND HAVE
THE EXPERIENCES WE DO YOU
UNDERSTAND THE WORLD OUTSIDE OF
HIMSELF. EDUCATION NOT DOES NOT
ONLY HAVE THE POWER TO INVITE
YOU TO HAVE THE POWER TO SAVE
LIVES. WITH THAT I STRONGLY
URGE YOU ALL TO MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU MR
GARCIA. NOT SEEN ANY ONE
PRESENT HERE IN THE CHAMBERS
WE'LL GO TO OUR PHONE LINES.
EIGHTEEN TEAM MODERATOR. AND I
WE FOR WE STARTED I THINK WE'LL
JUST TAKE. A FIVE WITNESSES IN.
IN SUPPORT AND FIVE WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION- MISTER
MODERATOR. SO WE COULD GO NOW
TO THE PHONE LINES. FOR OUR
FIVE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
THANK YOU OF OUR FIRST LINE IS
GOING TO BE ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR
LINE IS OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD.
NINE ONE EIGHTEEN YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. X. LINE
UP ONE TWENTY NINE YOUR LINE IS
OPEN PLEASE GO AHEAD. GOOD
AFTERNOON REBECCA GONZALES
NATIONAL ASSOCIATION OF SOCIAL
WORKERS CALIFORNIA CHAPTER IN
SUPPORT. NEXT LINE UP IS ONE
FORTY YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. YES GOOD
AFTERNOON MR ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
MY NAME IS MARKLEEVILLE SITES
ARE I AM A GOVERNING BOARD
MEMBER AT THE PALOMAR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICT AND MEMBER OF
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE TRUSTEES BOARD.
STRONGLY SUPPORT AB TEN FORTY
THANK YOU. EXLINE OPEN IS ONE
THIRTY SEVEN YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GO AHEAD PLEASE. MICHAEL YOUNG
ACTOR CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS HERE IN SUPPORT.
EXLINE IS ONE SIXTEEN YOUR LINE
IS OPEN GO AHEAD PLEASE. MISTER
CHAIRMAN MANAGED VIA WHEN THE
FIRE THAT. THEY EVER AGREED TO
MAKE POLITICS REQUIREMENTS AND
SUPPORT. OUR NEXT LINE IS
THIRTY NINE YOUR LINE IS OPEN
GO AHEAD PLEASE. BOB TOPEL
PACKAGE NEAR THE COLLEGE STRONG
SUPPORT AB TEMPORARY. THIS
RUNNER OF WE CAN GO NOW TO OUR
FIVE WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
THANK YOU. LEX LINE OPEN IS ONE
THIRTY TO ONE THIRTY TWO GO
AHEAD PLEASE. ONE THIRTY TWO
YOUR LINE IS OPEN. ONE THIRTY
THREE YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO
AHEAD PLEASE. ONE THIRTY ONE
LINERS. MY NAME IS CASEY GET
CONNECTIVITY AND THE INTER
CONTINENTAL MEETS UP WITH
ANYTHING. FORTY LINE ONE THIRTY
SIX YOUR LINE IS OPEN GO AHEAD
PLEASE. THIRTY SIX YOUR LINE IS
OPEN GO AHEAD. THERE IS NO
RESPONSE FROM ONE ONE THIRTY
SIX- THAT'S THE LAST QUESTION
THAT WE HAVE IN THE QUEUE
PLEASE CONTINUE. NO OTHER
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. WE
HAVE NO WITNESSES QUEUED UP AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU- TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. MR LOW. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH MISTER CHAIR THANK
YOU VERY MUCH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RESEARCH YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
AFFORD I TO I JOIN IN YOUR
COMMENTS ABOUT BEING A PRODUCT
OF ETHNIC STUDIES AND
SPECIFICALLY ASIAN AMERICAN
STUDIES AS I SHARED WITH YOU TO
THAT ACTUALLY A QUICK THE
MASTER'S PROGRAM IN ASIAN
AMERICAN STUDIES AT SAN
FRANCISCO STATE TO RUN FOR
PUBLIC OFFICE AND SO I FEEL
LIKE THIS IS A CONTINUATION OF
IMPORTANT WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE
DONE ESPECIALLY AS IT RELATES
TO THIS MOMENT IN TIME- ON
SOCIAL JUSTICE SO. I WOULD HOPE
THAT I MIGHT BE ABLE TO BE
ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR AND IF IT
ALREADY HASN'T BEEN MOVED LIKE
MOVE THE BILL AS WELL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS. MR
LEVINE. YEAH THANK YOU VERY
MUCH MR MEDINA AND I HAD AN
EXTENSIVE CONVERSATION WITH THE
AUTHOR ABOUT MY CONCERNS WITH
THIS BILL I'M NOT GONNA BE ABLE
TO SUPPORT IT TODAY I. HAVE
VOTED FOR ETHNIC STUDIES
REQUIREMENT BOTH- IN COLLEGE AS
WELL AS IN K. TWELVE. I WAS
VERY INTERESTING AND CONTINUES
TO BE VERY INTERESTING AND
PAINFUL EXPERIENCE- ON. THE
DEVELOPMENT OF THE CURRICULUM
ON THE ON THE K. TWELVE THAT'S
NOT MY CONCERN HERE FOR
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. I AGREE WITH
ALMOST EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN
SAID ABOUT THE VALUE. OF THE
AND I THINK STUDIES IN THE ROLE
IT PLAYS IN ALSO. THE
BENEFICIAL ASPECTS THAT HAS FOR
STUDENTS. I'VE TAKEN A NUMBER
OF ETHNIC STUDIES AND GENDER
STUDIES COURSES WHEN I WAS AT
COLLEGE AS WELL- IN IN. I
REFLECT ON THAT AND- I EVEN AS
I INTRODUCED LEGISLATION THAT
TOUCH ON ON THOSE TOPICS TODAY.
YOU KNOW. PUBLIC DECADES LATER.
AND AND I AM CONCERNED ABOUT
KIND OF THE PATCHWORK APPROACH
WE'VE BEEN TAKING WITH ETHNIC
STUDIES WE HAVEN'T REALLY.
THOUGHT ABOUT THIS. FROM A
HOLISTIC STANDPOINT ABOUT WHERE
WE MAKE SURE. CALIFORNIANS
REALLY UNDERSTAND CALIFORNIA
AND OUR COUNTRY AND WE'RE WE
DELIVER THAT EDUCATIONAL
CONTENT AND WE'RE IT IS MOST
APPROPRIATE WE'VE BEEN DOING IT
AGAIN PATCHWORK PIECEMEAL HERE
WE'RE GONNA TRY IT HERE AND
THERE AND PROBLEMS HAVE ARISEN
ALTHOUGH I THINK THAT THEY CAN
BE WORKED OUT TO TAKE TO
REALLY- GET TO THAT THAT THAT
THE ETHIC OF WHAT WE'RE LOOKING
FOR FROM ETHNIC STUDIES. AND
I'M NOT SURE OF THIS QUITE DOES
IT FOR ME IN THIS INSTANCE ODD
BECAUSE I THINK THAT EVERY
STUDENT SHOULD HAVE I THINK YOU
MADE THIS POINT IN YOUR OPENING
PRESENTATION- AND IT'S A VERY
GOOD POINT- THAT EVERYTHING
SHOULD HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY. TO
TAKE THIS COURSE A COURSE THAT
FEELS THE THIS GOAL AND- AND I
AGREE WITH YOU A 100% AND I
THINK THAT YOU KNOW I ATTENDED
PIERCE COLLEGE ONE SUMMER- YOU
KNOW- IN AND TOOK A COURSE IN
ITS FINAL WATER RESPECTFULLY
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THEY SHOULD
ABSOLUTELY- PROVIDE THIS
COURSEWORK FOR STUDENTS THAT
WANT TO TAKE IT. BUT I CAN SEE.
AS WELL YOU KNOW I WENT TO CAL
STATE NORTHRIDGE- THE FIRST.
CHICANO STUDIES PROGRAM IN THE
NATION- WORLD RENOWNED IN ITS
ETHNIC STUDIES PROGRAMMING. BUT
I COULD SEE WANTING TO GET TO
NORTHRIDGE TO REALLY TAKE A
DEEP DIVE INTELLECTUALLY. ON MY
ETHNIC STUDIES COURSE COURSE
WORK AND THIS COULD BE FOR ANY
ANY INSTITUTION. AND SO I COULD
SEE A REASON NOT TO KNOCK OUT
SOMETHING IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IF I DON'T WANT TO.
BECAUSE I DECIDED TO DO IT
LATER IN IN THE CSU- OR TO TAKE
IT IF IT IS MY CHOICE AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE BUT AGAIN NOT
THAT WOULD BE MORE ON A CHOICE
ISSUE AND THEN I'VE GOT.
BROADER. INSTITUTIONAL CONCERNS
ABOUT- THE PURGATORY THAT IS
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FOR SO MANY
STRUGGLING CALIFORNIANS THAT
WANT TO GET IN THERE TO
ACCOMPLISH A GOAL TO FURTHER
THEIR LIVES TO GET A JOB TO GET
ON TO HIGHER ED. IN INCOMPLETE
A- A POST SECONDARY DEGREE- AND%
THAT WE ARE MAKING IT EVEN MORE
STIFLING MORE DIFFICULT MORE OF
A STRUGGLE MORE OF A DELAY MORE
OF A WAIT- A MORE OF A- FIVE A
BLOCK TO GETTING THEM WHERE
WHERE THEY WANT TO GO AND SO- I
YOU KNOW I'M GONNA VOTE NO ON
THIS TODAY I'VE GOT ALL OF
THESE CONCERNS. I YOU KNOW I
I'M SURE YOU'RE GONNA CONTINUE
WORKING ON THIS BILL SO I WILL
KEEP AN OPEN MIND- BECAUSE
AGAIN I APPRECIATED THE POINT
YOU MADE IN YOUR PRESENTATION
ABOUT EVERYONE SHOULD HAVE AN
OPPORTUNITY. AND I AGREE WITH
THAT AND I BELIEVE THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE HAS WORKED.
DILIGENTLY AND OVER TIME
WHETHER IT'S K. TWELVE FOR HIRE
READ TO MAKE SURE THAT THERE IS
AN ETHNIC STUDIES- COMPONENT IN
A STUDENT'S EDUCATION. AT
LEAST. TWICE IN THEIR LIVES
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR
MULVANEY MISTER BLOOM. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR- I DON'T WANT
A REPEAT- MANY OF THE- POINTS
THAT WERE JUST MADE BY OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM MORAN- BUT I
SHARE- BOTH HIS ASSESSMENT OF
THE IMPORTANCE OF THIS
CURRICULUM AND IT WAS A CO
AUTHOR OF OUR CHAIRS BILL- OVER
THE PAST COUPLE OF YEARS- SO I
BELIEVE IN THAT- BUT I ON ALSO
CONCERNED ABOUT HOW IT FITS
INTO THE OVERALL- CURRICULUM-
IN A TWO YEAR PROGRAM- WHERE
IT'S REALLY FAST PACED AND-
STUDENTS ARE FREQUENTLY VERY
GOAL ORIENTED- AND HAVE TO MAKE
CHOICES ABOUT COURSES. AND OF
MAY CHOOSE TO PRIORITIZE- OTHER
THINGS AND SO WHEN WE REQUIRE
OF COURSE IT I THINK THERE'S A
LITTLE BIT OF A BUTTERFLY
EFFECT THAT TO- AT THE COULD
OCCUR HERE BUT- I- WILL SUPPORT
THE BILL- TODAY AND- AND HOPE
THAT- WE CAN CONTINUE TALKING-
I KNOW WE'LL CONTINUE TALKING.
ABOUT THIS TOPIC BECAUSE IT'S
AN IMPORTANT ONE AND- I LOOK
FORWARD TO THAT CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU. MISTER MURATSUCHI
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I APPRECIATE TO
YOU KNOW THE COMMENTS IN THE
FEEDBACK FROM ALL OF MY
COLLEAGUES ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES- IN THIS COMMITTEE-
I DO WANT TO- THE SPECIFICALLY
KNOWLEDGE SOME OF THE- CONCERNS
RAISED BY A MR LEVINE- YOU KNOW
I. RECOGNIZE MANY OF THOSE
CONCERNS BECAUSE I HAD- I RAISE
MANY OF THOSE SAME QUESTIONS
WHEN IT WHEN I WAS. APPROACHED
BY THE- COMMITTEE COLLEGE L. I.
COMMITTEE COLLEGE DISTRICT- ON
WHETHER TO TAKE THAT THE BILL
ON I KNOW THAT- YOU KNOW ONE OF
THE BIG CHALLENGES FOR
COMMITTEE COLLEGE IS- IS TO GET
OUR- OUR- OUR OUR STUDENTS TO-
TO GET THEIR DEGREES IN EITHER
TRANSFERRED OR TO. TO GET THEIR
ASSOCIATE DEGREE OR TO GET
THEIR THEIR CERTIFICATES OR
TRAINING THAT THEY'RE LOOKING.
A FROM COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND-
YOU KNOW IT'S A BALANCING ACT
IN TERMS OF- WHETHER WE- SHOULD
BE ADDING EIGHT EIGHT EIGHT A
NEW REQUIREMENT OR NOT.
ORIGINALLY I HAD THE BILL. TO
REQUIRED JUST FOR ASSOCIATE
DEGREES FOR TRANSFER. IN ORDER
TO ALLOW- YOU KNOW THE ONE
THIRD OF CSU STUDENTS. THAT
THAT TRANSFER FROM COMMUNICABLE
AS HIS. TWO TWO S. AND THE- LOS
ANGELES CHANCER INDICATED TO
SAVE TIME AND MONEY. BY BEING
ABLE TO SATISFY THE ETHICS AS
REQUIREMENT AT COMMUNITY
COLLEGE BEFORE THEY TRANSFER.
TO- CAL STATE UNIVERSITY. BUT
YOU KNOW AND- ALSO
ACKNOWLEDGING THAT THE CONCERN
THAT WAS RAISED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS ABOUT. YOU
KNOW WHETHER THERE WAS AN ISSUE
OF- OF ACADEMIC FREEDOM. IT WAS
ACTUALLY THERE THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ACADEMIC
SENATE THAT- INDICATED THAT
THEY WANTED TO MAKE THE
REQUIREMENT BROADER OF FROM NOT
JUST STATE REQUIREMENT FOR
ASSOCIATE. DEGREES FOR TRANSFER
BUT FOR ALL STUDENTS- SEEKING
AN ASSOCIATE DEGREE. AND SO
THAT- YOU KNOW IS THE REASON
WHY WE BROUGHT IN IT FOR THE
ASSOCIATE DEGREE SO I WANT TO.
MAKE SURE ALL THE NEW THAT-
THIS MADE THIS BILL MAY
ULTIMATELY. NOT BE NECESSARY
ULTIMATELY THEY THE COMMUNIQU
IS ACT SENATE MADE TO ADOPT
THEIR OWN AT AS QUORUM. BUT- IN
A ORDER TO. CONTINUE PUSH FOR
MORE. YOU KNOW EDUCATE UP TO
EDUCATE TO- IN PREPARE OUR
STUDENTS- AT ALL LEVELS HIGH
SCHOOL COMMUNICABLE IS-
UNIVERSITY. TO DEAL WITH THE-
THE CHALLENGES OF AND THE
OPPORTUNITIES OF DIVERSITY IN
IN OUR STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS WHY I AM OKAY OF
PUSHING FORWARD WITH THIS BILL
AND I WOULD RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR IPHONE. THANK YOU MISTER
MURATSUCHI WHEN I THANK YOU
ALSO FOR ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS AS OUTLINED ON PAGE
FIVE. OF THE ANALYSIS AND THANK
YOU ALSO FOR YOUR VERY ELOQUENT
PRESENTATION. OF THE POWER. OF
ETHNIC STUDIES THE POWER OF
CHANGING LIVES AND BEFORE WE
VOTE I JUST WANT TO SHARE. A
STORY THAT I READ AND PERHAPS A
PROFESSOR THAT YOU MAY HAVE HAD
AT CAL. RON TO KHAKI SOMEONE
WHO HAD A BIG INFLUENCE OF ME.
RUN TO COCKY. A PROFESSOR OF
HISTORY FIRST. FEATURE OF
BLACK- STUDIES BLACK HISTORY AT
UCLA BEFORE GOING TO CAO TELLS
A STORY OF HOW HE GOT OUT OF
THE TAXI- IN WASHINGTON DC GOT
INTO A TAXI WAS GOING TO GIVE A
PRESENTATION. AND THE TAXI
DRIVER YOU KNOW JUST MAKING
CONVERSATION ASK RON TAKAKI
WHERE HE WAS FROM. YOU KNOW AND
I THINK- HE USES THAT HE
EXPLAINS THAT THAT COMMENT FROM
THE TAXI DRIVER. RUN TO CATCH
HIS FAMILY HAD BEEN IN HAWAII
FOR GENERATIONS AND SO THAT
QUESTION LIES TO THE ROOT OF
WHO IT IS THAT'S AN AMERICAN
AND HOW ARE WE PERCEIVED. AS
AMERICANS AND SO I THANK-
MISTER MURATSUCHI FOR BRINGING
THIS BILL FORWARD AND ASKED IF
I CAN BE ADDED AS A CO AUTHOR.
THANK YOU SIR- DO WE HAVE A
MOTION. MOTION BY MISTER LITTLE
SECOND BY DOCTOR RUMBLE- AND
THEN SECRETARY WOULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO
PASS AS A MENTOR TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA HIGH CHOI. ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM. BLOOM HI
GABRIEL IRWIN KILEY LEVINE
LEVINE NOW LOW. LOW I RUBIO
RUBIO I SANTIAGO CALAVERAS WELL
THERE IS NO. THANK YOU THE BILL
IS FIVE TO SEVEN CALL THE BILL
IS ON CALL WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS-
BECAUSE OF THE SHORTAGE OF TIME
I'M GOING TO HOLD A HEARING A.
B. SEVEN FIFTY SIX SO THAT WE
CAN GO ON TO BILLS THAT ARE ON
CALL AND WE WILL PULL AB SEVEN
FIFTY SIX CHILDREN NEXT
HEARING. SO MADAM SECRETARY IF
WE COULD GO TO BILLS ON CALL.
OKAY ITEMS SIX AB. TWELVE SIXTY
NINE. ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI
GABRIEL IRWIN KILEY LEVINE.
LEVINE I SANTIAGO VALLADARES.
CALAVERAS HIGH. THE VOTE IS
EIGHT ZERO.
THE ITEM NUMBER
EIGHT AB TWELVE NINETY.
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA HI GABRIEL
IRWIN KILEY LEVINE LEVINE I.
SANTIAGO VALLADARES VALLADARES
I. THE VOTE IS. EIGHT ZERO. THE
BILL IS OUT. I ITEM NUMBER NINE
AB EIGHT FOUR SIX. ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI GABRIEL IRWIN KILEY
LEVINE LEVINE I SANTIAGO. THE
VOTERS. FIVE TWO. TWO ONE FOUR.
YEAH THE BILL'S ON CALL. ITEM
NUMBER TEN AB FOURTEEN THIRTY
TWO. CHOI GABRIEL IRWIN HIGHLY.
RUBIO RUBIO I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO HI. THE VOTE IS EIGHT
ZERO BILL IS OUT. ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN AB NINE FOUR ZERO. CHOI
GABRIEL. IRWIN KILEY KILEY I
RUBIO RUBIO I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
HI. THE VOTE IS NINE ZERO NINE
ZERO BILL IS OUT. ITEM TWELVE
AB TWELVE FIFTEEN CHOI GABRIEL.
IRWIN KILEY KILEY I RUBIO RUBIO
I SANTIAGO SANTIAGO I. THE VOTE
IS NINE ZERO NINE ZERO BILL IS
OUT. ADAM THIRTEEN AB. THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN. CHOI GABRIEL
IRWIN HIGHLY KILEY I. RUBIO
RUBIO I SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I'D.
THE VOTE IS NINE ZERO. NINE
ZERO BILL IS OUT. ADAM FOURTEEN
AB FOURTEEN NINETY ONE. CHOI
GABRIEL IRWIN KILEY KILEY I.
THE VOTE IS NINE ZERO NINE ZERO
BILL IS OUT. I AM SIXTEEN AB
TEN FORTY CHOI. GABRIEL WHEN.
HIGHLY HIGHLY NO. SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO I BALLADARES- BUILDERS
IS NOW. THE VOTE IS. SIX THREE.
LEAVE THE BILL ON CALL LEAVE IT
ON CALL. IT THE CITY. THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. GABRIEL IRWIN
IRWIN I HIGHLY KILEY I LO LO I
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO II. THE VOTE
IS ELEVEN ZERO ELEVEN ZERO
CONSENT CALLER IS OUT. AND THIS
JUST GO BACK AND FILE ORDER
AGAIN. JACKIE ON THE DIFFERENCE
DOESN'T PICK IT UP. NUMBER.
SEVEN YEAH GOOD WE STILL HAVE
SOME VOTE ON ALL. YES. THREE
ITEM NUMBER NINE. AB EIGHT FOUR
SIX. GABRIEL IRWIN IRWIN I
KILEY KILEY NARROW SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO HI. THE VOTE IS EIGHT
THREE EIGHT THREE THE BILL IS
OUT. ITEM NUMBER SIXTEEN AB TEN
FORTY. CHOI GABRIEL IRWIN IRWIN
I. THE VOTE IS. SEVEN THREE.
ADELIZA. ALL OUT ON THE TWENTY
ADELINE. OR JUST JACQUI NGUYEN
AT AND ON. YEAH OKAY THE ITEM.
ONE EIGHTY SEVEN SEVEN FIVE
GABRIEL IRWIN IRWIN I HIGHLY
HIGHLY I LOW LEVEL I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I'D. ELEVEN OF THEM I
DON'T WANT THEM SIGNATURE. WAS
THAT ITEM ONE YES. HI GABRIEL
OKAY THE VOTE IS TWELVE ZERO.
THAT BILLS OUT OKAY THE RESULT
OF A ITEM TO ITEM TWO AB TEN
SEVEN THREE GABRIEL. GABRIEL I
IRWIN. IRWIN YEAH FIVE IRWIN I
KILEY KILEY I LOW LEVEL II
SANTIAGO. SANTIAGO I THE VOTES
TWELVE ZERO LOSE OUT ITEM THREE
AB TWO THREE THREE GABRIEL
GABRIEL I IRWIN IRWIN I HIGHLY
KILEY I LO LO HI SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO HI THE LOTUS TWELVE
ZERO. ITEM FOUR EIGHTY THIRTEEN
EIGHTY THREE ARAMBULA. GABRIEL
GABRIEL I IRWIN IRWIN I HIGHLY
HIGHLY HI SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI
THE VOTE IS ELEVEN ZERO. ITEM
SIX AB TWELVE SIX NINE GABRIEL.
APRIL I IRWIN IRWIN I HIGHLY
KILEY NARROW. SANTIAGO SANTIAGO
I. THE VOTE IS ELEVEN ONE
WITHOUT. ITEM EIGHT AB TWELVE
NINETY. APRIL GABRIEL I IRWIN
IRWIN I KILEY KILEY I SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI THE VOTE IS TWELVE
ZERO WITHOUT ITEM. NINE EIGHTY
EIGHT FOUR SIX. GABRIEL. APRIL
I. THE VOTE IS NINE THREE
BILLION DOLLARS. I AM TEN AB
FOURTEEN THIRTY TWO CHOI
GABRIEL GABRIEL I IRWIN IRWIN I
HIGHLY HIGHLY I. THE VOTE IS
ELEVEN ONE AT. ELEVEN ZERO
ZERO. ITEM ELEVEN EIGHTY NINE
FORTY CHOI GABRIEL GABRIEL I
IRWIN IRWIN I. THE VOTE IS.
ELEVEN ZERO. ITEM TWELVE AB
TWELVE FIFTEEN CHOI GABRIEL.
NOT VOTING- ONE IRWIN I. THE
VOTE IS TEN ZERO BILL IS OUT.
THE ITEM THIRTEEN AB THIRTEEN
SEVENTY SEVEN CHOI. GABRIEL
GABRIEL I IRWIN IRWIN I. THE
VOTE IS ELEVEN ZERO BILL IS OUT.
ADAM FOURTEEN EIGHTY FOURTEEN
NINETY ONE CHOI. GABRIEL.
FOURTEEN NINETY ONE. APRIL I
IRWIN IRWIN HI THE VOTE IS
ELEVEN ZERO. ITEM IN SIXTEEN
EIGHTY TEN FORTY CHOI. GABRIEL
IF YOU IF YOU WANNA READ. APRIL
NOT VOTING. ONE THE VOTE IS
SEVENTY THREE YES. NEWS VOTED
YES. THAT THAT THAT'S ALL. OKAY.
DURING THANK.